Mein Streamingrechner ist gerade abgeschissen.
Ist das schlecht?
Sehe ich keinen Chat?
Sekunde, muss den Rechner erstmal neu starten.
Äh, Tastatur?
Ist mein Streamingrechner abgeschissen?
Einfach so random.
Einfach RIP.
Press F.
Einfach weg, Vara.
Schneller als man F pressen kann, Vara, weg.
Ich muss nochmal schnell, ist eh noch keiner da, ich muss nochmal schnell mein Headset entwirren.
So, Headset ist entwirrt, perfekt.
Äh, ich muss warten bis der Streamingrechner wieder gestartet ist.
Dann sehe ich wieder was, sonst sehe ich nichts.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt hier den Chat auf, dass ich überhaupt was sehe.
So.
Streamingrechner.
Er kriegt nicht ein Windows.
Ihr seht es auf dem zweiten Bildschirm gerade nicht, ich kriege gerade irgendwie 50.000 Popups.
Das ist irgendwelche Updates.
Die Updates fehlgeschlagen sind.
Der Rechner war überhaupt nicht an, ich weiß gar nicht wann er versucht hat Updates zu machen.
Hier Leute.
Sign up to experience the best of Wobblors.
So sieht es aus Leute.
Sign up.
Give follow.
Give sub.
Daddy can't subscribe für zwei Monate.
Dankeschön, nice.
Ich kann leider nichts drücken gerade, weil mein Streamingrechner noch nicht am Start ist.
Ich muss erstmal 50 Popups wegklicken, dann, dann, dann vielleicht, ja.
Ja.
Jetzt, hä?
Ah.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Jetzt funktioniert es.
Sehr schön.
Quit.
Erstmal ganze Popup weg.
Skype.
Warum habe ich überhaupt Skype noch?
Welches Skype da installiert?
Der Witcher Soundtrack ist mir gerade zu, zu relaxing.
Wir brauchen, wir brauchen was anderes, ja.
Jetzt auch, auch ja.
Witcher 3.
Music.
Full Soundtrack, ne.
Das ist ein bisschen zu.
Zu, zu anstrengend.
Ähm.
Hm.
Was haben die denn hier zu bieten?
Relaxing.
Wir brauchen irgendwas für den Hintergrund.
On how, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Also wirklich.
Oh, das, die, die hatten den best, besten Soundtrack.
Beste.
Huge DLC.
Perfekt.
Passt.
Übrigens, ähm, ich bin ja immer noch der, ah, jetzt funktioniert es.
Jetzt sehe ich euch auch die, die, die Vorschau.
Ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung, dass der erste Witcher 3 DLC eines der besten Storys ist, die je ein, ein Studio game-technisch auf dem Bildschirm gebracht hat, ne.
Hohoho.
Ah, jetzt ist es schon ein bisschen, nicht, nicht ganz so, nicht ganz so lahm.
Vielleicht ein bisschen leiser.
Perfekt.
So.
Jetzt klappt es auch.
Wir auf einen Schlag jetzt alle Leute ankommen, weil Switch gecheckt hat.
Haha.
Twitch ein bisschen gebraucht.
Ähm, ja, wir, wir können mal gucken.
Wenn die Witcher-Musik zu nervig ist, dann passt.
Äh, übrigens, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, äh, meine Frage.
Wer ist, ja, ja, habt ihr, habt ihr alle, ähm, den Switcher gespielt?
Habt ihr, habt ihr alle den Witcher 3 mal gespielt irgendwann?
Äh, aber zumindest mal eine Frage an die, an die Leute, die Witcher 3 gespielt haben.
Was ist...
Okay, Tuning Pack, geh fort.
Was ist eure Lieblings, ähm, Quest?
Also, ich meine jetzt nicht, ich meine jetzt nicht, es muss keine kleine Quest sein.
Ihr könnt meinetwegen sagen, ähm, keine Ahnung, die Quest mit Triss in Novigrad.
Oder ihr könnt sagen, die Main Quest oder der erste DLC-Main Quest.
Irgendwas, keine Ahnung.
Was, was, was war eure Lieblingsquest?
Also, ich muss ganz klar sagen, für mich ist es die Platin-Wine-Main-Quest.
Joma mit der Pfanne.
Hehe.
Also, für mich ist es eindeutig die Platin-Wine-Main-Quest.
Die ist richtig gut.
Und ich krieg immer noch, ich krieg ja immer noch fast Albträume.
Hier, wartet mal.
Ähm, Children's Song.
Es ist, es ist alles, es ist alles gruseliger, wenn das irgendwelche Kinder singen, ne?
Na, der Sound, der Sound ist schlecht.
Ja.
Der Dude hier.
Bestes, bestes, bestes Theme im Game und ich find auch die, die beste Main Quest ever.
Ja.
Da, da kriegste, da, da, da kriegst schon fast Albträume von, ähm.
Das ist, das ist wirklich einer der besten, äh, wie soll man sagen, er ist, er ist nicht wirklich, er wirklich, er ist nicht wirklich so Antagonist, so einer der besten, ähm, tja, wie nennt man das so?
Ja, Gegner auch nicht wirklich.
Ja.
Ähm, weiß ich gar nicht, wie man das nennt, so einer der besten Bösewichte, aber hier, das, das Theme von, von hier ist wirklich top.
Genau, der Teufel.
Michael, dankeschön, vier Monate, huge.
Das Schlimmste an Witcher 3 ist, dass es, äh, vorbei ist.
Ich hab das jetzt zweimal durchgespielt und mir reicht's eigentlich, aber ich würd's gern nochmal durchspielen, aber es gibt leider nicht mehr Content.
Und das Spiel hatte schon unglaublich viel.
Es hat noch unglaublich viel Content.
Auch das Ende von dem DLC, ich mein, ich kann jetzt mal ein bisschen spoilern, das Game ist von 2015.
Das Ende vom DLC ist auch mega geil.
Wenn er, wenn er dann einfach so, einfach so random mit dem, mit dem Totenkopf wegläuft.
Und, und vor allem sein, sein, sein eigenes Musik-Theme pfeift.
Ich find das übelst gruselig gemacht.
Aber wahrscheinlich muss man die Story gespielt haben.
Beste, beste DLC.
Ich kann euch sagen, wer das noch nicht gespielt hat, ähm, also, zumindest den Blood & Wine DLC, den müsst ihr unbedingt spielen.
Beste.
Äh, nicht den Blood & Wine DLC.
Ich mein, Heart of Stone.
Warum erzähl ich die ganze Zeit Blood & Wine?
Schwachsinn.
Heart of Stone hat so, ja, voll durcheinander gebracht.
Ich mein, Heart of Stone müsst ihr unbedingt spielen.
Eines der besten, ich hab die ganze Zeit Blood & Wine gesagt, die, eines der besten Quests oder einer der besten Storylines, die ich bisher in Games gesehen hab.
Was'n heute dran? Ja, genau.
Ich wollte erst mal warten bis...
Oh, der Hype-Train läuft, Leute.
22 Prozent.
Huge.
Lohnt es sich, Witcher 3 zu spielen?
Ja!
Du wirst kaum nen Game kriegen...
Für den, mittlerweile ist es ja oftmals runtergesetzt.
Du wirst kaum nen Game kriegen, wo du für 29...
Na gut, ich glaube, für 50 Euro so viel Singleplayer-Content und vor allem so viel guten Singleplayer-Content kriegst.
Der Scam-Train ist am Start, ja.
Gibt's nicht.
Also, mir fällt kaum ein anderes Singleplayer-Game der letzten Jahre ein.
Übrigens, Stripes hat abonniert, dankeschön, hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ähm...
Mir fällt kaum ein anderes Singleplayer ein, was für 50 Euro so viel Content bietet, was in den letzten Jahren erschienen ist.
Tainser ist auch am Start, hab ich auch wieder nicht gesehen hier.
Eieieiei.
Der Zugucker ist auch da, sechs Monate.
Ja, und wenn ihr mal auf einen Sale wartet, ist es eigentlich noch viel besser, dann ist es nochmal eine ganze Ecke günstiger.
Warum genau sollte man sich eigentlich den Expansion Pass kaufen, wenn man doch die Sachen auch so...
Was auch immer, vollkommen egal.
Ihr solltet's auf jeden Fall spielen.
Der Hype-Train ist erfolgt...
Erfolgreich.
Stufe 1.
Emotes.
Dankeschön.
Huge.
Der Scam-Train war erfolgreich.
Habt ihr's eigentlich mitgekriegt?
Jetzt, wo wir gerade sind, hier bei Twitch.
Habt ihr's eigentlich mitgekriegt, dass, ähm...
Dass Overwatch...
Jetzt auf YouTube streamt.
Seit ein paar Tagen ist das, ist das raus.
Als Hintergrund eignet sich der Witcher-Soundtrack tatsächlich nie so gut.
Der ist entweder zu nervig...
Oder zu...
Zu relaxing.
Ähm...
Aber, so ein geiles Spiel und so ein geiler Soundtrack, äh...
Das ist...
Welche Software findest du am besten...
Um Full-Images einer Maschine zu erstellen?
Musst ihr ehrlich sagen, ich hab ewig, wirklich ewig keine Full-Images mehr erstellt.
Ich hab früher mal Clonezilla verwendet, aber das war irgendwie auch ziemlich der Crap.
Davor hab ich auch mal mit Windows, hab ich mit Ghost und Akronis True-Image rumgewurstelt.
War alles Müll.
Ich mach mittlerweile gar keine Full-Backups mehr.
Irgendwie kann sich ja Witcher-Soundtrack nicht entscheiden, wie laut's sein soll.
Ähm...
Ich mach mittlerweile gar keine Full-Backups mehr.
Mit, ähm...
Komplettem System-Image.
Ich mach Backup von den wichtigsten Sachen.
Und, ähm...
Wenn man das gemacht hat, so was neu zu installieren, ist ja kein großer Akt.
Das dauert 20 Minuten.
Ähm...
Ich kann...
Da kann ich dir leider nichts Gescheites zu sagen.
Für Full-System-Images.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ähm...
Das war ja ein größerer Deal.
Blizzard verlagert die gesamte Serverstruktur von Amazon AWS zu Google.
Ja, ich hab's mitgekriegt.
Da ist richtig viel Kohle geflossen.
Wobei ich sagen muss...
Ähm...
Ganz ehrlich, ich hab eh schon relativ wenig Overwatch League geguckt.
Ich hab eh schon relativ wenig Overwatch League geguckt.
Aber für mich ist es vorbei.
Also ich guck auf...
Ich werd...
Also ich guck garantiert nicht auf...
Ähm...
Auf YouTube jetzt irgendwie Overwatch League.
Und ich hab hier von...
Auf Twitter gelesen...
Weil Hearthstone...
Äh...
Hearthstone wurde ja auch umgewurstet jetzt auf YouTube.
Und einer der bekanntesten Hearthstone-Caster hat gestern irgendwas gepostet...
Ja...
Ähm...
Dass die...
Dass der Viewcount...
Übelst Müll ist.
Auf YouTube.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht...
Da hätte man ja nie drauf kommen können vorher.
Wer hätte das nur erahnen können, dass der Viewcount Crap ist auf YouTube.
Aber da ist so viel Kohle geflossen.
So viel Kohle geflossen.
Das ziehen die jetzt durch.
Äh...
Leider.
Ähm...
Ich hab ab und zu ganz gerne mal Overwatch League noch geguckt.
Aber das ist jetzt vorbei.
Ich guck das garantiert nicht auf YouTube.
Und ich mein, wenn man sich hier anguckt...
Ähm...
Hier.
80%
80% weniger Viewer auf YouTube als auf Twitch.
Das ist schon hart, oder?
Äh...
Der Martin hat sein Abonnent gewechselt...
Sein Abonnement gewechselt.
Huge.
Big Brain Entscheidung.
Näh.
Das ist halt...
Das ist halt Fail.
Und dann kommt noch dazu, dass Blizzard irgendwie nicht ordentlich Werbung macht.
So.
Ich...
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz die Fragen aus dem Chat noch durchgehen.
Und dann erzähl ich euch, was wir heute mal ausprobieren.
Weil ich hab hier einen gefundenen Blog.
Nextcloud-Hub.
Es kam vor ein paar Tagen...
Es kam vor ein paar Tagen eine neue Nextcloud-Version raus.
Und die machen...
Die haben einen riesen...
Jaja.
Klar behalten hier.
Ähm...
Die haben einen riesen Aufriss gemacht.
Hier auch marketingtechnisch.
Dass sie jetzt eine Alternative sein wollen zu Office 365.
Unter...
Unter anderem.
Unter dem, was sie sonst noch so alles machen.
Und...
Ich wollte schon mal...
Mir das seit einer Weile wieder angucken.
Was da draus geworden ist.
Es hört sich...
Übrigens.
Es hört sich so an, als sagt die Perry...
Guck mal hier.
Haha.
Da hat sie auch geschrieben hier.
Perry.
Das war in...
Das war in Witcher 3 tatsächlich OP.
Äh...
Perry Counter.
Da konntest du alles mit ownen.
Haha.
Der Soundtrack kann es ja echt nicht entscheiden, wie laut und leise er sein soll.
Genau.
So.
Ich muss mal kurz Streamfragen gucken.
Ähm...
Eiskräuter.
Das stimmt.
Ähm...
Die...
Viewerzahlen von der OWL waren eh schon nicht so gut.
Und es war auch massiv...
Also zumindest...
Ich mein...
So wirklich Belege habe ich dafür nicht.
Und hat auch wahrscheinlich sonst keiner.
Aber...
Mal rein aus Aktivität.
Von...
Über Reddit.
Über den Chat.
Über alles.
Weil so...
Drüber hat es sich nicht angefühlt wie ein Stream, der 120.000 Zuschauer hat.
Ich weiß nicht, wo die Zuschauer alle hergekommen sind.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Blizzard View botted hat im eigentlichen Sinn.
Aber in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein bisschen geboostet.
Den Eindruck hat das Ganze schon gemacht.
Aber OWL ist halt auch so ein Ding.
Das kann nicht...
Das darf nicht...
Nicht...
Und selbst wenn man mehr Geld reinsteckt als es bringt...
Ja...
Aber das ist voll...
Das ist RIP.
So ich muss jetzt mal schnell hier noch die...
Die Fragen aus dem Chat mir angucken.
Laufen auf deinem NAS auch LXC Container?
Ähm ich hab da...
Ich hab da...
Ja!
Ja...
Ja.
Also würden, würden, würden ohne Probleme laufen.
Ich hab aktuell 5 Docker Geschichten drauf laufen.
Unter anderem halt hier Nextcloud.
Äh...
Ein Wiki.
Einen File Server und ähhh...
Einen Content Cloud oder so.
einen Container, der andere Container aktualisiert,
die Base-Images
und
eine Übersichts-Webseite
und weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, was noch.
Ich glaube, reicht gar nicht.
Ich glaube, ein bisschen mehr.
Müsste gerade mal nachgucken.
Fünf, sechs Sachen.
Ja, ja.
So, gucken, dass ich keine
Subs übersehen habe.
Hm, nix, oder?
Ich habe nix mehr übersehen.
Habe ich irgendwas übersehen, Leute?
Ach doch, hier, der Michael50Billian
hat gefragt, Max, wenn du dich eigentlich
dazu entscheidest, weniger zu arbeiten,
im Stream zu hören, öfters, naja, ich arbeite ja schon weniger.
Ja, aber ob ich jetzt wirklich mal irgendwie
auf drei Tage rede, das ist hier keine Ahnung.
Ich würde ja auf der einen Seite gerne,
aber auf der anderen Seite auch nicht.
Ich bin da unentschlossen irgendwie.
Noch, noch.
Lastsünd.
Ja, ich habe mir so ein Ding hier gekauft.
Das wollte ich nämlich heute mal ausprobieren.
Also, was wir heute vorhaben, ist Folgendes.
Was wir, was,
was wir heute ausprobieren, ist Folgendes.
Ich habe einen Raspberry Pi 4 hier.
Ich habe mir so ein komisches, vor einer Weile schon mal so ein komisches
active, gekühltes Gehäuse gekauft.
Das habe ich zusammengebaut und ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen,
ey, was, Plattchat?
Wo ist Plattchat?
Ja, hier, richtig, richtig Plattchat, Alter.
Richtig Plattchat.
Ich dachte dazu nur,
don't talk in chat, unless you are
high elo, SR2000
plus failfish.
Um mal aus meinem,
äh,
Overwatch Meme TXT Dokument vorzulesen.
Plattchat, genau.
Erstmal Sub only Chat.
Na, sowas mache ich nicht.
Ähm, wollen wir SR-Schwanzvergleich machen?
Wenn ihr, wenn ihr, wenn ihr,
lasst mal, lasst mal überlegen, was war denn
mein höchster SR in Overwatch?
Ich glaube, 4200 oder 4100?
Irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, schon so lange her.
So, ähm, wow.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht Kauf auf Rechnung.
Geh fort.
Also, was wir, was wir, wie gesagt,
ich habe mir so ein komisches Gehäuse gekauft,
habe ich heute Morgen zusammengebaut
und ich kann euch gleich schon sagen,
kauft dieses Gehäuse nicht, das Gehäuse ist Müll.
Ähm, man sieht es hier nämlich gar nicht.
Das besteht aus so, doch, man, hier sieht es mal gut,
das besteht aus so komischen Platten.
Die, die legt man übereinander, macht dann Schrauben drüber.
Das Problem ist, dass die,
also, ich habe es ja noch nie erlebt,
dass ein Zusammen, dass das Zusammenbau
von so einem billigen Gehäuse derartig kompliziert ist.
Die haben sogar ein eigenes Video dazu gemacht.
Wie man das Ding zusammenbaut,
weil die Leute unfähig waren.
No aim, no brain, Winston main.
Nice.
Hier, Installationsvideo.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal das Installationsvideo an.
Das ist grausam.
Ja.
Passt mal auf, wie kompliziert,
wie unnötig kompliziert der Zusammenbau
von einem Gehäuse ist.
Der Switcher muss mal kurz die Klappe halten.
Guckt euch mal an, wie unnötig kompliziert
der Kram ist.
Habe ich vorhin unten,
habe ich mich unten in die Küche gesetzt
und habe den Kram zusammengebaut.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich habe, glaube ich, für so ein Publisher,
ich habe 20 Minuten gebraucht, bis das funktioniert hat.
Und dann hatte ich den Lüfter noch falsch rum dran.
Weil der Lüfter, waren sie ja auch so wahnsinnig clever
und haben an dem Lüfter keinerlei Markierungen,
in welche Richtung der Luftfluss ist.
In dem, hier guckt mal, in diesem Dokument,
in dem Dokument steht drinnen,
wie rum man den Lüfter,
wie rum man den Lüfter machen muss
für richtigen Luftfluss.
Allerdings der Lüfter selbst hat keine,
hat keine Pfeile, wie der Luftfluss ist.
Total crap.
Crap Gehäuse.
Kauft euch das bloß nicht.
Wenn ihr euch ein gutes Raspberry Gehäuse kaufen wollt,
dann kauft euch,
Moment,
dann kauft euch das da.
Das ist gut.
Da wollte ich mir auch noch eins kaufen.
Alles, was ich bisher gesehen habe an Videos und sonst was drüber,
ist das hier wohl mit das beste Gehäuse,
was man sich,
was man sich kaufen kann.
Das ist auch passiv gekühlt.
Ist, äh, verteilt quasi die Hitze komplett
über das ganze Aluminium Gehäuse.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal,
pass mal auf, wie unnötig kompliziert der Kram ist.
Äh, choose my name.
Du hast es,
du hast es ja wenigstens gemerkt.
Wir hatten bei uns im Rechenzentrum,
hatten wir Switche falsch rum eingebaut.
Der Lüfter falsch rum.
Und es gab laufend irgendwelche Alarme.
Bis die Leute dann irgendwann mal auf die Idee gekommen sind, so, hups,
der Luftfluss ist ja falsch rum.
Jetzt guckt euch mal an, wie kompliziert,
wie sinnlos kompliziert das ist, dieses Gehäuse zu suchen.
Zusammenzubauen.
Vor allem, was für ein kleines Micromanagement
gefuddelt das ist.
So, Alter, mach die, mach die Schrauben raus.
Ah.
Guckt mal hier. Guckt euch das mal an.
Für so ein poplisches
Kackehäuse.
Was ist das? Was ist mit denen los?
Ist das Lego?
But why? Warum kann man nicht
einfach was machen, wo man den Raspberry Pi
reinklipst und gut ist?
Sieht's gut aus? Ne, sieht noch nicht mal gut aus.
Wartet mal. Äh,
ähm,
Playback-Speed.
Wir gucken dir mal so zu.
Bisschen, bisschen, bisschen schneller.
Es ist echt, guck, das ist, das heißt, du kommst
dir wirklich vor, als baust du Lego zusammen,
anstatt so ein Raspberry Pi-Gehäuse.
Es ist ohne Probleme
handelbar. Ich hab's ja auch in 20 Minuten gemacht.
Ähm, aber es ist halt echt
schon ein bisschen übertrieben kompliziert für so
ein kleines Popelgehäuse.
Oh, da hab ich jetzt den Lüfter falsch
rum dran gemacht.
Erstmal.
Weil kein Pfeil drauf ist
auf dem Lüfter, in welche Richtung der Luftfluss ist.
Ich kenne keine Lüfter, die
keine Pfeile haben. Bis heute.
So, und wenn das Ganze
fertig ist, dann...
Ich hab's an 3,3 Volt angeschlossen.
Ne, den Lüfter hörst du gar nicht. Null.
Also ich hab ihn auch an 3,3 Volt angeschlossen.
Den Lüfter kannst du an
3,3 Volt oder 5 Volt anschließen.
3,3 ist dann langsamer, aber reicht.
Wir gucken uns auch gleich dann mal die Temperaturen
vom Raspberry an.
Ähm, und dazu kommt halt, dass
das Gehäuse nicht mal gut aussieht.
Guck dich mal das Gehäuse an.
Also es ist ziemlicher Crap
zusammenzubauen.
Es kostet
relativ viel.
Es ist Crap zusammenzubauen
und es sieht hässlich aus. Also
nehmt lieber, nehmt lieber das hier.
Nehmt lieber das hier.
Ohne Mist. Das ist rund
beste, beste Case.
Wenn du willst, Michael, können wir das machen.
Ja.
Können wir machen.
Luftfluss ist doch eigentlich immer dort, wo der Motor
sitzt, Richtung Sticker. Ja, hab ich auch
so eingebaut, aber
ich hats halt die
die Platte falsch rum.
Hier ist ja die Platte, wo er
das drauf macht.
Und ich hatte die Platte anders rum gedreht.
Ich hab's so angebaut,
wie der hier gemacht hat, allerdings
anders rum. Der Luftfluss war prinzipiell
schon richtig, aber
die Platte war falsch rum.
Also auch falsch.
Muss ich nochmal abmachen. Also ich find's
Gehäuse nicht gut.
Genau. Und was ich mir geholt
hab, ist, die hab ich ja schon ne Weile hier rumliegen.
Die 970 EVO
1TB. Dann hab ich mir
dieses Pi-Gehäuse geholt.
Raspberry Pi 4. Aber Michael,
erinnere mich nochmal dran,
nicht, dass ich das nachher vergesse.
So, und da hab ich mir dieses
Ding geholt, wo man, da kann man
die SSD reinmachen. Ich hab
allerdings das doofe Gefühl,
ich hab's nämlich vorher mal kurz
angestöpselt, dass es nicht
richtig funktioniert. Man sieht das hier gar nicht,
wie's innen aussieht.
Ich hab das Gefühl, das wird nicht
richtig funktionieren.
Weil,
gucken wir mal, ob man das hier irgendwie von innen sieht.
Ja, so ungefähr sieht das von innen
aus. Das ist halt einfach so
ein Board, wo man eine M2 SSD draufmacht.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass das gut funktionieren
wird, weil, ich hatt's vorhin mal kurz
angeschlossen für 5 Minuten, bin aufs Klo gegangen,
bin wiedergekommen. Ey, das Gehäuse hat
geklüht. Oder fast geklüht.
Ich hab's in die
Hand genommen und ich hab mich nicht verbrannt,
aber es war schon unangenehm heiß.
Also die NVMe
SSD wird da ziemlich
hot drinne, ja.
Das heißt, was wir jetzt machen
ist, ich schnapp mir jetzt erstmal
eine Micro SD Karte
und nebenbei können wir schon mal das aktuelle Raspbian
downloaden. So, ich hab
mir nämlich ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben, die wir machen.
Während das ganze downloadet und flashet,
gucken wir uns nämlich mal das
Werbevideo
an von
von
Nextcloud, was sie alles tolles, neues haben.
Und dann könnt ihr euch ja mal überlegen, Chat,
hier, wo haben wir's?
Der Chat kann sich mal überlegen,
wie wir Nextcloud installieren wollen.
Also, wir haben die Auswahl zwischen,
wir können einfach ganz
normal ein Raspbian installieren
und das mit
Office-Alternative sag ich gleich nochmal was.
Wir können einfach
ein Raspbian installieren und darauf
mit dem offiziellen Installer-Script oder
meinetwegen auch von Hand
den Kram installieren.
Nextcloud ist PHP-Kram.
Wir können aber auch,
also wir könnten einen LXC-Container machen,
wir könnten einen Docker-Container machen
oder wir könnten
einen Docker-Compose-File machen mit
Nextcloud, was das Ganze dann für uns
anlegt. Und das Ganze
checken wir doch irgendwie in Git ein oder so.
I am root.
Twitch Prime. Zwei Monate. Dankeschön.
Big brain sub.
Docker auf dem Raspberry Pi. Das funktioniert
absolut problemlos. Funktioniert wunderbar.
Ist überhaupt kein Ding.
If your Raspberry Pi
will not boot.
Was?
Ich hoffe, der bootet.
Ok, download. Raspbian.
Hast du schon mal Docker
und CUDA zusammen... Ne, hab ich noch nichts zusammen gemacht.
LXC und darin dann
Docker mit Nextcloud. Ne, das ist zu...
Das ist zu nested.
Es funktioniert.
Man kann in LXC ohne Probleme nested
dockern, aber das ist dann
doch zu übertrieben.
Was sollte man mit einem Pi nicht machen?
Naja, als Desktop-Ersatz taugt er nicht sonderlich
gut. Es sei denn,
man kommt damit aus, dass man
ziemlich lahm webbrowst
und ein bisschen E-Mails liest und ein bisschen
Instant Messenger macht. Ansonsten ist
halt alles, was Datenbank ist, auf dem Raspberry Pi
nicht so der Wahnsinn, wenn man das mit der
Onboard-SSD-Karte
macht und man ein bisschen
I.O.
braucht. Nicht so toll.
Aber nachdem
man an einem aktuellen Raspberry jetzt auch
eine SSD anschließen kann,
gibt es eigentlich nichts
so richtig Grundlegendes, was man auf dem Raspberry
Pi nicht machen kann.
Der Raspberry Pi ist auch ein super
Übungsteil,
wenn Leute ein bisschen
rum-experimentieren wollen mit
Cluster-File-Systemen oder irgendwelchen
Distributed-Storage-Geschichten
wie Ceph oder wenn Leute
ein bisschen hier
Kubernetes-Cloud-Geschichten, Cloud-Hype
Hyperscaler
habe ich ja letztens gelernt, als ich das Ganze
ein bisschen üben wollte. Dafür ist das eine super
Plattform. Es gibt eigentlich nichts, was
du da grundlegend nicht drauf
machen kannst.
Wo der Raspberry
Pi halt relativ schnell
schlapp macht ist, wenn du da Sachen drauflaufen
lassen willst mit mehreren Usern
gleichzeitig und was halt
ein bisschen Performance braucht.
Dann nicht. Zum Beispiel, wenn du
Home Assistant für Heimautomatisierung
drauflaufen lassen willst, läuft das
ganz gut, aber wenn da viele
Sachen drin sind, wenn viel gelockt wird
und sonst was, da kommt der Raspberry Pi
relativ schnell an seine Grenzen.
Stimmt, ja, wenn die
Docker-Images nicht für arm sind, dann geht's nicht.
Das ist klar. Aber
Nextcloud geht ohne Probleme.
So, ähm, wir wollten eigentlich
mal schauen, was ist denn das?
Habe ich das jetzt schon gedownloadet?
Was ist denn das da oben für ein Knopf?
Äh, habe ich das jetzt schon
downloaded oder nicht?
Firefox. Wo habt ihr jetzt neulich die Downloads
versteckt? Hier irgendwo, ne?
Das ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich mich permanent
drüber beschweren könnte.
Dieses Menü. Ich meine, sind wir auf
dem Desktop oder sind wir auf dem Tablet?
Was ist hier los?
All thin clients für einen Terminal Server.
Kann man machen, da läuft ja selbst auf dem
Tablet.
Was ein bisschen doof ist, ist,
wenn du
Linux drauf verwendest oder wenn du das halt
für Linux-Clients machst,
Linux hat halt keine gescheiten
äh, keine gescheiten grafischen
Remote-Fähigkeiten.
Du kannst zwar so Sachen machen,
wie VNC oder ein bisschen
bisschen besseres VNC,
was, äh, Teile
von der Grafikkarte verwendet.
Du kannst, äh, die billigste Variante ist
SSHX-Forwarding, aber
das ist nichts im Vergleich zum Beispiel
was Microsoft neuerdings hat
mit ihrem, äh, kompletten
3D-beschleunigten Remote-Desktop
oder auch was beispielsweise
ähm,
VMware anbieten kann mit
durchgereichten Grafikkarten oder auch
ähm, Citrix und so was.
Da gibt's nix in der
Richtung. Wenn man einfach nur
eine Oberfläche braucht, die irgendwie geht, mag das
ganz gut funktionieren.
Was verwendest du denn, Umut?
Was nimmst du denn als
ähm, Oberfläche für
deine Terminal? Oder meinst du mit
Terminal-Server wirklich Text? Aber wahrscheinlich
meinst du schon GUI, oder?
XRDP ist tatsächlich ganz okay, ja.
Äh, äh, X2Go ist auch ganz
nett, aber das kann man leider, leider
hat's halt immer noch, braucht's
noch ne Weile, bis es da ist, wo
die anderen sind, die ich da grad erwähnt hab.
Funktionieren tut's
gut. Ich hab auf der Arbeit jahrelang,
äh, X2Go verwendet.
Funktioniert
wunderbar. Je nachdem.
Je nach Desktop. Okay, also, Moment,
ähm, wir wollten das ganze flashen. Wo hab ich,
ich brauch mal ne SD-Karte. Wo ist
meine SD-Karte? Hier, huge.
Wobei, kann man
die, kann man die Raspberry Pis nicht mittlerweile
sogar von USB booten?
Raspberry Pi 4
booten mit
ohne SD-Karte von
USB. Easy, zeig her.
Pi 4 hat noch keinen USB
Boot, das heißt, das Video ist gamas.
Stimmt, ja, du hast recht.
Hab ich letztens sogar gelesen. Das Video ist gamas.
Okay, wir skippen mal kurz
drüber, was der, was der Typ macht.
Okay, es ist schon mal Windows.
Magma...
Bonk, KS! Bonk, KS!
Alter, was ist da los?
Seht ihr das gleiche, was ich auch sehe?
Es ist Magenta Cloud.
Das ist die, das ist die erste
Usage von Magenta Cloud so,
so in the wild, die ich, die ich je gesehen
hab.
Okay, machen wir weiter. Was, was macht der denn?
Dateipunk...
Was, was treibt der da?
Was macht der da?
Funniest... Was macht der denn da?
Ich, ich, was macht, was, was,
was macht der da?
Torrent?
Er ist schon im Internet 6.0 und...
Ach!
Jetzt check ich, was der macht.
Der richtet die SD-Karte so ein, dass sie dann USB
bootet. Ja, das ist ja noob.
Das kann ich auch. Ja?
Man kann natürlich von der, man kann natürlich quasi
den Bootmanager, wenn du das so willst, starten von der
SD-Karte, der dann die, äh,
USB bootet. Ja, das, das
geht natürlich.
Aber dann kann ich auch gleich von der SD-Karte
booten und einfach meine SSD
mounten später. Das macht dann keinen
großen Unterschied, weil die SD-Karte,
die verreckt halt genauso beim Stromausfall
ganz gerne mal. Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was der da treibt. USB
Boot Raspberry Pi 4. Gibt's
da, gibt's da irgendwas?
Forum Raspberry.
Was, Evelink auf dem,
was ist das?
Hier, zeig mal.
Ah.
USB?
Was genau?
Sonoff, die, wer benutzt denn einen Sonoff
bitteschön, ohne ihn zu flashen?
Gibt's, gibt's da, gibt's wirklich Leute,
die das machen?
Ja, anscheinend, anscheinend derjenige, der das Video aufgenommen hat.
Ja, genau.
Das funktioniert. Du kannst die Bootpartition
auf der SD belasten, die Rootpartition
auf die, ähm,
SSD verfrachten. Okay, wir machen,
jetzt erst mal Standard. Wir flashen den Kram jetzt erst mal
stinknormal auf die
Micro-SD-Karte.
Wenn ich sie in den Card-Reader reinkriege.
Hallo.
Ich krieg die Micro-SD-Karte nicht in meinen
Reader rein. Funktioniert
nicht. Ah, jetzt.
Perfekt. Ah, yes.
Excellent, excellent.
Auf USB.
Connect. Jawoll.
Zack.
Add-Sure.
Was?
Hab ich nicht.
Add-Sure ist kaputt. Warum?
Add-Sure ist RIP.
Okay.
Installieren wir mal neu.
Äh, ist das eine Linux-VM auf einem Windows-PC?
What the fuck, Alter?
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Äh, wisst ihr was, Leute? Ich, ich, ich, ich, ich
remove das mal kurz. Ich weiß nicht, was der da
für, was der da für Schmerzen grad hat.
Es sieht, es sieht auf jeden Fall
kaputt aus. Ich mein, wir können's
auch die Dehnen, ja?
Das ist eigentlich überhaupt kein Unterschied. Aber
warum geht das nicht? Ich glaub, ich muss mal ein Update machen.
Ich glaub, ich muss mal updaten.
Ich hab schon lange, ich hab schon lange die VM nicht
mehr geupdatet. Wir machen das jetzt einfach
mal. Oh, was?
Konflikt.
Ah, yes. Excellent.
What?
Oh je.
Was hat der denn für Schmerzen?
Ah, das ist ein Q5.
Okay.
Weißt du was, wir machen jetzt den Loop-Style, wir deinstallieren das einfach.
Oh.
Braked was? Cura!
Na gut, brauch ich die eh nicht. Kann weg.
Weg.
Ich will hier eh nichts
3D drucken in der Stream 4M.
Yes.
What?
LibDMX?
What the hell? Was willst du von mir?
Was ist das? Warum hab ich das überhaupt installiert?
Hab ich das, hab ich gar nicht installiert.
Ja.
Wir installieren den Kram jetzt einfach mal.
Weg damit. Zack.
Jetzt aber. Darf ich jetzt updaten?
Yes. Excellent, excellent.
Jetzt funktioniert's.
X-Server kaputt. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist, was ich da eigentlich grad
deinstalliert hab. Warte mal, müssen wir jetzt mal gucken.
Wo ist denn?
Hab ich nicht ordentlich copy-pasted?
Ja. Was ist das überhaupt?
DXDMX.
DXXDMX.
Das ist unter Linux
Das ist alles auch immer so schön benannt.
XtremeMultiHead.
Ach, da kann man
Da kann man verschiedene
Monitore zusammen zu einem großen machen.
Okay.
Widescreen, ja. XtremeMultiHead.
6Head.
Fast schon 11Head.
Das, was Chillfreaks sagen.
Wieso? Ich hab's jetzt deinstalliert.
Ich brauch den Kram eh nicht.
Oje, es installiert Java 8.
Monkeys.
Ja, lassen wir ihn mal installieren.
Und alles nur um ne SD-Karte zu flashen.
Ich mein, wir könnten die SD-Karte auch DDen, ja.
Ugym. 7 Monate.
11Head.
Aber sowas von. Leider hab ich
Leider war ich so blöd und hab mir mein
Programm eingebaut,
dass es, ähm,
Aspect Ratio immer gleich lässt. Sonst könnte ich jetzt
einen 11Head machen hier.
Aber es geht leider nicht.
Weil der den Kopf nicht skaliert.
Low Programming Skills.
Hat nicht gereicht.
Allerdings muss man sagen, es ist komplizierter.
Äh, so zu machen, dass die,
dass, äh, ne, das
Seitenverhältnis beibehalten wird, als einfach nur
immer gleich groß wie Fenster
zu machen. Also eigentlich ist
die Implementierung von mir
mehr 5Head, als wenn ich
jetzt einen 11Head machen könnte.
Falls man mir überhaupt noch
irgendwie folgen kann, was ich grade überhaupt sage.
Max, kannst du bei Twitch Top Cheerer
und Top Geschenkgeber einstellen?
Also,
das ist ja zur Zeit nur Top der Woche.
Wäre Top of all time nicht besser.
Ähm,
ich kann das mal gucken.
Die Sache ist bloß die,
ich hab das bei mir ausgeblendet,
ich seh das gar nicht.
Ich hab hier Dings, ich hab hier FFZ installiert
und ich hab in FFZ und
by the way, das kann ich jedem auch nur empfehlen
zu machen. Sollen wir jetzt nicht so laut sagen.
Ähm,
ich hab alles ausgeschaltet in FFZ.
Twitch Overlays sind ausgeschaltet.
Donator sind ausgeschaltet, Cheerer
sind ausgeschaltet, alles ausgeschaltet. Ich seh nix.
Das einzige, was ich seh, ist Chat mit
allen Emotes bei der Twitch TV FFZ
und Stream. Fertig.
Beste.
Den ganzen Crap, der da
mittlerweile rumspukt auf Twitch, was
irgendwelche Stream Overlays angeht,
irgendwelche Voting-Geschichten, irgendwelche
anderen Sachen, die den Chat halt blocken.
Der Hype-Train,
alles weg.
Ich brauch eine puristische Viewing
Experience. Ja.
Camtrain.
Ähm, ist jetzt
der Soundtrack fertig?
Es ist übrigens Musik an, falls man das nicht hört, aber
wisst ihr was, wir machen ein bisschen Wupp Wupp Wupp.
Wupp Wupp Wupp geht immer.
So, Wire, warum hab ich denn
überhaupt WireGuard installiert hier drauf?
Haben wir mal zusammen WireGuard installiert, Leute?
Kann das sein? Wir haben mal im
Stream WireGuard gemacht, ne?
Schon mal Chatarino 2 ausprobiert.
Ne.
Was ist Chatarino 2? Chatclient
for Twitch. Ich will das im Browser haben.
Wenn ich das nicht im Browser hab, ist doof.
Ich will das neben
Browser sehen im Stream.
Doch doch, ich glaub wir haben WireGuard mal im Stream, da kann
nämlich gleich hier, WireGuard
weg.
Kann man eigentlich sowas hier machen?
Ne, na das geht nicht.
WireGuard.
Man konnte ihm doch aber sagen,
ja den ganzen Mist,
alles fort,
istisch alte.
So, und jetzt reboote ich mal,
ich bring jetzt die aktuelle Kernel-Version alles drauf.
Gucken, was wir für ein Kernel installiert
haben.
5.4, das ist LTS, passt.
Reboot.
Du wolltest doch mal WireGuard-Tutorial
machen, wollte ich das? Wir haben uns das im
Stream zusammen angeguckt, ziemlich sicher.
Ich glaub wir haben nen Raspberry oder wir haben
uns ne, haben wir uns nicht ne Digital
Ocean VM gemacht dafür?
Und dann irgendwie WireGuard
VPN oder sowas? Ich kann mich
da nicht mehr dran erinnern, ich mein, ich bin jetzt
auch schon ein paar Jahre hier am Start, ich kann mir das auch nicht
alles merken, was wir alles schon gemacht haben, aber ich glaube,
ziemlich sicher haben wir WireGuard schon gemacht.
So.
Muss mal gucken. Alles, alles nur
um ne SD-Karte zu, zu dingsen, ne?
Ja. Install.
Jawoll. Ah, yes.
Ach guck Leute, jetzt funktioniert's.
Easy. Wir brauchen ja erstmal
ne 500 MB RAM verwendeten,
500 MB RAM verwenden,
damit man ne SD-Karte flashen kann. Muss,
muss sein. Excellent.
Outplayed.
Perfect Image.
Das Ding bescheuert.
Wo geht denn das hier auf? Soll nicht hier aufgehen.
Soll gefälligst hier aufgehen.
Wie heißt das WireGuard? Ich hab kein WireGuard Video gemacht.
Ich hab nen, wir haben nen
Stream, wir haben das im Stream installiert. Ziemlich sicher.
So. Haben wir das Richtige?
Transcend,
Boot, RootFS. Okay, da ist schon irgendein
Raspbian Zeug drauf wahrscheinlich. Egal.
Flash. Bam. Wow.
Okay.
Warum geht denn das heute alles nicht richtig?
Was ist heute los?
Was ist denn heute? Was ist denn heute kaputt?
Kann das sein, dass der
Download kaputt ist?
Ne, ne, ZIP muss man nicht entpacken.
Das Ding ist schlau
genug, das kann den Kram selbst
entpacken.
Okay, wir laden's nochmal neu runter.
Vielleicht ist der Download
kaputt gewesen.
Geht ja schnell. Guckt euch das mal an.
Easy. 30 MB die Sekunde.
Das ZIP muss man nicht entpacken.
Gibt's nen speziellen Grund, warum du
Tritzen benutzt und nicht J?
Ich glaube der ursprüngliche Grund
war, weil Tritzen
die gleichen Kommandozeilen
Parameter backwards
hatte wie Jaurt
damals und
weil es schöne farbige Ausgabe hatte.
Also seht ihr, manchmal bin ich auch absolut
noobstyle bei der Auswahl von Software.
Einfach was, was
ich bedienen kann, wie das alte und
hübsche Konsolenausgabe hat, nämlich
jetzt aber.
Was?
Was hat der denn für
Schmerzen?
Default Windows.
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Dann doch den DER.
Was ist mit dem los?
Kann das sein, dass das Ding irgendwie versucht
irgendwelche Magic
irgendwas zu mounten oder so?
Dass der im Hintergrund
irgendwas mountet?
Wo ist es denn?
Nö.
Der versucht nichts zu mounten?
Das hatte ich noch nie.
Was ist das Problem?
Wir könnten, wir könnten
mal gucken. Also wenn man gucken
will, ob man was richtig runtergeladen hat,
macht man da einfach mal eine
eine
Hashware drüber und gucken uns das an.
Was sagen die denn hier? Haben die hier
hier, Schad 256, bra ma.
Und dann mal
vergleichen.
Ist das richtig? Guckt hier.
Richtig. Na dann dedehnen wir den Kram.
Doch. Meinetwegen.
Ich weiß nicht. Fragt mich nur, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Dedeh beste.
Kann das sein, dass du Edger mit Zudo...
Habe ich das nicht gemacht?
Das muss ich machen. Ja. Ja, ja.
Na klar habe ich das nicht gemacht.
Ich habe es hier drüber gestartet. Ja logisch.
Ja Leute, ihr habt recht. Muss das mit Zudo starten, sonst geht es nicht.
Korrekt.
Chat.
Huge.
Wahnsinns Chat
wieder hier.
Big brain.
Deluxe.
Chat.
Guckt, jetzt geht es auch.
Jetzt kommen mir die ganzen Besserwisser wieder an, ey.
Ja man,
nicht das hier. Oh, mach doch ein anderes
Kommando.
Ich glaube, ich habe das mit Zudo
Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen sogar mal im Video gezeigt.
Aber das ist einfach ein Unterschied
zwischen, man weiß, dass es prinzipiell
existiert, zu
ähm...
Man denkt jedes Mal dran.
Moin, Bulldilo.
Huge Fehlermeldung von Edger.
Ja, das wäre auch sinnvoll,
wenn das Ding fragen könnte, so nach dem
Motto, ah, Rootberechtigung.
Weil, eigentlich
müsste es das können.
Ich habe doch auch Dings hier.
Wenn ich hier versuche, etwas zu installieren,
das geht glaube ich auch, guck mal.
Ah, ne.
Ich lasse es jetzt mal bleiben.
Ich müsste so ein grafisches Zudo-Ding
eigentlich installiert haben.
So, ist geflasht? Ne, flasht noch.
Das Zudo-i bringt doch in dem Fall
nichts.
Zudo-i kriege ich eine Root-Shell.
Jetzt gleich müssen wir Zudo-i machen.
Aber in dem Fall hat mir Zudo-i
ja nicht so viel gebracht. Ich meine, ich hätte Zudo-i machen können,
danach Edger starten, danach weiter machen
können in der Root-Shell, weil wir brauchen jetzt eh eine Root-Shell.
Und zwar, was wir jetzt machen müssen ist,
hier in der Tat Zudo-i und wir müssen
mounten. Was war das nochmal?
Äh, SDB?
Ja, ha?
SDB.
Mount.
Äh, SDB1.
So, das ist die Boot-Partition
von meiner SD-Karte.
Und weil es in Raspberry ist und wir uns
danach per SSH drauf einloggen wollen,
muss ich sagen Touch
SSH, sonst funktioniert das Ganze nicht.
Ich würde euch ja prinzipiell
per Capture Card sogar
an den Raspberry anschließen, aber
das brauchen wir nicht, weil wir werden an dem Raspberry
eh nichts, nichts machen
großartig, außer uns per SSH einloggen.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich gucke hier gerade auf dem Schreibtisch rum,
ich glaube, ich finde auch auf die Schnelle mein
äh, was ist das, Mini-HDMI
zu normalem HDMI nicht.
Das können wir nicht jetzt anschließen.
Okay, Touch
SSH, unmount den ganzen Crap.
So, fertig.
Gut, ähm,
jetzt kann ich die SD-Karte
rausholen und in die Raspberry stecken.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob das Ganze funktioniert.
Das ist übrigens
die billigste 16G
Micro-SD-Karte, die ich hab hier.
Was macht
das Sync-Command? Es stellt sicher, dass auch
alles aus dem Buffer auf
die Platte geschrieben ist.
Eigentlich brauchst du es
nach einem Unmount nicht.
Ich bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher,
dass es beim Unmount automatisch
passiert. Aber ich hab
mir das so angewöhnt.
Lustigerweise mach ich das nur unter Linux, unter
Windows bin ich noch nie
auf die Idee gekommen, sicher entfernen zu machen
vom USB-Stick.
So.
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz auf meinem Router
schauen, was das Ding
für eine IP gekriegt hat.
PiAd122682.
Moment.
141?
Ah, yes.
So.
Und was ist das Erste,
was wir jetzt machen, wenn wir uns auf dem Raspberry Pi
eingeloggt haben? Wir waren ja schon ein paar Mal drauf,
Leute. Wisst ihr es noch? Was ist das Erste, was wir machen?
Chat, enttäuscht mich nicht.
Passwort ändern. Nein, das machen wir nicht.
Update.
Ja, das ist das Zweite, was wir machen.
Das ist das Zweite, was
wir machen.
Resize. Nee.
Gut SSH deaktivieren. Nee.
Keycopion.
Spatzgranate hat gewonnen.
Weil ich hab keinen Bock immer das Passwort einzutippen.
Bam. So sieht's aus.
Spatzgranate hat offiziell
jetzt das größte Brain.
Zur Zeit. Kann sich heute noch ändern.
Im Laufe des Streams.
Huge Brain Chat heute. Ja.
Excellent Chat. Ist die Musik zu laut
oder passt so?
Kann das immer schlecht anhand von diesen komischen
Graphen erkennen, ob das jetzt
passt oder nicht? Passt.
Okay. So. Sind wir
eingeloggt. Das Erste.
Guck mal, was für ein Kernel drauf ist.
V7L.
Ah ja. Alles klar.
Update.
Haben die jetzt standardmäßig eigentlich schon
den 64 Bit Kernel?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das wird ja dann hier irgendwo stehen. Hier wird's ja wahrscheinlich
irgendwo stehen, wenn man
äh, wenn das 64 Bit
wär. Den kann man installieren.
Nicht standard. Okay.
Was muss ich denn installieren für den 64
Bit Kernel? Wisst ihr das?
Wollen wir mal ausprobieren.
Wir machen erst mal ein Upgrade.
Ah, jetzt alles upgraden.
Okay. Ne, muss ich mal gucken.
Ist der, kann man den schon verwenden?
Pi 4 64 Bit Kernel.
Install.
Raspbian Kernel for testing.
Was?
Ne.
Stimmt nicht.
Tilmun? Okay.
Oh my god. Ah ja.
Gut.
Ah, yes.
Wo?
Wo macht das denn? Hier.
Oh, das scheint mir ganz schön kompliziert
zu sein.
Das ist wohl nicht getan. Einfach nur mit
äh, apt install kernel
x64 oder sowas.
Ja, dann lassen wir's erst mal.
Für unsere Zwecke auch vollkommen unerheblich
jetzt. Bloß ein 64 Bit oder
ein 2- und 3-Bit-System ist vollkommen, vollkommen
egal, wo wir Nextcloud installieren wollen.
So.
Äh. Okay.
Was auch immer.
Okay, danach starten wir neu. Ne, danach
installieren wir erst noch mal ein paar Sachen.
Die wir eh, die wir eh brauchen.
Ach, wir haben das Nextcloud Hub
Video noch nicht gesehen. Genau.
Ich wollte euch ja erzählen, was, warum
ich Office 365 Alternative
sage. Weil, die sagen das selbst.
Morris, 7 Monate. Dankeschön.
Pock. Huge.
Ups. Falsch geklickt.
So, also weil, die werben jetzt
damit, das kam erst vor ein paar Tagen raus,
die werben jetzt damit, dass
Nextcloud heißt ja nicht mal Nextcloud, sondern
Nextcloud heißt jetzt Nextcloud Hub.
Und, ähm,
sie sind viel geiler als
bisher.
Nextcloud Hub.
Nextcloud Hub is the full content collaboration suite
to manage all your documents and communications.
Leute. Leute.
Meint ihr, das ist ein hottes Grill, was da spricht?
Worry free package, so to speak.
With Nextcloud Files
you can manage all your files and documents.
You can download
and upload.
View and edit them.
You can find everything with full text search
and by tagging.
Okay, jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst, Leute.
Jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst.
Oh, nochmal.
You can manage all your files and documents.
Das ging bisher auch schon.
You can download and upload.
View and edit them.
You can find everything with full text search
and by tagging.
Sieht aus wie immer.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich hab' gerade gesagt, die Suchfunktion funktioniert standardmäßig.
Hab' ich gerade gesagt, die Suchfunktion funktioniert
standardmäßig?
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Die Suche hat bisher nie richtig funktioniert.
Die Suche hat
nie richtig funktioniert bisher, die war immer kaputt.
Also, Volltextsuche hat noch nie-ansatzweise funktioniert.
Teilsuche ging so, aber Volltextsuche war teilweise so kaputt, dass du nicht mal deine eigenen To-Dos und Notes durchsuchen konntest nach einem Wort.
Was die Anwendung halt komplett überflüssig macht.
Wozu brauche ich eine Notizanwendung ohne Suche?
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja, ich wollte auch schon Line-Dancing. Interessiert mich persönlich auch immer unglaublich.
Unglaublich.
Was? Ey, du Nex, Stufe 1. Dankeschön.
Big Brain, Big Prime Sub.
Nee, gar kein Prime.
Gar kein Prime. Richtig.
Ein echter. Ein richtig echter. Huge. Dankeschön.
Karl und Micky.
In NexCloud Talk, you can chat with others, work on documents, and even do audio and video calls, like in a real office.
And best of all, you can even participate in the mobile phone.
Ein echter, das ist die Sprecherin in dem Video.
Bestimmt nicht, oder? Das ist Marketing.
In the NexCloud Calendar, you can manage, share and sync all your appointments with your phone and desktops.
Oh, I see right now, I need to make a quick phone call. But where is the number?
Of course.
Moment, das ist auch noch...
Ist das noch in Deutschland hier?
Brom Nürnberg to Berlin Tief.
But where is the number?
Of course. In Contacts.
In NexCloud Contacts, you can view, manage and share all your contacts.
And of course, you can also form groups based on topics.
Mach mal wieder was auf YouTube.
Ja, ich mach ein Video über Chrome Funktionen demnächst.
Ich weiß, ich hab's letzte Woche schon erzählt.
What the fuck?
Just like my life.
Pass mal auf.
Wo ist McCree, Alter?
Yeeha!
Oh, jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen.
Ja, das will ich mit mir mal heute ausprobieren.
Ihr wisst, dass ich kein Office verwende, aber ich will mal wissen, ob das auch nur ansatzweise funktioniert.
...your Office documents together with others.
Do you remember?
Karl, Paulette, Micky, here they are again.
Dom-PC, ich glaube, das ist einfach diesmal alles default dabei.
...the powerful content collaboration platform with all the features you need.
And by the way, the entire NexCloud Hub is open source and can run on-premises, so you have control over your own data.
On-premises.
Your cloud, your data.
On-premises heißt nichts anderes, als dass es auf eurem eigenen Rechner laufen kann.
Das ist ja mittlerweile...
...braucht es einen eigenen Namen, ja.
Man kann nicht einfach sagen, so nach dem Motto, ich installiere es bei mir in einer On-Premise.
On-Premise.
Und die richtig coolen Leute, die sagen nicht On-Premise, die sagen On-Prem, weil es irgendwie cooler klingt.
So, haben wir geupdatet.
Gut, äh, wie, wie, wie, achso, nee, erst mal Zeug sehen.
Also, was wir auf jeden Fall brauchen, ist mal wieder ein T-Mark, ist ein WIM.
Ähm, was brauchen wir sonst noch?
Äh, H-Top.
Ähm, was brauchen wir noch?
Was brauchen wir sonst?
Was ist noch so?
Äh, XFS, Tools, äh, keine Ahnung.
Gucken wir mal, können wir alles immer noch installieren, was wir brauchen.
Aber ein WIM-Power auf jeden Fall.
ASCII-Quarium.
Ich glaube, ASCII-Quarium ist nicht standardmäßig drinne in Raspbian.
Nano ist, äh, kann überhaupt nicht größer WIM sein, weil Nano und WIM überhaupt nicht so die, die gleiche Kategorie abdecken.
Du kannst mit beiden Basic Text bearbeiten, aber WIM ist halt deutlich umfangreicher.
Nano richtet sich halt an, an Leute, die einfach nur was editieren wollen.
Das kann man so gar nicht miteinander vergleichen direkt.
Wenn man einfach nur, einfach nur öffnen will, editieren will, speichern will, ohne sich damit zu beschäftigen, ist Nano sicherlich der bessere Editor.
Aber wenn es um Funktionen geht, kann da WIM, kann Nano WIM nicht das Wasser reichen.
Und VS Code auch nicht, weil VS Code nicht auf der Kommandozeile läuft.
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich noch so viel WIM verwende.
Einfach, weil es auf jedem Server läuft.
Und weil du mal easy irgendwelche Sachen auf der Kommandozeile editieren kannst.
Okay, wir rebooten mal schnell.
Und dann schauen wir mal.
Also, was haben wir jetzt gesagt?
Wir wollen das Ganze mit Docker installieren, ne?
Da muss ich mir irgendeinen, mit Docker, mit Docker oder wollen wir das ganz, ganz pro irgendwie mit einem Docker Compose File machen?
Aber als erstes muss ich jetzt mal meine SSD anstöpseln und gucken, ob die ordentlich funktioniert.
So.
So, sehr gut.
Ähm, wir hätten dann die 5-Head-Variante, ja.
So, ich stöpsel mal die SSD an und wir gucken uns das an.
SSD ist dran.
Das Ding müsste jetzt als 1TB Platte drin stehen, hier oben.
Da, hier.
SDA, 1TB Platte.
Also, mkfs.xfs auf dev.sda.
Da wird jetzt meckern, dass schon was drauf ist.
Und das wird überschrieben.
So.
So, SSD ist fertig.
Formatiert.
Dann können wir das Ding mal mounten.
Und mal gucken.
Warum hängt denn das beim Mounten?
Das, das, das hört sich schon mal nicht gut an.
Oder es fühlt sich schon mal nicht gut an, wenn das am Ende schon beim Mounten hängt.
Ich habe euch gesagt, das Ding, der USB-Adapter macht einen Kack-Eindruck.
Ich glaube, das spackt.
Ich glaube, das spackt rum.
Guck mal, das hängt schon beim Mounten.
Der USB-Adapter ist, glaube ich, einfach Müll hier.
Der da.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte es vorhin mal in die Hand genommen.
Ich habe mir fast die Finger verbrannt, so heiß ist die SSD.
Wir geben dem nochmal eine Chance.
Ich meine, vielleicht hat er ja beim ersten Mount, muss er irgendwelche Dinger unter der Haube noch anlegen.
Aber normalerweise ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Du formatierst das, mountest das, geht instant.
Dass es jetzt hängt, ist schon mal höchst verdächtig.
Ne, es muss nicht SDA1 sein.
Ich habe direkt auf das Device das Ding formatiert.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Okay, wir gucken mal kurz ins Log rein.
Ah, was ist das hier?
Device Reset.
Oh, das liest sich nicht gut, Leute.
Ah, er hat gemountet, guck mal.
Keine Partition angelegt.
Nö, wozu?
Ne, Partition overrated.
Gebaited.
So, okay.
Was haben wir?
Touch.
Cute.
Chat.
Eieiei.
Anscheinend funktioniert der Kram jetzt.
Okay.
So, dann schauen wir doch mal, was die Festplatte so hergibt.
Über USB.
Erstmal PV installieren.
Wir schauen mal, wie schnell das Ganze ist.
Wir gucken mal kurz, wie schnell das Ganze ist.
Hier, blub.
Bin.
Wie schnell ist die SSD?
Die ist, äh...
Wöh!
Habe ich gemountet?
Ja, sie blinkt.
Äh.
Leute, der Adapter hat Schmerzen.
Wie sag ich euch?
Das Spackt rum.
Oh, ja, ja, ja.
Moment, ich brauche den passenden Sound dazu.
Ich brauche den passenden Sound dazu.
Ah.
Yoshi.
Moment.
Nein.
Ich brauche den...
Eieieieiei.
Wo gibt es den Sound?
Nein, das nicht.
Den Sound gibt es irgendwie nicht.
Eieieiei.
Okay.
Ha.
Sound.
Ne, leider finde ich den Sound nicht.
Ähm.
Eieiei.
Das Spackt ein bisschen rum mit dem Adapter, würde ich sagen.
Das sieht, das sieht, das sieht nicht gut aus, Leute.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Und die SD-Karte ist.
Wie verrückt am blinken.
Ich, ich, ich.
Ich lege da mal meine Hand drauf.
Ich gucke mal wie, wie, ähm.
Wie warm das Ding wird.
Also, das ist ziemlich warm.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es daran liegt.
Ne, ich habe nicht.
keinen anderen M2 Adapter mehr, aber
ich hab noch massig USB auf
SATA, also
ich mach da einfach ein normales SATA SSD dran
und gut ist, jaja, ich hab
noch genug da, also daran wird es nicht scheitern
dass es nicht funktioniert, aber es könnte
auch sein
es könnte auch sein
dass es irgendein Bug ist
mit diesem USB
Dings
was auch immer dahinter steckt, hier diesem
wo steht es denn hier
hier diesen UAS Treiber
Geschichten, haben deine SATA
Adapter ein Netzteil, ich hab eins mit Netzteil
ich hab welche ohne Netzteil, für SSDs
geht eigentlich das ohne Netzteil
es ist
es ist nicht, das sieht nicht gut aus hier Leute
ähm
wow
warum ist der
warum ging das jetzt auf einmal
ok
das sieht nicht gut aus
also entweder
ist meine SSD im Arsch
das glaub ich nicht
oder das spackt rum mit dem Adapter
ich gehe davon aus es spackt rum mit dem Adapter
achso
ähm
das
vielleicht ist die jetzt im Arsch
nee, nee, nee, nee
man kann das doch bestimmt
Linux Disable U
ja
wie deaktiviert man den Kram
wie deaktiviert man das
was?
ähm
Adapter mal woanders testen
kann ich machen
nee kann ich nicht machen
weil äh
in der VM macht der Adapter
spacken diese Sorte Adapter auch rum
das weiß ich, also das hab ich schon ausprobiert
in der VM mag er das auch nicht
und in der VM hatte ich ähnliche Probleme
deswegen weiß ich, man konnte diesen Kram
irgendwie deaktivieren
hier das da, man konnte diesen Mist irgendwie deaktivieren
wobei mir das jetzt schon ein bisschen zu
gefrickelt aussieht
ist eine NVMe SSD
eh Overkill
äh ja
ist sie
ich will die auch nicht für den Raspberry
auf Dauer verwenden
ich wollte eigentlich nur mal gucken
ah hier
was das so hergibt
ich glaube ich muss den Raspberry auch wieder einschalten
okay
also was muss man machen
ähm, ja genau
das ist doch die gleichen Probleme die wir haben
äh, ah nee also ich glaub
Power Probleme hab ich nicht
ich hab das offizielle 5 Volt
äh 3 Ampere Netzteil
das sollte oder was ist das, nee 5
das reicht auf jeden Fall
außerdem würde das Ding meckern wenn er zu wenig Strom kriegt
okay also was muss man hier machen
um das auszuschalten
Vendor ID
okay jetzt jetzt Leute jetzt kommt Linux
gefuddelt, ähm
okay das machen wir jetzt
ich deaktiviere, ich schalte
mal den Raspberry Pi aus
vielleicht kann ich ihn, kann ich auch runter fahren
ich kann euch übrigens mal einen Trick zeigen
wenn ihr ein Linux System habt
wo ihr noch per SSH drauf kommt
ich muss gleich mal nachgucken was man genau machen muss
ähm, wenn ihr ein Linux System habt
wo ihr noch per SSH drauf kommt
aber das Ding höchstwahrscheinlich hängt
und nicht mehr richtig runter fährt
ihr könnt dem Linux System sagen einfach
Power ausschalten und zwar
da muss man ähm, muss man nachgucken
ich kann aber den Pfad immer nicht merken
genau man kann
kann das da echonen
nach ähm
VOC
SYS
im Prinzip dahin
dahin kann man das echonen
und dann schaltet das Ding sich automatisch Power aus
ohne dass man
jetzt irgendwie aufs Remote Interface muss oder so
ich habs ehrlich gesagt auf dem Raspberry Pi noch nie ausprobiert
aber
auf dem Raspberry Pi funktioniert es auch
jetzt hat er gar keine Chance hängen zu bleiben
okay also
was müssen wir jetzt machen
achso wir sollen uns
die Hersteller ID
und sowas abschreiben
okay machen wir
erstmal warten bis das Ding wieder neu gestartet ist
ah da ist er
wie ist er schon wieder da
da ist er wieder
glaubts nicht
ging aber schnell
High Speed Pi
und wir starten erstmal was
dass wir nicht immer raus fliegen
so die SSD hat er wieder erkannt
so also jetzt brauchen wir
was brauchen wir
äh D-Mask bla bla bla USB
kann doch einfach so gucken oder
ja
und was da
uuuh
ne was
was LS USB
Tree
man konnte sich doch irgendwie
ah Tree genau man konnte sich doch irgendwie so ein so ein
Device Baum malen lassen
warum haben die alle überall
andere Kommandos für
so
also wo hat er denn meine meine
meine SSD erkannt
wo ist meine SSD
hier
was da ha
na gut dann stöpsel ichs mal ab und wieder dran
aber trotzdem merkt man
ich kann mir die Befehle für LS USB
wie ging das nochmal
LS USB und dann
LS USB find SSD
man konnte sich doch so einen so einen
Baum malen lassen irgendwie
Tree und man muss ihm jetzt
allerdings sagen dass er alles auch anzeigt
das ist übelst wie
Tree
minus
ne das haben wir doch gerade
oder ist es oder ist es das
das ist es doch hier oder
das ist doch die SSD hier
ok also was müssen wir jetzt machen
äh ID
Vendor and ID Product
wo ist ID
ach hier oben
ID Vendor and ID Product
das kennen wir doch bestimmt noch mit LS USB raus
was ist was minus
Paint Tree
ja so das da
die zwei Dinger brauchen wir
das da ne das ist die SSD hier
das brauchen wir
hast du doch in dem ich habs ehrlich gesagt nicht gesehen
stehts nicht drinnen
aber die zwei Sachen müssten es sein
so und dann muss man was mit dem Zeug machen
what
das da
ok oh je
mal gucken ob das funktioniert
da habe ich ja so
da habe ich ja so meine Zweifel ob das klappt
ja habe ich ja gerade gemacht
ich habe ja gerade hier ähm
nach Vendor geguckt da war nix
gibts nix
ok jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt
ob das funktioniert
ok also hallo
USB Storage Que...
sowas erzählt der Typ hier doch auch ne
dass man das da reinschreiben soll
ach ne das muss man da vorschreiben oder
Moment
Moment Moment das muss man
vorschreiben
oder ja
naja ok
wartet mal wie war das nochmal hier mit ähm
das da
brauchen wir
jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt ob das was bringt
ja save reboot
ok Leute
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob das ob das klappt
hahaha
ich hab meine Zweifel
ob das funktioniert
ich muss aber danach noch irgendwas machen
hab ich fast vergessen
muss ich irgendwie noch einen Bootloader updaten oder so
scheint nicht
SSD via USB Controller oder NVME
NVME
über USB
die blinkt schon mal wie verrückt
meine SSD
aha aha aha
ich seh jetzt hier nix von UAS oder so
ok mount mount
mal gucken vielleicht gehts jetzt ja
def
SDA nach MNT
der scheiß hängt schon wieder
ok ich nehm doch mal ne andere SSD
vielleicht
das is auch noch ne möglichkeit
vielleicht wirds zu warm
ich hab noch ne billig
eine billig SSD hier rumliegen
die nehmen wir jetzt einfach
hätt ja sein können dass das funktioniert
achso hier
check that it works
ok wir checken ob es workt
ja
UAS is blacklisted for this device
using USB
also es hat funktioniert
es hat funktioniert was wir gemacht haben
ok wir testen jetzt einfach noch mal
was passiert wenn wir
wie viel
mal gucken wie viel IO wir kriegen
schreiben
das ist
der Adapter ist für n Arsch
voll für n Arsch
ich hätt TMAX starten sollen hätte ich jetzt gucken können
was passiert
ja guck mal
der Spack drum
kannst knicken
kannst du knicken
oder nicht oder doch
ich hol mal die andere SSD
das ist zwar keine
sonderlich gute die ich hier hab
das is ne SanDisk
ja SanDisk
240G
irgendwas
so eine hier
was die ich jetzt noch hab
ja so ein Ding da
genau so ein Teil
das ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig toll
aber für unsere Tests reicht es auf jeden Fall aus
guck mal
jetzt funktioniert es
aber allein schon
dass der immer die USB Sachen resetet
das ist doch nicht normal
da ist doch irgendwas im Argen
da ist doch irgendwas im Arsch
ich mein jetzt kriegen wir
das passt jetzt über USB
ich mein das könnte ein bisschen schneller sein aber
das geht
250 MB die Sekunde
da kann ich mit leben
vielleicht mag er jetzt doch
vielleicht hat er nur mal kurz gebraucht
vielleicht hat er sich kurz verschluckt und jetzt ist es ok
na probieren wir es doch mal aus
vielleicht mag er jetzt ja doch
also wenn er es jetzt halbwegs schnell löscht
dann
ist für den Arsch
ich nehm jetzt die andere USB
die andere USB SSD
voll für den Arsch
ja
normalerweise in der Millisekunde weg
das ist nicht normal hier
das spackt übelst rum
ich warte jetzt bis er das hier oben hingekriegt hat
und dann anmount ich das Teil
und dann schließen wir hier die
die Billig SSD an
was aber auch egal ist
weil für Tests ganz ähnlich 240G
selbst wenn das nur
keine Ahnung 80 MB die Sekunde hat
oder so ist es immer noch besser als ne SD Karte
ja guck der hat wieder resetet
weg damit
guck mal sogar das
sogar das anmounten
schwubbelt übelst rum
wenn wir gerade dabei sind
wir können nebenbei
können wir nochmal hier gleich Docker
installieren
Compose
warum bitteschön ist MediaWiki suggested
wenn ich Docker Compose installiere
MediaWiki
hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun
äh da Basti W. schreibt ähnliches hatte ich
bei ner Samsung NVMe USB Adapter auch
kann sein es könnte ja auch sein
dass das irgendein Kernel Bug ist
oder so
ich mein
das ist ein Zusammenspiel jetzt von
ähm
Controller in der SSD
Controller auf dem Adapter
USB Hub
Raspberry Firmware
Linux das ist alles dabei
es kann überall in die Hose
gehen ja
ich stöpsel mal um
ich mach mal die Billig SSD dran
wir müssen übrigens noch testen
wie warm der Raspberry Pi wird
hier da ist die andere
ähm
wir müssen noch testen wie warm der Raspberry Pi wird
V Gen Temp
wie ging das
Pi Get CPU Temp
das ist immer so ein Kommando
was ich mir nicht merken kann
V C Gen
so rum
jemand der sich sowas merken kann
okay also
wir starten hier oben mal unseren
was haben wir 35 Grad aktuell
okay
so 35 Grad dann gucken wir mal
wie die Auslastung vom System ist
und hier unten starte ich mal
ein bisschen
bisschen Rechenlast ja
was weiß ich hoch hoch das da
so
das rechnen wir jetzt aus
was BC nicht drauf
ai ai ai
Scanning
wow
was
pending kernel ab
wo sollen der auf einmal herkommen
ich hab doch alles geupgradet
newer kernel available
current running kernel version is
which is not expected kernel version
what
das habe ich noch nie gesehen
was des Virus
genau das wird es sein
was das habe ich noch nie gesehen
was ist das
ich will dass der Restart irgendwas bringt
weil wir haben geupgradet und gerestartet
kam mit Docker
was
echt jetzt
ne
Docker macht doch an meine kernel version nichts
der hat es gemerkt beim Docker installieren
aber das ist nicht die Ursache
ok
also gucken wir mal wie warm das ganze wird
was machst du ich gucke gerade
also jetzt gerade im moment
Dann gucke ich, wie warm mein Raspberry Pi 4 wird, wenn ich ihn was ausrechnen lasse.
Wenn ich alle vier Kerne mal 100% auslaste.
Gucken, wie warm er wird.
Wir hatten das jetzt schon mal ausprobiert. Das letzte Mal waren wir bei 85 Grad und dann ist er abgekackt.
Oder ist er abgekackt?
Ich glaube, der ist nicht abgekackt. Der ist einfach nur eingebrochen und hat runtergetackt.
Ich glaube, abgekackt ist er nicht. Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr richtig daran erinnern.
Aber zumindest hatten wir das letzte Mal Probleme, was die Temperatur angeht.
Ne, ne, abgekackt ist er nicht.
Jetzt sollte er deutlich unter 85 Grad bleiben.
Ich meine, der hat immer einen Lüfter drüber.
Der hat Passiv-Kühlkörper drauf und einen Lüfter drauf.
Also der kann jetzt gar nicht zu warm werden.
Ja, 50 Grad. Ist doch okay.
Ich meine, es ist immer noch ganz schön... Oh, es geht hoch, Leute.
Es geht hoch.
Ich hole mir gleich das...
Der Bauer...
Der Bauer CPU-Köpf-Kit und mache Flüssigmetall auf meinen Raspberry Pi.
Und dann mache ich eine Wasserkühlung drauf. Genau.
Ich muss aber erstmal meine CPU köpfen. Sonst geht das nicht.
CPU-Köpfen und Flüssigmetall drüber.
Lüfter auf Low. Ja, ja, ja. Lüfter ist auf niedrigste Stufe.
Stickstoff. Können wir auch machen.
Geht doch. 53 Grad für 100% CPU-Last. Das ist okay.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Ich würde mal sagen, selbst wenn es hoch geht auf 55, 56 und da voll hast, wenn es eine Weile läuft.
Das ist doch in Ordnung.
Vollkommen okay.
Okay. Dann rebooten wir nochmal, wenn er der Meinung ist, wir sollen rebooten.
Kannst du gleich mal ein Crypt-Setup-Benchmark machen?
Kann ich machen, aber der fällt... Also haben wir schon mal gemacht im Stream.
Der fällt ziemlich schlecht aus.
Ich kann es machen, wenn du willst.
Aber der fällt schlecht aus, weil...
...die Krypto-Geschichten in der ARM-CPU nicht aktiviert haben, weil die wahrscheinlich ein paar Cent sparen wollten.
Ursprünglich dachte ich ja, das liegt daran, weil es kein 64-Bit-Raspbian ist, aber die haben wohl die Krypto-Extensions gar nicht in der CPU drinne.
Also wenn du willst, kann ich es installieren und machen, aber ich kann dir sagen, das Ergebnis ist Crap.
Okay, wir rebooten mal. Vielleicht bringt es ja doch was.
Was für einen Kernel hat er eben erwartet hier? Einen Dings? L5?
Äh...
Ja, das ist naheliegend, ne? Man denkt erst, es liegt am 2-3-Spit-Betriebssystem, ist es nicht.
Ich hab dann in irgendeinem Forum gefunden, dass die quasi die ARM-CPU haben, aber entweder haben sie die Krypto-Sachen nicht lizenziert...
...oder es ist gar nicht erst drauf. Keine Ahnung.
Okay, was genau will der mir eigentlich sagen mit...
...15993-8+, und...
...ist V8...
...8+, ist das der 64-Bit-Kernel? Kann das sein?
Kann das sein, dass das der 64-Bit-Kernel ist?
Und das der 32-Bit-Kernel?
Ich meine, das ist die ARM-Architektur-Version, ja?
Aber der Raspberry Pi hat ja V8.
Ähm...
Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem JavaScript-V8.
Kann man... warte mal...
Äh...
...upsearch-kernel?
Gibt's denn da eigentlich alles für...
Nee, nee, äh, Firmware.
Oh fuck, was war das?
Firmware?
Kernel musste... konnte man ja nicht suchen, ne?
Kernel hat ja nichts gebracht.
Muss man Firmware suchen?
Ups.
Äh...
Wie heißt denn das Package, wo die Kernel drin sind?
Wo der Kernel drin ist?
Firmware?
Nee.
Ähm...
Wie heißt denn das Paket für den Kernel?
Lass uns hier einfach...
Ja, ich bilde mir ein, das heißt Linux-Firmware, Linux-Herr...
Aber da findet er weder noch, weder so, noch...
...weder noch, weder so, noch...
Also wenn du nach Header suchst...
Das war ja...
Das war ja mein Urspr...
Mein ursprünglicher Ansatz war, dass ich nach...
...nach Header suche, aber da hab ich nichts... äh...
...brauchbares...
Ah, hier!
Da sind wir doch.
So.
Was haben wir da jetzt alle so zur Auswahl?
V8.
Nee.
Ich weiß, was wir für ein Kernel drauf haben.
Das scheint nicht der richtige zu sein.
Weiß nicht, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Wir könnten mal ein Update machen.
Schreiwald Twitch Prime, danke schön.
Huge brain sub.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was das andere für n...
Was V8 Plus...
Was das sein soll.
Pye...
Was ist das überhaupt?
Okay, is... V8 ist doch glaub ich der neue 64-bit Kernel.
Okay, Leute, wir installieren jetzt den 64-bit Kernel.
Einfach weil's... weil's geht.
Wir installieren jetzt den 64-bit Kernel.
Also.
Angeblich geht das so.
Wollte ich eh schon mal die ganze Zeit ausprobieren.
If you want to switch to 64-Bit-Körnel,
add
arm64-bit gleich 1.
Ah, guckt hier, V8.
Das ist der
64-Bit-Körnel.
Okay, also, was muss man...
Wo muss man es eintragen?
In die Config?
Gut, Config.txt.
Es gibt noch keinen Eintrag für.
Vorher Update machen?
Habe ich mir auch
überlegt, aber wir haben ja quasi
das Neueste
aus dem Image schon drauf.
Weiß nicht, ob das so sinnvoll ist, wenn ich das noch
update vorher.
Ich meine, das ist Firmware-Update, wir können es machen.
Sie meckern ja überall rum
und sagen, eigentlich soll man das gar nicht ausführen,
weil Beta-Software und sonst was.
Was, erst danach?
Was denn? Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Would you like to proceed?
No. Wir machen das, wir machen das,
jetzt mal so, wie ich das ursprünglich fordere.
Wir tragen das jetzt mal ein und rebooten.
Ähm, so.
You can still...
So, und was muss man dann rebooten?
If the force kernel loading system...
Erst danach?
Bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Pipe for install 64-Bit-Körnel.
Ne, ne,
deprecate war was anderes.
Stimmt!
Ja.
Gut, gute Idee.
Kernel 8, da ist es.
Alles da.
Okay.
Reboot.
Ähm.
Hallo, kann ich ja nur tippen.
So, mal gucken, was jetzt passiert.
Entweder startet er nicht mehr.
Oh, er ist wieder da, Leute.
Er ist wieder da.
Bäm.
Ha!
Haha!
Hat funktioniert.
Wir haben 64-Bit-Körner.
Huge.
Sehr gut.
Ich bin ja fast geneigt.
Leute, soll ich die...
Soll ich die andere SSD noch mal anstöpseln
und gucken, ob die jetzt funktioniert?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es überhaupt
irgendeinen Einfluss darauf hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber vielleicht, vielleicht,
vielleicht hat sie irgendwas gebracht.
Komm, ich stöpsel noch mal kurz an.
Schadet ja nichts.
Okay.
SDA. Mount.
Oh nee, okay, es hängt.
Haha, alles gut.
Wir müssten es nicht noch mal probieren.
Das hat da keinen Einfluss drauf gehabt.
Also, mit dem Adapter kommt er nicht klar.
Guckt hier.
Der spackt rum.
Der hat richtige Schmerzen mit dem Adapter.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was er für Probleme hat, aber...
Große, anscheinend.
Große Probleme.
Small Brain Problems.
Der hat einfach nicht
den IQ von Twitch Chat.
Sonst würde es funktionieren.
Ich würde-ich würde ja gerne abbrechen
und die SSD wieder rausstöpseln, aber
Ich lass ihn mal, ich lass canon fertig,
fertig machen.
Spackt er nämlich rum.
Resetting Device? Ne.
Das ist für ein Arsch.
Das ist ja doof.
Ah, wir nehmen
die Billig... die Billige
SSD und gut ist es.
Good.
Gut, Docker haben wir schon, Docker Compose, Docker-Zeug haben wir schon installiert, ne?
Ja, gut.
No happy meal for you.
Sieben Monate, aktuell im siebten fortlaufenden Monat.
Huge Sub.
Okay, andere SSD wieder dran.
Da ist er ja.
Superspeed Gen 1 USB.
Ja, die Benamung von USB haben wir ja schon öfters festgestellt, sind ein bisschen undurchsichtig.
Spinning Frog ist auch am Start.
Der Name passt irgendwie gut dazu, oder?
Spinning Frog.
Äh, okay, also, jetzt kann man den Kram mauen.
Ne, ne, ne, wir müssen erstmal ein Filesystem drauf machen.
Auf, äh, SDA.
Ja, ich weiß, dass da schon was drauf ist, aber das ist mir egal.
Mount.
Guckt, Leute, das geht auch gleich viel schneller.
Jetzt ist die SSD auch nicht kaputt.
Das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt die Billig-SSD und die funktioniert lustigerweise.
Für gleich, bam.
Funktioniert instant.
Die ist aber halt nicht so schnell wie die andere.
Guckt, klappt auch sofort.
Der Adapter ist kacke oder halt die Kombination aus Adapter, Controller, Raspberry Pi, Firmware, Linux, was auch immer.
An irgendeiner Stelle geht es auf jeden Fall ordentlich schief bei der anderen SSD.
Jetzt sieht man nämlich auch, wie schnell das hier eigentlich geht, wenn es geht.
Okay, also, wir haben gesagt, wir wollen, äh, Nextcloud installieren.
Und wir hatten uns jetzt entschieden dafür, wir wollen das Ganze per, äh, Docker und Docker Compose machen.
Ah, also zumindest der Chat will das, will das machen, per Docker, Docker Compose.
Dann machen wir das doch.
Ich meine, wir könnten das Ganze jetzt auch nicht als Root machen.
Das wäre prinzipiell eigentlich...
...die...
...empfohlene Variante.
Man muss nicht unbedingt immer mehr unter Root machen, als irgendwie notwendig ist.
Aber ich meine, warum nicht?
Wir schmeißen das Ding danach eh gleich wieder weg.
FreeNAS. Ja, FreeNAS hab ich bei mir, äh, nicht, nicht mehr im Einsatz.
Ich hatt's mal ganz kurz, aber ich konnt mich damit nie richtig anfreunden.
Ähm, seitdem hab ich ganz normal ZFS...
...auf meinem...
...Linux-Server drauf.
Komm ich auch super mit klar.
Was bedeutet denn Compose im Zusammenhang mit Docker?
Ähm, zeig ich dir.
Docker Compose ist im Prinzip eine ganz kleine...
Achso, ja, doch, zeig dir an.
Ähm, im Prinzip ist es ein ganz kleines Hilfstool, was aus einem YAML-File quasi Docker...
...also du definierst in einem YAML-File, das machen wir jetzt einfach mal hier.
Du definierst in einem YAML-File, was der für Container anlegen soll.
Und dann sagst du nur noch Docker Compose... äh...
...ab, und der startet die ganzen Sachen für dich.
Also, es ist kein Unterschied unter der Haube, ja?
Unter der Haube sind das ganz normale Docker-Container.
Nur, dass man halt, ähm, nicht jeden Container von Hand starten muss...
...und man auch sich seine Config-Datei backuppen kann...
...und einfach auf einem anderen Rechner Docker Compose absagen kann.
Und es ist direkt wieder da.
So, ähm...
Ja, YAML ist PPEGA-Format, aber was willst du machen?
Mittlerweile werden wir es am liebsten...
Äh, wobei, so schlecht ist YAML...
...so schlecht ist YAML-Format.
So schlecht ist YAML-Format.
So schlecht ist YAML auch gar nicht.
Ich meine, ich bin Ruby-Fan und, äh, wer sich noch dran erinnern kann...
...früher unter Rails, da hat man alles mit YAML gemacht, ja?
Ruby hat das YAML, die haben das YAML geliebt, alle.
Ähm...
Also, ich guck mir mal das offizielle Docker-Compose-File an für Nextcloud...
...aber, ähm...
Ich, ich, ich hab ja eins.
Ich hab ja eins.
Ich würd einfach meins nehmen.
Insecure.
Ja, wir wollen Insecure haben.
MariaDB.
Ich will, ich will weder MariaDB...
...oder MariaDB.
Ähm...
Ich will weder MariaDB noch sonst was.
Ich will zum Testen so eine billige SQLite und gut ist...
Also, was machen die hier?
Services, bla bla bla...
Postgres, sonst was.
Ne, Leute, wisst ihr was?
Wir nehmen, wir nehmen, wir nehmen mein Docker-File.
Oder mein, mein, äh, Compose-File.
Für Nextcloud.
Kann ich nämlich einfach copy-pasten und gut ist.
Und da kann ich, wie gesagt, ich benutze...
Ich benutze einfach das eingebaute, die eingebaute SQLite-Datenbank für Nextcloud.
Und, ähm, das war's.
Und wir installieren einfach aktuelle 18er.
Version 18 ist das.
Von, von...
Ich glaube.
Von Nextcloud.
Dann ist das nämlich total einfach.
So.
Services.
Zack.
Oh, was macht denn der für riesen Einrückungen da standardmäßig?
Das wollen wir aber nicht.
Nextcloud.
Ähm...
Ich hab das neu noch nicht getestet, aber es gibt noch einen weiteren Grund, warum ich keinen FreeNAS verwende.
Weil ich will ja noch mehr machen.
Auf meinem Rechner.
Als da nass drauflaufen zu lassen.
Bisschen File-Server ist so Nebensache bei mir.
Neben den ganzen anderen Dingern.
So, also.
Nextcloud.
Dann muss man eben sagen, was er für ein Image verwenden soll.
Leute, falls man da jetzt was anderes machen muss.
Und irgendjemand von euch in letzter Zeit, in letzter Zeit mal Nextcloud installiert hat.
Und ich jetzt irgendwie Mist eingebe.
Müsst ihr mir das sagen.
Weil, ich schreib, weil mein Dock, mein Docker-Compose-File ist noch Fan von Version 17.
Ich würde jetzt einfach Version 17 durch Version 18 ersetzen.
Und hoffen, dass alle...
Alles funktioniert.
So, jetzt müssen wir ihm sagen, was er verwenden soll.
Als, ähm...
Als Ordner.
Wo er sein Zeug drinne speichert.
Weil, wenn man das nicht angeben, dann speichert er alles in seinem Magic-Filesystem quasi im Container drinne.
Was man zwar auch drauf zugreifen kann, dann irgendwie unter...
War...
Ne, wo ist das?
War, Run...
Dings, FS, Docker, irgendwas.
Aber es ist viel angenehmer.
Man gibt dem ein Verzeichnis an, wo er seine Dateien ablegen soll.
Hat nämlich auch den großen Vorteil.
Wenn ich das Ganze upgrade.
Dann ist es einfach immer da.
Ja, ich muss mich da um nichts großartig kümmern.
Aber man muss sagen, selbst das schützt einen nicht davor, dass irgendwelche Updates, ähm...
Upgrades, Skripts, Scheiße bauen.
Also sprich, Backups sind nie verkehrt.
Also, ich kann noch so viel vercontainerisieren oder, keine Ahnung, oder irgendwie verdevopsen oder was auch immer.
Ähm, wenn die eigentliche Anwendung irgendwie Kacke baut und mein Zeug kaputt macht, kann ich mich nie großartig davor schützen.
Deswegen ist es immer gut, wenn man vor einem Upgrade oder generell nicht vor einem Upgrade, wenn man regelmäßig mindestens von den wichtigsten Sachen irgendwie ein Backup macht.
Das ist auch ein Vorteil von so einem Docker-Compose-File.
Ähm, das ist halt die einfachste Variante.
Wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwelche...
Wenn man jetzt nicht sich gerade ein Kubernetes-Cluster oder sowas daheim hinstellen will.
Wo man einfach sein Kram in der Config-Datei definiert und man sagt ab und es läuft alles wieder.
Sofern man natürlich die Files von den einzelnen Containern gebackupt hat.
Okay, Volumes, was nehmen wir da jetzt hier?
MNT, ja, Nextcloud oder so.
So, und das Ganze muss in dem Container selbst dann gemountet werden nach www.html.
Weil das dort ist, wo Nextcloud sein Zeug halt macht.
Und ich glaube, das war es schon.
Ich muss mal in meinen Compose-File reingucken.
Ich glaube, das war es schon.
Mehr muss man nicht machen.
Das ist halt ganz praktisch.
Ähm, jetzt kann ich dieses File nehmen.
Sag einfach Docker-Compose ab und der startet mir den Kram so wie es sein muss.
Ich muss allerdings noch unter MNT mal ein Nextcloud-Verzeichnis anlegen.
So, und jetzt sage ich Docker-Compose ab und dann sollte eigentlich alles hochfahren.
Haben wir noch minus D, dass er das Ganze im Hintergrund macht.
Wow, was habe ich kaputt gemacht?
Ich habe es zerstört, Leute.
Ah, ich glaube, ich habe einen Minus vergessen, ne?
Naja, ich habe einen Minus vergessen.
Jetzt aber.
Ey, so, jetzt startet er den Kram und dann schauen wir mal, ob das Ganze funktioniert.
Ob es denn die Versprechen halten kann, die sie da in ihrem Marketing-Video angepriesen haben.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Was findet ihr eigentlich besser?
Unrate oder Freenas?
Ganz ehrlich, weder noch.
Ähm, ich nehme einfach einen ganz normalen Linux-Server, mache mir dann Samba drauf und gut ist.
Mehr brauchst du nicht.
Ja.
Mit der nächsten Ubuntu-Version kommt angeblich ja auch, äh, quasi, dass man installieren kann auf Zerf.
Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Sie haben mir irgendwas gesagt.
Und du nimmst ein Ubuntu, machst ZFS drauf, installierst einen Samba-Server, fertig.
Weder Freenas noch, äh, irgendwo zu.
Weil ich finde, man beschränkt sich damit irgendwie zu sehr.
Auf so einem Ubuntu-Server kannst du alles machen, was du machen willst.
Und ich weiß, dass man unter Freenas theoretisch auch irgendwelche BSD-Container laufen kann, lassen kann.
Und unter Unrate gibt es quasi auch irgendwie so ein Docker-Installer.
Äh, Gedöns.
Ich denke mal, wenn man einen GUI braucht, ist Unrate nicht verkehrt.
Aber mein Fall ist es nicht.
Ich installiere mir am liebsten einen Ubuntu-Server, mache ZFS drauf, installiere mir einen Samba für File-Server und fertig.
Ja.
Und dann alles, was ich sonst noch so brauche.
Was ist eine Nextcloud-Hub?
Das ist die, das ist die 18er-Version von Nextcloud.
Die haben sich jetzt umbenannt.
Und sind angeblich viel grafischer.
Und besser als vorher.
Wie ging das, Docker-Compose-Logs?
Okay, es läuft, Leute.
Es läuft.
Nextcloud ist am Start.
Und jetzt sehen wir auch schon mal einen großen Vorteil von diesem ganzen...
Äh, oder auch nicht.
Ah, kann das sein, dass ich vergessen habe, den Port anzugeben, worauf das lauschen soll?
Ne, 80.
Warum zeichnet er das denn an?
Bin ich jetzt...
Bescheuert?
Ne, geht auch nicht.
Huge.
Äh.
Habe ich was vergessen zu exposen oder so?
Weil angeblich, angeblich sollte er auf Port 80 laufen, ne?
Wie, kein Telner drauf?
Zum Thema ZFS bekommst du irgendeine Art von Benachrichtigung, wenn eine Platte ausfällt.
Äh, könnte ich machen, habe ich aber nicht gemacht.
Braucht man das? Echt?
Also, ich habe mein aktuelles Compose-File genommen, da ist das nicht drinne und es funktioniert trotzdem.
Der lauscht gar nicht gerade aktuell.
Ah, hier.
Ports.
Guck mal, doch.
Tatsächlich, braucht man.
Lul.
Äh, ich weiß übrigens, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Warum es in meinem...
Also, besser gesagt, ich weiß, warum es in meinem aktuellen Docker-Compose-File funktioniert.
Aber, äh, hier nicht.
Weil ich noch eine Load-Balancer, beziehungsweise ein Proxy davor habe.
Und das habe ich hier nicht.
Also, muss man ihm hier wahrscheinlich sowas noch sagen, ne?
Ports.
Jui.
Wim, Alter.
Was für Eindrückung.
Also, muss man ihm sagen, Port 80, 80.
80, 80.
Bam.
Ab.
So.
Stimmt das jetzt?
Schauen wir mal.
Aha.
Let's start.
Ah, Port 80.
Da ist er.
Und da ist die Nextcloud.
Steht da auch irgendwie die Version drinne?
Es wäre natürlich auch, äh...
Wo kämen wir denn da hin, wenn im Installer-Bildschirm die Versionsnummer drinstehen würde?
Okay.
Username.
Admin.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Huge Password.
Okay.
Okay, guck...
Ja, das ist die Version 18.
Hier.
Kalender, Task, Talk, Mail und Only Office.
Only Office ist diese Geschichte, die angeblich so für...
Für...
Na, halt für Office 365 Konkurrenz sorgen soll.
Bin leider noch ein bisschen skeptisch, aber wir gucken uns das Ganze an.
Ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert.
Auch bei den alten Versionen nicht.
Hat er eine Erfahrung mit euch?
Habt ihr das schon mal getestet hier?
Only Office, ob das was taugt?
Oh, ne, läuft ganz gut.
Ja, wie gesagt.
Ihr wisst ja, ich verwende überhaupt kein Office, wenn es sich nicht vermeiden lässt.
Für nix.
Ich bin jetzt, was Office-Anwendungen angeht, nicht gerade der Experte, der installt.
Ja, weil in meinem eigentlichen Docker-Compose-File, was ich bei mir gerade auf dem Server liegen habe,
da ist noch ein Loadbalancer davor.
Also noch ein Proxy davor.
Deswegen hat das mit den Ports gerade nicht hingehauen.
Findest Sie-File besser als Nextcloud?
Sie-File wollte ich auch nochmal ausprobieren.
Habe ich noch gar nichts mitgemacht.
Läuft das Nextcloud-Zeugs dann über Apache?
Ja.
Also anscheinend, anscheinend ist Standard-Mission Apache davor.
Weil irgendwas muss den PHP-Crap ja starten.
Community-Document-Server.
Bin ja mal echt gespannt, wie gut das funktioniert.
Wir können es hier einfach ausprobieren.
Ich meine, ich kann es nicht von außen freigeben, dass ihr drin rumtippen könnt.
Allein schon aus dem Grund, weil dann irgendwelche Leute direkt wieder irgendwie titten und dickpicks rein copy-pasten.
Das war ich jetzt schon.
Ich kenne den Twitch-Chat.
Ähm, deswegen mache ich einfach mal zwei Browser-Fenster auf, nebeneinander und wir bearbeiten das zusammen.
Keine Ayaya-Pics.
Ich, Leute, ich kenne im Discord den Weebspam-Channel und ich weiß, was da einige posten und ich weiß auch, dass sofort, sobald ich das freigeben würde, die Leute komische, komische Dinger posten würden.
Garantiert.
Stimmt, wo ist der Sibaro eigentlich?
Aha.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Collabora und OnlyOffice?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich hab mich da null mit beschäftigt, ehrlich gesagt.
Was macht der da eigentlich im Hintergrund so lange?
Was macht der da?
Macht doch gar nix.
Ah, vielleicht sollten wir doch mal Sort bei CPU machen, ne?
Okay, doch.
Er installiert.
Es scheint ja hochkomplex zu sein, was er da installiert.
Was ist Leaked?
Was?
Was habe ich wieder Leaked, Leute?
Der Provokateur.
Was habe ich Leaked?
MonkaS?
Er installiert das, äh, er installiert Wikipedia wahrscheinlich.
Weil wir könnten ja mal gucken, was er so macht
Äh, D-Stat
Ja, Install
D-Stat, da sehen wir ein bisschen I.O.
Und Zeugs
Oh, er ist fertig
Ha, siehste, man muss ihn bloß androhen
Mit man guckt mal nach, was er so macht
Schon funktioniert es
Was ist das da eigentlich?
Er ist fertig
Guck, komm, gucken wir nach, was er macht, ist er fertig
Äh, ah, yes
Excellent blauer Hintergrund
Exquisite
Gehört das so?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass das so gehört
Das gehört im Leben doch nicht so, oder?
Next
Start
Huge, da sind wir
Oh, Vineyard PNG
Das wollte ich schon immer mal
Excellent, Leute
Excellent
Ich mein
Das könnte aus dem Game sein, ne?
Mittlerweile kann man das schwierig noch unterscheiden
Welches Texture Pack ist das?
Das RTX-On hat er hier eindeutig
Das eindeutige RTX-On
So, wie
Macht man denn jetzt die Geschichte mit
Zusammenarbeiten
Im
Bei Textdokumenten
Ähm, okay, das heißt wir brauchen auf jeden Fall schon mal
Einen zweiten User, dass wir das ordentlich testen können
Oh, Users
Da machen wir mal hier einen
Anonymen Tab auf, dass man das auch
Ausprobieren kann
Äh, neuer User
Ja, keine Ahnung, Max, Passwort
Huge, Passwort, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Äh, E-Mail brauchen wir nicht
Passwort, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Was? 8 Characters
Der ist doch so secure
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9
Jawoll
Was? Nein!
Was ist da los?
Ich darf das Passwort nicht nehmen
Wenn Programme mitdenken wollen immer, ey
Huge Security
Okay, dann ist das Passwort
Wird jetzt
1, 2, 3 Ausrufezeichen
Perfekt
Ah, ja, ja, Ausrufezeichen
Okay
Also, Login
Max
Ah, ja, ja, 1, 2, 3 Ausrufezeichen
So, ähm
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wie das funktioniert
Also, ich leg
Ich mach's mal komplett Noob-Style
Ja, ich guck's mir gar nicht an
Ich mach einfach mal so, wie ich das jetzt
Intuitiv, wie ich das machen würde
Also, ich würde
Ein Textdokument anlegen
Oder Dokument, hier, Dokument
Leg ich an, hier, keine Ahnung
Äh, Cute Chat
Cute Chat, Dokument
What?
Grip, Grip
Geht nicht
Warum nicht?
Es ist überhaupt, stimmt überhaupt nicht
Wir haben extra einen 64-Bitcoin installiert, guck mal
Wir haben, wir, das stimmt überhaupt nicht
Das ist, Gbait
Next Cloud
Vielleicht muss man da was Spezielles angeben
Aber 32
Ich bin Dokka
Läuft Dokka als 32
Kein Schimmer
Ich würde davon ausgehen
Wo sehe ich das überhaupt?
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Diese, dieses Problem hat sich mir noch nie gestellt
Wo sehe ich das überhaupt?
Na, Dokka ist egal
Es ist egal, was Dokka für ne Version hat
Ähm, für was ist es egal
Was Dokka für ne, für ne
Für ne Architektur hat, wichtig ist was letztes Mal.
Das Next Cloud, was der Container hat
Und wahrscheinlich ist der Container
32-Bit oder so
Dokka Info
Aber das ist eigentlich egal, in was Dokka läuft
Ja, Arsch64
Ähm
Next Cloud
Dokka 64-Bit
Ah, guck mal da
Da muss ich irgendwas angeben
Kann das sein?
Wie macht man das jetzt?
Wie, wie verklickere ich dem jetzt
Dass der 64-Bit
64-Bit starten soll
Supported Architektur
Das muss man bestimmt irgendwo angeben, ne?
Ich brauch
ARM64 V8
Kann man das irgendwie angeben, irgendwo?
Wie gibt man das an?
Ich würde jetzt ja
Ich würde ja eigentlich erwarten
Dass der standardmäßig das nimmt, was ich installiert hab
Leute, hab ich
Hab ich den Kram schon installiert?
Bevor
Wir das auf 64-Bit-Kernel geswitcht
Haben?
Oder danach?
Echt, hab ich das da vorgemacht?
Ah ja gut, da dran könnte das natürlich
Liegen
Dann, dann schmeißen wir das jetzt nochmal
Alles weg
Dann löschen wir das einfach nochmal, sehr easy
Dokka war
Vor Kernel-Switch
Was, Image Manifest List Support
Plattforms
Von was ist das?
Ah, man muss in die Yaml
Ah, also sprich, sowas hier im Endeffekt
Muss man das irgendwie hinter das
Image machen?
Neue Emotes
Da kann ich nur das hier zu sagen
Dokka Compose
Ok, wir gucken jetzt nochmal
Schnell, wenn man den Kram
Jetzt startet, nochmal neu
Funktioniert OnlyOffice überhaupt
Auf ARM? Kein Schimmer
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass
Wenn man, wenn die den offiziellen Docker-Container haben
Sie das Fett bewerben
Dass das einfach geht
Ach, muss man das da vorschreiben?
Muss man das so machen?
Vielleicht?
Ich hab das noch nie gemacht
Das Problem hatte ich bisher nie
So vielleicht?
Ah
Ah, yes
Excellent
Exquisite Docker Pull
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt klappt
Das ist für mich Neuland hier
Leute
So wie das Internet für uns alle
Nahezu, alle
Zumindest was Breitbandausbau angeht
Ich hatte das Problem
Noch nie, dass ich
Meine Container in der falschen Architektur
Wie geht das überhaupt?
Wie geht, das geht doch gar nicht
Leute
Das kann doch eigentlich gar nicht sein
Ich kann doch gar keinen Container
32 Bit starten auf einem 64 Bit Körner
Wie soll das gescheit, wie soll das gehen?
Na wobei, doch
32 Bit starten auf einem 64 Bit Körner
Müsste ja wahrscheinlich funktionieren
Ich hab mich da nie mit beschäftigt
Das müsste ja wahrscheinlich gehen
Weil normalerweise
Also bei den ganzen Container Geschichten ist es ja so
Du verwendest ja immer den Host Körner
Das heißt, du kannst eigentlich da gar nichts spezielles machen
Vielleicht geht es auch einfach
Vielleicht ist die Fehlermeldung einfach auch Kacke gewesen
Nextcloud
Suchen wir mal
Raspberry
Only Office
Schauen wir mal
Aha
What?
Was?
Die Fehlermeldung ist einfach nur Kacke
Die Fehlermeldung ist einfach nur Müll
Och Mann
Erst
Rühren sie die Werbetrommel
Und wahrscheinlich
Einer der am meisten eingesetzten Plattformen
Geht nicht
Ich weiß nicht mehr was wir machen
Habe ich noch genug Platz?
Wir machen uns einfach eine Ubuntu
VM
Ahhhh
Das ist aber schlecht
Das wird eng
Das wird eng mit der Ubuntu VM Leute
Das wird knapp
Kann man hier noch ein bisschen was löschen?
Monka Festplatte voll
Mach mal einen Cleanup
Kann ich machen
Naja hältst die Grenzen oder?
Cleanup System Files
Und jetzt?
Nicht so wirklich viel zu cleanen was es hier gibt oder?
Hältst dich in Grenzen
328 MB
Who cares?
Jungs das macht es jetzt auch nicht fett dabei
Quatsch das liegt
Ich weiß ja woran es liegt
Ich habe einfach so viel Kram installiert
Aber ist kein Problem
Wir kommen mit 8 GB
Mit 8 GB kommen wir aus für eine Ubuntu
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem
Okay das funktioniert hier drauf schon mal nicht
Das ist natürlich doof
Das hätte man vielleicht mal von Anfang an nachgucken müssen
Aber wir installieren
Das ist easy
Kein Problem wir installieren uns einfach
Wir installieren uns einfach eine Ubuntu VM
Alles kein Ding
Ubuntu Server
Download
Wir brauchen den Alternate Installer
Weil der neue Ubuntu Server Installer Crap ist
Komm wir nehmen den
Wir nehmen den LTS Server
Reicht für unsere Zwecke auch
Wobei ne wir nehmen den
Leute wir nehmen den
Da haben wir ne neuere Docker Version Build in
Was Ubuntu Live ISO
Moment nein nein nein
Warum lädt der das Live ISO runter
Hier den brauchen wir
Dass sie das mittlerweile so versteckt haben
Ach Quatsch nicht arm
Äh
Hier
Den brauchen wir
Downloads
Kein so Zeug
Ja hier Deep in
Weg
Haben wir schon mal ein bisschen mehr Platz bitte
So ok ähm
Naja
Nachdem der Raspberry Pi jetzt ja eh nur rumsteht
Können wir noch mal
Soll ich noch
Irgendwas
Will irgendjemand noch mal was getestet haben auf ne Raspberry Pi 4
Will er irgendwie noch was wissen
Was
Was er vielleicht wissen muss das er sich ankauft
Hast du deinen neuen Rechner schon zusammen
Ne noch nicht
Den lassen sie auch erst mal
Ja ich weiß das der Nextcloud Container nicht ab ist
Wir können den ja auch nicht verwenden
Weil die äh
Die Office Geschichte
Auf ARM Plattform nicht
Funktioniert
Ich lasse den jetzt einfach im Hintergrund mal laufen
Und wir schauen mal wie warm das Ding wird
Ähm
Wir können mal
Sysbench CPU wie ging das nochmal
CPU
Sysbench
Ja
Ist besser als mein komisches
Improvisiertes
Ähm
PC Zeug
Wie gut läuft denn der Minecraft Server auf dem Pi
Wahrscheinlich ziemlich gut
Hast du nen Kühler auf dem Raspberry Pi
Ja
Ne Passivkühler und da drüber nen Lüfter
Habe ich heute zusammengebaut das Gehäuse
Das hier guck
Fällt mir nicht
Bam
Ok das geht relativ schnell
20.000 Prime Numbers
Dürfte
Dürfte zackig gehen
Was für ein OS hat denn das
Manjaro Linux
Äh hat Sysbench
Sowas wie nen Endlos Benchmark
So nen Heat
Wie macht man denn unter Linux
Habe ich mir noch nie angeguckt
Generate CPU Heat
Ich will das Ding einfach so
So heiß wie möglich wird
Stress
Bam Stress
Das will ich haben
Apt Install Stress
Ok Stress
CPU 4
Jetzt gibt's Stress
Äh CPU 4
Reicht das einfach so
Easy
So
Äh macht das Ding da
Wir lassen den jetzt mal laufen und gucken wie warm der wird
Wir lassen den jetzt einfach während wir
Während wir ähm
Nextcloud installieren auf der Ubuntu Kiste
Lassen wir einfach mal hier im Hintergrund
Den Raspberry Pi laufen und mal schauen
Wie warm der Maximal wird
Taugt der Wasser als Retropie
Auf dem 3er lief ein N64 nicht besonders toll
Der 4er ist ein bisschen schneller als der 3er
Aber das sind jetzt keine Welten dazwischen
CPU mäßig
Also generell so groß ein Riesen Upgrade
Ist die Hardware nicht
Das größte
Der größte Unterschied zwischen Raspberry Pi 3 und 4
Ist eigentlich I.O
Netzwerk I.O USB I.O
Und sowas der jetzt zum ersten mal
Annehmbar schnell ist
Der nicht wirklich schnell ist aber annehmbar schnell
CPU und der Rest ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
Viel schneller als vorher
Also sprich wenn der Kram vorher nicht richtig lief
Ist die Chance das es nachher auch nicht richtig läuft
Recht hoch
Ok hat er jetzt
Hat er jetzt downgeloadet
Download
Ubuntu Server I.O
Mir fällt gerade ein
I.O sprechen das die coolen Leute
Nicht dann auch eher I.O aus
Also das
Ubuntu I.O
Für den Router
I.O
I.S.O
Was das
Das ist ein Gnome Terminal
Mit ZSH
I.O
Und für
VMs das ist vor allem eine Workstation
Was man jetzt auch hier gleich
Sehen wird weil wir erstellen
Jetzt eine neue Ubuntu VM
Wir haben
Leider nicht so viel Festplattenplatz
Also wir müssen ein bisschen
Ein bisschen genügsam sein
Ich geb dem Ding mal eine
8 GB Platte
Was wird jetzt als nächstes gemacht naja
Wir installieren jetzt Nextcloud
Nochmal auf einer Ubuntu VM
Das ich eben dieses
Collaboration Zeug testen kann
Was ich ja eigentlich vor hatte
So 15
Next installieren wir selbst
Ubuntu 64
Next
Ja 2 CPUs
2 reicht
Ja gut
Nut wunderbar
Kein Nut
Bridge Network das man da auch ordentlich drauf zugreifen kann
Man weiß ja nie genau
Next
20G
Bis sie groß war 12
12G
Single File
Disk Space Now
Next
Finish
Gut schauen wir mal
Wie das jetzt unter Ubuntu funktioniert
Das geht jetzt relativ schnell
Weil es dann auch Performance mäßig auf meinem Desktop ein bisschen schneller läuft
Und wir eigentlich nichts großartig machen müssen
Und gut ist
Äh
ISO
Start
Englisch ist ok
Install
Ubuntu Server
Denkst du das neue
X570D412T
lohnt sich als möglichst kleine Server
Board
Nachdem ich selbstverständlich genau weiß
Was da drauf ist
Sag ich einfach mal ja
Ähm
Portugalina
They said in an official blog post
They want to be an alternative to Office 365
But I don't think it will
Be an alternative
So also machen wir das Ding mal Englisch
Installier Language
Europe
Ich will eigentlich nur
Ich will eigentlich nur meine passende
Tastatur auswählen
Yes
No kein French Keyboard
Kein Baguette Keyboard
Next weiter
Hahaha Wubblos Englisch
Alter
Oh man
Deswegen habe ich auch meine Sprache nicht
Englisch im Streben
Wie hat der Oettinger mal erzählt
And in my home country
We say we are all sitting in one boat
Hahaha
Also besser als der kriege ich das noch hin
Tote Tasten
Eliminieren
Ausnahme Ubuntu passt
Test
123456 Huge Password
Yes auf jeden Fall wollen wir das
Weak Password verwenden
Mark Weak Pass Passwords
Also Nextcloud Hub ist ein Office 365
Welches man selbst auskennen kann
Das sagen sie
Ich glaube es ja nicht wirklich
Das sagen sie halt zumindest in ihrem Blog Post
Schauen wir wie schön schnell das installiert
Im Vergleich zum Raspberry
So lang sind wir eigentlich schon on
Die Zeit geht immer rum
Ähm
Wir sind richtig schön schnell im Vergleich zum Raspberry
Flutscht
Flutscht richtig
Ok nein kein Proxy weiter
Was macht eigentlich unser Raspberry gerade von der Tastatur her
Äh was laber ich für ein Scheiß
Von der voller Temperatur her
53 Grad ok
Wärme wird es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
Auf dem Raspberry funktioniert es nicht
Ne auf dem Raspberry da funktioniert
Die Only Office Geschichte nicht
Kannst der kann ja
Mach automatisch
DNS Server
Äh ein SSH Server
Kein DNS Server
Ähm
Warum Ubuntu
Ich mag weil ich Ubuntu Server mag
Ich mag Ubuntu Server
Bin Ubuntu Fan
Außer auf dem Desktop
Lustigerweise
Auf der Arbeit haben wir nur Red Hat
Was viele im Enterprise Umfeld haben
Da ist Red Hat ziemlich
Ziemlich weit verbreitet
Bei vielen Hostern
Ist es tatsächlich Debian das stimmt
Ähm ich persönlich mag
Ubuntu Server
Einen großen Vorteil der Ubuntu Server
Hat gerade von Heimgebrauch ist
Find ich das viele Sachen dabei sind
Ja die ähm
Das gewöhn dir doch mal
Bitte Umfeld ab so 2019
What
Was sprichst du
Ähm
Du meinst im Enterprise Umfeld
Also
Wie willst du es denn sonst nennen
Man könnte natürlich auch eine Arch Linux an den Server hinzulegen
Klar kann man alles machen
Aber das ist dafür nur wirklich nicht gedacht
Ähm
Erator Mordheimer sagt
Bei ihm auf der Arbeit gibt es auch noch Red Hat
Das ist das Elotrix Linux
Red Hat
Kannst du bei VMware eigentlich
Komprimierte Disk Images erstellen
Mit KVM
Kann man zum Beispiel
Äh die Dinger
Ich glaube die sind
Sogar standardmäßig schon komprimiert
Kennst du ne gute
Möglichkeit sich selbst signierte
Sicherheitszertifikate für ein NAS
Auszustellen zu generieren brauche das
Für WebDAV für Windows Explorer
Äh
Solange man da nicht ein Let's Encrypt nehmen kann
Fällt mir da nichts gutes ein dazu
Also ich mein wenn du es
Selbst komplett aufstellen
Also wenn du es selbst komplett
Ausstellen
Kannst dann ist es kein Problem
Weil dann musst du einfach nur in deinen Truststore
Unter Windows eben die
CA reinmachen mit der du es ausgestellt hast
Und dann kannst du einfach OpenSSL
Ähm einfach mit OpenSSL
Keys generieren das ist kein Ding
Wenn du ein richtig echtes gültiges Zertifikat brauchst
Dann fällt mir eigentlich bloß Let's Encrypt
Ein oder Geld ausgeben
Kann man mit Python auch Apps klar
Ja wie gesagt wenn die ein gültiges Zertifikat
Brauchen jetzt irgendwas was
Was dann auch ne Browser akzeptiert
Dann kommst du an Let's Encrypt nicht vorbei
So was haben wir denn
Für ne IP
Äh
Okay gut
Tab auf SSH
Was war das 143
Ja
Huge secure Password
So
Da sind wir
Erstmal ein Update machen
Und dann gleich mal Nextcloud drauf fahren
Apt
Hast du studiert Max? Ne habe ich nicht
Ich habe 2007 ne Ausbildung gemacht
Ist schon ein bisschen her
Bin ja auch wupp wupp old
Also
Wenn du wie gesagt wenn du Let's Encrypt
Verwenden kannst Ghost Rider
Dann ist das
Würde ich dann würde ich das machen
Das ist relativ simpel mit Certbot
Mit Certbot kannst du nämlich auch
Über DNS Challenge
Dir für interne Sachen
Was ausstellen ohne das der
Webserver öffentlich stehen muss
Ähm du brauchst halt nur die Domain
Die muss dir gehören
Beziehungsweise du brauchst Zugriff auf den DNS Server
Der für die Domain zuständig ist
Dann kannst du das machen
Was machst du auf der Arbeit
Wenn dich das interessiert kann ich dir empfehlen
Ich habe ein Video zugemacht
Auf Youtube das da
Ähm
Da lasse ich mich 14 Minuten drüber aus
Was ich auf der Arbeit mache
Also wenn es dich interessiert kannst du es einfach angucken
Ja Certbot geht ohne Zugriff von außen
Das funktioniert
Du kannst mit
Also zeigen nicht
Aber ich kann dir zeigen was du machen musst
Ähm du kannst mit
Let's Encrypt
Kannst du DNS Challenge machen
Und das funktioniert dann folgendermaßen
Mal gucken ob es irgendwie ein gescheites Bild
Oder so für gibt
Naja das Bild ist jetzt nicht wirklich schön
Ähm
Ah
So halb
Also ein schönes Bild ist es nicht
Äh das geht
Du brauchst aber den DNS Server der für die Domain ist
Das ist wichtig
Oder du machst dir
Du machst dir irgendeine
Irgendeine kostenlose Domain
Bei irgendeinem dünnen DNS Anbieter
Aber
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall
Einen DNS der für die Domain zuständig ist
Und dann gehst du in Certbot
Und sagst du möchtest als Challenge DNS verwenden
Und dann
Gibt er dir einen so einen Token aus
Und dieses Token musst du auf deinem DNS
Als TXT Rekord hinterlegen
Und dann ist es fertig
Und dann sagst du eben
Ja habe ich gemacht weiter
Aber vorher würde ich erstmal testen ob es auch funktioniert
Und ähm
Wenn du es als TXT Rekord hinterlegt hast
Dann checkt er das
Das heißt man braucht keinen Web Server öffentlich
Das habe ich für mein ganzes Zeug gemacht
Ja das ist richtig
Das habe ich für mein ganzes Zeug intern gemacht
Und ich habe es auch so automatisch
Also ich mache ja
Ich nehme ja mittlerweile den Cloudflare DNS
Für mein Zeug
Das ist eine ziemlich gute API
Und ich habe es jetzt so eingerichtet
Das die paar Services die ich habe
Die laufen halt hinter einem Reverse Proxy
Und der Reverse Proxy ist
So eingestellt
Das der automatisch
Die Zertifikate über Let's Encrypt
DNS Challenge erneuert
Weil Certbot hat einen
Cloudflare Plugin
Genau
Also ich nehme Certbot mit dem DNS
Cloudflare Plugin
Und da macht er das automatisch
Ja ne eben nicht
Sag ich doch gerade er macht das automatisch
Peter ein Fickert
Bester
Äh
Dankeschön für den Sub
Mit dem Cloudflare Plugin für DNS Challenge
Ist überhaupt kein Ding
Stellst du dir einmal aus
Und dann guckt er automatisch
Bei mir nach
Und updatet den Kram
Ein paar Tage bevor es ausläuft
Ist überhaupt kein Problem
Oder neun Monaten oder so laufen
Und ähm
Ich musste noch nicht einmal
Zertifikate wieder von Hand
Ähm
Choose my name das funktioniert nicht
Das muss öffentlich
Erreichbar also nein das ist nicht erreichbar
Das muss öffentlich auflösbar sein
Weil ja der DNS
Der Let's Encrypt Server
Also der Let's Encrypt Zertifikat
Ausstellungsdienst
Der macht ja einen Lookup
Auf dem DNS Server
Der für diese Domain zuständig ist
Wo ich ein Zertifikat ausstellen soll
Legt dort einen TXT Rekord
Mit dem geheimen Token
Mit dem geheimen Passwort quasi drinnen
Nö ich mach keine Wildcard Zertifikate
Könnte man machen habe ich aber nicht
Ähm
Weil das ist ganz gut integriert
In diese ganze Docker
Reverse Proxy Geschichte
Sobald ich einen neuen Container anlege
Mit äh
Neuem Namen dann stellt er automatisch
Ein Wildcard Zertifikat für diesen Container aus
Das ist echt praktisch
Ok also
Ähm
App Install Docker
Compose
Wir machen das das gleiche
Wir machen das das gleiche wie auf dem Raspberry
Wir kopieren uns jetzt nämlich einfach den Kram
Äh
Set Maus
Warum ist die Maus überhaupt an
Lull
Wie gesagt ich habe früher Wildcard Zertifikate gemacht
Aber so finde ich viel praktischer
Man muss ein bisschen aufpassen
Mit Let's Encrypt
Wenn man gar so sehr viel probiert
Und neu erstellt
Man gerät auch ab und zu mal gerne an das Wochenlimit
Für Domains
Wenn man zu viel rumprobiert
Aber an sich sind die Limits bei Let's Encrypt ziemlich großzügig
Äh ich habe
Also ich verwende zwei Sachen
Ich verwende für alles
Was nicht Container ist
Eigentlich immer Nginx
Aber für alles Container Zeug
Nämlich mittlerweile Traffic weil es super integriert ist
Ist
Das ist halt total einfach damit
Da sagst du einfach hier Container mit diesem Label
Und dann kannst du sogar
Automatisch Let's Encrypt Zeug machen lassen
Und sowas
Das ist halt echt praktisch
Also Traffic für alles was
Container ist
Und Nginx für alles was
So ist
Für Sachen die von außen
Erreichbar sind prinzipiell Nginx
Das geht auch
Also man kann
Ähm
Man kann ein bisschen tricksen
Das haben wir
Ich verwende Plain Docker
Ich habe daheim kein Kubernetes oder irgendwas anderes
Das einzige was ich mache
Ich habe ein Docker Compose File
Das ich den Kram wieder herstellen kann
Mit meiner einen
Wie gesagt ich habe ja bei mir daheim
Mein Setup schon deutlich entschlackt
Im Vergleich zu den letzten Jahren
Das ist jetzt nur noch eine kleine Kiste
Die hier übrig geblieben ist
Da ist jetzt nicht mehr
Die große Kiste ist weg
Und ähm
Da brauche ich kein
Keine irgendwelche Hypervisor
Äh nicht Hypervisor ähm
Hyperscaler nennt man es ja
Und keine Orchestrierungsgeschichten
Da ist ein Ubuntu Server drauf
Da ist mein Docker Compose File drauf
Und da ist
Eine System SSD drinne
Und eine Platte für Backups
Und Zeug
Fertig war es
Also ich habe es deutlich vereinfacht
Ja zum spielen ist es cool
Das stimmt
Spielen ist das natürlich nice
Set paste
Ähm eins müssen wir bloß nochmal weg machen
Das hier
So und jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit
Gucke ob es funktioniert
Äh Moment was ich da mache ist Blödsinn
Wir tun mal so als sind wir noch auf meinem Raspberry
So
Mal gucken ob die Nextcloud jetzt funktioniert
Ja ach genau
Was ich sagen wollte zu Let's Encrypt
Das habe ich ja auch schon im Stream gemacht
Es gibt ja die Variante
Das du das man ein bisschen trickst
Also sprich man kann sich
Bei einem
Entweder hat man eine Domain
Oder wenn man keine Domain hat
Kann man sich bei irgendeinem Dünndns Anbieter
Einfach eine anlegen
Ja zum Beispiel DuckDns
Ist übrigens auch mein bevorzugter Dünndns
Wenn ich einen verwende dann den
Ähm hat eben auch jemand im Chat geschrieben
Da kann man sich da eine Domain anlegen
Und
Dann stellst du dir die
Das Zertifikat stellst du dir aus
Für die Domain
Und danach biegst du einfach
Intern in einem Dünndns
Das um
Auf eine interne IP
Und fertig
Und schon kannst du das Zertifikat intern verwenden
Aber ich
Kann euch prinzipiell
Nur empfehlen
Ähm weil die Domains sind halt
Schwierig zu merken
Der Domain kostet nicht mehr viel
Wenn du keine Ahnung 7 Euro im Jahr
Für eine Domain
Die nicht gerade .de ist
Oder irgendwas was begehrt ist
Bezahlst du 7 Euro im Jahr
Und dann hast du eine eigene Domain
Ja und
Ihr könnt den größten Bullshit
Ever in diese Kontaktfelder
Reinschreiben
Das juckt die überhaupt nicht
Aha da ist es
Ihr braucht kein
Ähm wie nennen sie das
Wie heißt das nochmal
Diese Who is protection
Brauchst du nicht
Schreibt einfach irgendein Bullshit rein
Ich hab die Domains
Jetzt schon paar Jahre
Es hat noch keinen gejuckt
Dass ich da absolut unrealistische
Dinger reingeschrieben hab
Ja ich weiß theoretisch braucht mans
Und theoretisch ähm
Muss mans auch
Und theoretisch könnte einem auch die Domain
Weggenommen werden wenn man es nicht macht
Ähm
Die Domainanbieter
Wären bescheuert euch zu sperren
Deswegen
Weil wenn ihr euch sperren bezahlt ihr kein Geld mehr
Okay also Admin
Yes finish auf gehts
Exzellent
So jetzt muss es funktionieren
Jetzt muss es funktionieren
Wir sind auf x64
Wir sind auf einem aktuellen Ubuntu
Wir haben alles installiert was wir installieren müssen
Ha top bam
Jetzt mal hier gucken
Was macht der da im Hintergrund
Er foggt sich
Admin mit schlechtem Passwort funktioniert aber
Neuer User nicht
Man muss halt manchmal Kompromisse eingehen
Habt ihr gesehen wieviel schneller das ist
Hier drauf als auf dem Raspberry Pi
So start nextcloud
Okay also
New document cute chat
Ah jetzt funktioniert es Leute
Jetzt funktioniert es
Also ich hab meine Domain hier
Kann ich aber auch nur
Bedingt empfehlen
Ich hab die damals genommen weil die mit Abstand die billigsten waren
Die waren so übertrieben billig
Ähm
Muss mal hier ein bisschen was zu machen
Die waren so übertrieben billig da hab ich
Da hat mein Brain ausgesetzt
Ja
So bevor wir hier anfangen müssen wir erstmal noch einen neuen User anlegen
Oh User
Was ist hier New User
Max Passwort
Was hatten wir für ein Passwort? Ah jaja 123456
Ah jaja 123
Ich kann ja immer schreiben
Ah jaja
Ausrufezeichen
Okay yes
Inkognito Window
Max
Ah jaja 123 Ausrufezeichen
Achso
Okay also
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Wie gut das funktioniert
Mal gucken ob das wirklich
Eine Alternative zu Office ist
Ich bin ja noch sehr skeptisch ja
Aber sie sagen das ja selbst
Kann man das hier irgendwie einklappen?
Ne
Ah perfekt
Yes
Was ist Nextcloud wenn ich fragen darf
Der Name Cloud ist ein bisschen irreführend
Eigentlich ist es
Einen File Sync
Sowas sowas wie
Sowas wie ähm
Dropbox
Es ist im Prinzip
Einen File Sync
Web Interface
Bisschen was kann
Also Cloud ist eigentlich gar nicht mal so die richtige
Bezeichnung dafür
So also wir haben jetzt hier QChat
Wie kann man das sharen?
Sharen hier
Sharen mit
Äh
Äh sharen mit Max
Jawoll
Jetzt ist es geshared jetzt müsste ich es hier sehen oder?
Ah Chat ah jaja
So und jetzt
Kann man es jetzt zusammen bearbeiten?
Oh
Guckt mal Leute
Das funktioniert ja richtig gut
Sowas kann man da drinnen jetzt machen
Also ihr wisst ja
Ich verwende kein Office
Ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen
Also dementsprechend habe ich auch
Keinen plassen Schimmer davon
Was man da jetzt mal schön ausprobieren könnte
Okay wir machen jetzt Word Art
Qt Chat
Also als erstes brauchen wir erstmal
Ayaya Image
Copy Image kann man das hier einfügen?
Loading Image
Brauchst du eine Excel Schulung?
Leute das habe ich geschickt um Shift mit der Excel Schulung
Auf der Arbeit ich habe einfach nichts mehr geschrieben
Okay
Das funktioniert so schon mal nicht
Gibt es das ganze auch transparent?
Jetzt haben wir schon mal das erste Problem
Der Scheiß funktioniert nicht
Funktioniert schon mal nicht
Ja schon mal kaputt
Funktioniert das so?
Ne
Also Leute
So popelige Sachen
Wie Bilder einfügen funktionieren schon mal nicht
Was sollen das geben
Wenn es fertig ist
Wir sollen das verwenden wenn Bilder einfügen nicht funktioniert
Okay
Save Image
Dann gucken wir erstmal
Ob man das vielleicht so hochladen kann
Nimm ein Bild was im Nextcloud Filesystem zu finden ist
Ja das wird schon
Das muss ja funktionieren
Aber trotzdem fail dass es nicht klappt
Wie würde ich denn hier jetzt ein Bild hinzufügen
File
Äh
Ne
Wie füge ich denn hier ein Bild
Ihr wisst ja ich bin ein absoluter Office Profi
Was sowas angeht
Insert
Image
From
File
Ah
Jetzt ist es exzellent
Musik
Ah ja ja
Ah da ist es
Okay das funktioniert
Und hier hat es auch aktualisiert
Äh
Wo ist mein Fenster hin
Das Fenster ist einfach verschwunden
Lul
Lululululul
So
Wie sehr lastet das eigentlich ein Raspberry aus
Keine Ahnung
Das läuft nicht auf dem Raspberry
Wir haben es probiert auf dem Raspberry zum Laufen zu bekommen
Aber
Es wird nicht unterstützt auf dem Raspberry
Okay also das gemeinsam editieren
Funktioniert ganz okay
Wenn ich hier hinten was mache
Ach guck mal hier sieht man auch wo man editiert
Okay
Ist doch eigentlich ganz nett
So
Insert Image
Oh Chart
Das ist für die ganzen Business Leute ist das unglaublich wichtig
Wir brauchen Charts
Stonks brauchen wir
Richtige Stonks
Also Pie Chart
Pie Chart
Okay
Oh Kokona
Äh
Ah
Okay okay okay also
Äh
Alter
Wie editiert man das
Okay also
Es ist hier Orange
Orange
Blue
Ne
Haha bestes Chart überhaupt
Da wären wir so zieh drauf gekommen
Oh Blau ist Orange und Blue ist
Oh das ist
Das ist Brainfuck jetzt Leute
Hehehe
Kann man das Overlayen
Kann ich jetzt
Eieiei klein machen und da oben drüber machen
Nee nee das funktioniert nicht
Das wäre zu advanced
Chart Title
Lull W größer Kek W
Okay
Das funktioniert prinzipiell
Ne
Mir gefallen die Listen hier oben nicht wirklich
Oh Word Art
Leute wir brauchen ein Word Art
Unbedingt
Word Art ist huge important für alle Business Stonks Leute
Die brauchen das
Word Art
Jawoll
Beste
Ja
Ohne Word Art geht gar nix hier
Share es mal public
Und lass den Chat editieren
Das ist bei mir im Internet weg
Ich könnte es nicht mal public sharen
Word Art
Das ist aber kein richtiges Word Art
Richtiges Word Art muss gebogen sein
Und hässlich
Ja genau Churok
Das muss gebogen sein
Geht das vielleicht
Ne ne
Aber ist doch ganz nett
Wenn man so viele Sachen braucht
Kann man es doch dafür verwenden
So wir machen jetzt mal
Wir machen jetzt mal ne
Ne Präsentation
Mal gucken ob das funktioniert
Ich hab übrigens im Chat ein paar Dinger übersehen
Ich muss mal kurz Chat hoch scrollen
Ne oder
Hab doch nix großartig übersehen
Also falls ich was übersehen hab
Müsst ihr es nochmal kurz
In Chat schreiben
Na klar hat Neux Cloud Internet Zugriff
Werde ich dann sonst installieren sollen
Was Wrapping Style rechts
Was meinst ihr
Oh
Das hier
Das ist mir zu advanced Office Magic
Hier
Zu advanced Office Magic
Oh Leute
Es funktioniert
Man kann doch ein hässliches Word Art machen
Hier
Jawoll
Da hab ich drauf gewartet
Das brauchen wir
Es muss so richtig
Es muss so richtig scheiße aussehen
Erst dann ist es ein gutes Word Art
So und jetzt müssen wir mal den Chat probieren
Genau den Chat müssen wir nämlich probieren
Chat
Cute Chat
Send
Und wo weiß ich jetzt
Dass ich ne Chat Nachricht gekriegt hab
Lull
Test
Chat ist broken
Geht nicht
Chat ist kaputt
Chat
Geht nicht
Seht ihr das Leute Chat ist kaputt
Cute Chat
Also Chat Chat geht nicht
Chat ist
Hinüber
Aber man kann doch hier oben bestimmt
Chatten
Irgendwie
Fax
Guck mal hier oben hab ich jetzt nen Kontakt gefunden
Aber was bringt es mir
Ich hab nen Kontakt gefunden
Hab wenn ich damit überhaupt nichts machen kann
Guck mal
Ich hab nen Kontakt gefunden mit dem ich absolut nichts machen kann
All Contacts
New Contacts
Es könnte auch sein das liegt daran
Weil ich Admin bin
Warte mal
Ich leg mir nochmal nen User an
Noch nen zweiten Test User
Max2
Ayaya123
Funktioniert die Suche
Probieren wir dann gleich
Die Suche war nämlich bisher immer Müll
Ups
Ayaya123
Ausrufe zeigen
Don't save
Next next next
Create Document
Presentation machen wir jetzt
So und
Wir sharen die Presentation
Jetzt mit
Wie sharet man hier überhaupt was
Ah
Das ist GUI Leute
Presentation sharen wir mit
Max2 sharet mit Max1
Perfekt
Excellent
Presentation da ist es
Ok
Funktioniert sehr gut
Ähm bisschen kleiner machen
Hier was sieht
So wie kann man das jetzt schön hässlich machen
Öh
Uääh
Igitt
Das sieht ja wirklich aus
Wie 1995
Äh
Also wenn ich so ne Präsentation zu sehen bekomme
Da muss ich ja
Da muss ich Instant Kotzreflex äh
Ja
So geht dann hier der
Igitt sieht das eklig aus
Meine Güte
Insert
Textart
Wir müssen ein hässliches Wordart hin machen
Das sieht hier schon ganz anders aus als beim anderen
Ha
So ähm
Geht der Chat hier jetzt
Chat
Du Chat
Nö
Der Chat ist RIP
Der Chat ist RIP der funktioniert nicht
Das ist ja schon mal sehr ähm
Ernüchternd
Das nicht mal so grundlegende Sachen funktionieren
Was machen die Temperatur vom Raspberry
Gucken wir mal
Der ist bei 64 Grad
Hubelock
Oh Leute
Das kann sein mit Hubelock
Den Kram hier flame
Ähm ne ne
Ne
Aber wir reloaden das
Trotzdem mal ohne Hubelock
Wir reloaden
Wir reloaden es mal ohne Hubelock
Und gucken wir mal ob es dann funktioniert
Chat sollte
Auf der rechten Seite zu sehen sein
Wat
Der Chat sollte hier zu sehen sein oder
Warum sollte ich hier was in den Chat schreiben
Und es nicht hier sehen das wäre ja
Hier
Aus dem rechts sehe ich auch nichts hier Chat
Cute cute Chatte
Huge Presentation Mode
Bam
Ne ne ne also der Chat ist kaputt
Der funktioniert nicht
Contacts
Warum ist in den Contacts
Wie adde ich denn Leute zu meinen Contacts
Wie funktioniert das
Ok
Verschieben wir den Kram hier mal
Wie funktioniert das überhaupt
Ähm hier
Kann man auch nicht anklicken oder
Wie adde ich Leute zu meinen
Find Contacts
Da kann man immer nichts anklicken
Im Kontakten Tab nicht
Ne ich will
Ich will Max 1 adden
Weil hier oben ist ja Max 1
Aber mit dem kann ich ja überhaupt nichts machen
Da kann ich auch nicht chatten oder so
Chat
Ok
Dann schauen wir mal ob die
Ob die Volltextsuche funktioniert
Ok hier haben wir eine
Read me
Ok read me md
Lull w ist größer keck w
Twitch Chat
Chat beste
Omega Lull
Speichern
Open sidebar
So jetzt haben wir das gespeichert
Jetzt hoffe ich das ich das über die Suche finde
So machen wir mal
Über die Suche
Suche
Chat
Die Suche ist
Immer noch Müll
Ach ne Moment
Hat er das jetzt gefunden
Ich glaube der hat es gefunden
Vergesst es mal ich glaube der hat es gefunden
Ne ne das ist noch das alte
Vielleicht
Ja ich guck mal gleich beim Admin Account
Ob wir das irgendwie aktivieren
Was ist denn das hier oben eigentlich
Warum steht denn das da immer noch da
Kann das mal weg gehen
Was ist das da oben
Warum steht das da
Hä
Was ist das hier oben
Warum steht das hier oben da
Was ist das überhaupt
Warum steht das da
Ach weil ich in dem Ordner drinne bin
Oder was
Ah ok
Ok das ergibt Sinn
Chat
Ne
Nope
Die Suche ist immer noch kaputt
Ok ich lösch mal den ganzen Kram
Der standardmäßig drauf ist
Vielleicht geht es ja nicht richtig
Ne
Moment
Wie löscht man überhaupt nochmal
Ne
Actions
Massive Brain
New Folder
Notes
Gehen wir mal rein
Ganz einfach neues Textdokument
Chat.txt
Ganz billig
Einfach mal
Eins zwei drei
Chat
Twitch Chat
Lull
Poggers
Pog
So das heißt er sollte jetzt ja was finden
Wenn ich jetzt Chat suche sollte er das hier finden
Ok
Chat na gut jetzt findet er die Datei
Wollen wir ja nicht
Na Twitch muss ich suchen
Ok
Das
Der findet es nicht
Die Volltextsuche ist kaputt
Die funktioniert wieder nicht
Das war ja das ist immer
Das ist eines meiner größten Probleme mit Nextcloud gewesen
Dass die Volltextsuche nie funktioniert
Und wozu brauche ich sowas ohne
Volltextsuche ich weiß doch nicht wo mein Zeug liegt
Kek weh
Kek
Weh
Ne
Ok die Suche funktioniert nicht
Ähm
Vielleicht müssen wir die Suche noch einschalten
Und vielleicht müssen wir auch den Chat noch einschalten
Also werden wir nochmal Admin
Mit Big Brain Passwort
Example MD haben wir hier
Documents
Kann ich mal nach Documents vielleicht suchen
Doc
Sollte er eigentlich auch finden
Ne
Also
Die Suche ist nach wie vor Müll
Vielleicht muss man aber noch irgendwas aktivieren
Search
Äh
Seht ihr das irgendwo
Also ich sehe meine Suche hier unten nicht aber
Irgendwo
Äh Overview
Vielleicht hier
Vielleicht müssen wir den Kram noch irgendwie einschalten
Support
Äh
Sharing
Steht da irgendwas von Chat
Dark Mode
Teaming
Ne da kann man nur das da ändern
Security
Stativiert man
Die Suche
What
Ich dachte das ist mittlerweile alles eingebaut
Ich will nicht 20 Sachen neu
Dazu installieren müssen
Und ich will garantiert
Mir kein Elasticsearch
Selbst installieren müssen
Ihr meine sind die noch sind die noch bei Trost
Ich will mir noch kein Elasticsearch selbst installieren müssen
Das ich äh
Meine Dateien durchsuchen kann
Dann muss es irgendwie anders funktionieren
Ok
Ok was gibts was gibts denn noch für Apps
Also
Contacts ist ja schon mal irgendwie komisch
Ich meine ich dachte mir
Ich dachte mir ich kann Max jetzt ne Chat Nachricht
Schreiben aber irgendwie
Wir müssen bestimmt noch irgendwelche
Apps Talk Talk Apps und so installieren
Talk
Ok Talk
Ne Talk ist ja
Ne Talk halt
Wow
Ein Error
Funktioniert ja erst rein
Ah Yes einfach zweimal klicken
Chat
Ok das geht schon mal gar nicht mehr
Die Chat App
Ok aber wir haben Talk wir haben Talk
Dann probieren wir das jetzt aus Talk
Wo ist Talk hier Talk
Äh
Max
Hallo Max
Achso ich muss mich erst mal einloggen
So ob das jetzt funktioniert
WTF
Ah hier
Und man kriegt es auch hier oben angezeigt
Ok das ist tatsächlich ganz nett
So krieg ich jetzt ne neue Nachricht
Zugestellt wenn ich jetzt hier oben sage
Keine Ahnung neuen Message
Ach komm
Leute
Warum krieg ich keine
Warum No Notifications ich hab ne neue
Chat Nachricht gekriegt
Das ist so hakelig der Kram
Das ist doch nicht ernsthaft ne Alternative
Zu irgendwas was funktioniert
Muss ich im Talk Reiter sein
Ja es wäre total beknackt
Wenn ich im Talk Reiter sein muss
Hier hat das erkannt
Das ich neue Messages brauch
All Messages Chat Notifications
Ist an
Oh gibt nix
Was ich hab
Ich hab doch nicht Notifications Disabled
Ich hab gesagt
Dismiss All Notifications
Ich hab keine Notifications Disabled
Ok
Ähm
Tja wir machen das jetzt
Ok wir machen Add
Add Max
Hallo
Etf
Add Max
Ah das klappt
Guckt das funktioniert
Wenn man erwähnt wird funktioniert
Ok
Das ist sogar in Ordnung
Jetzt kann ich die Notifications
Nicht mehr dismissen
Ach jetzt so
Ja gut
Ist auch das ganz ok
Start Call ich ruf mich jetzt mal selbst an
Ah jetzt Excellent
Excellent Talk
Nachrichten vom Admin
Braucht man eigentlich
Ne das ist komplett Overrated
Was natürlich viel cooler wär
Wenn man das
Sehen könnte
Während man gerade
Editiert ne
Also sprich wenn wir hier gerade
Wenn man hier gerade am Editieren ist
Machen wir das ganze nochmal
Ich share nochmal was
Sharen wir nochmal mit
Äh
Wir
Vielleicht geht das jetzt
Wenn man schon zusammen
Im Chat ist
Man könnte einfach so machen
Lul
Achso hier
Add Max
Alderlade was geht
Hallo
So wirklich
Konsistent ist das ganze nicht
Was Chat rechts
Ah hier
Discuss this file
Discuss
Ja aber man kriegt ja davon
Überhaupt nichts mit
Ach guck mal
Da ist die Notification
Nice
Dismiss
Das heißt ich kann jetzt auch hier sagen
Ne Moment
Wie bin ich da jetzt hier nochmal drauf
Gekommen?
Ah hier
Comments Chat
This file sucks
Ah
Yes
Excellent
Five hat
Fine
Gehen Emojis? Nein geht nicht
Ah ja gut
Ah ja okay
Also
So behelfsmäßig wenn man
Wenn man unbedingt Office braucht
Und partout keine
Kohle ausgeben will für was
Dann kann man das verwenden
Kann das sein
Dass der Chat
Dass dieser Chat
Hier dann da
Landet
Ne der Chat hier funktioniert
Einfach mal prinzipiell gar nicht
Und hier kann ich ja auch nicht in den
Kann ich hier in den Chat
Ah
Ja so funktioniert das
Ich kann jetzt hier rumeditieren
Also ich kann jetzt hier rumeditieren
Und neben sehe ich den Chat
Ich editier jetzt hier mal rum
Und wenn jetzt der Admin was schreibt
Dann bist du fertig
Dann ploppt das hier auf
Das ist doch ganz gut
So viele Chats bin vermiert
Ja ich finde auch die
Oberfläche könnte ein bisschen
Noob freundlicher gestaltet werden
Ich meine es gibt nen Chat hier
Der nicht funktioniert
Der ist einfach defekt der geht einfach gar nicht
Der ist einfach nicht vorhanden
Der Chat
Es gibt den Talk Chat
Und es gibt den Chat zu dem jeweiligen
File
Das ist schon ein bisschen verwirrend
Was gibt es denn sonst noch für Apps
Chat Overload
Ich meine es wäre cool wenn hier oben einfach irgendwie Chat Nachricht
Dann gezeigt wäre
Neue Chat Nachricht kannst du nachgucken
Es gibt in der Mobile App keines so echt nicht
Wenn es keine Sync Option
Also wenn man nicht Syncen kann mit der Mobile App
Warum soll man dann die Mobile App überhaupt verwenden
Ne Spreadsheet mache ich nicht
Das ist mir zu
Das ist mir zu Office mäßig jetzt
Ähm
Hä wie es kann nur Daten Syncen aber es gibt keine Sync Option
Verstehe ich nicht
Wenn man Daten Syncen kann hat es doch die Option zu Syncen
What
Oder meinst du es gibt keine
Optionen
Für dieses Synchronisieren
Also sprich man kann nichts einstellen beim Synchronisieren
Okay Leute
Ich muss euch sagen diese Präsentationsvorlagen
Die sehen echt schlecht aus
Die sehen wirklich grausam aus
Boah
Igitt
Geh fort
So wir gucken mal was es sonst noch für Apps gibt
Was man sonst noch mal ausprobieren könnte
Also das ist ja alles beim Alten hier geblieben
Ich muss euch sagen es fühlt sich ein bisschen lahm an
Es fühlt sich lahm an
Die Oberfläche
Man darf nicht vergessen
Das ganze läuft quasi hier auf einer VM
Direkt auf dem gleichen Rechner
Also das müsste sich eigentlich ziemlich schnell anfühlen
Das sind 1 zu 1 Kopien von den Powerpoint Vorlagen
Ja aber wahrscheinlich von Powerpoint 2003 oder so
Also mittlerweile
Ich komme ja gerade in den
In den Genuss
Aktuell auf der Arbeit
Eine Powerpoint Präsentation machen zu dürfen
Mit Powerpoint
Da bin ich ja schon ganz heiß drauf
Kann mich kaum halten
Vor Freude auf Powerpoint
Und das neue Powerpoint 365
Muss ich zugeben
Auch als jemand der
Echt nie Office verwendet
Ist ganz in Ordnung
Die
Designvorschläge die es bringt
Sind meistens besser als das
Was man gebaut hat
Man hat Emojis
Und wichtigste Sache natürlich bei Präsentation
Und Imagefonts
Und so
Das neue Powerpoint ist schon ganz gut
Und läuft halt auch im Browser
Wir gucken jetzt mal was es für Apps zum Thema Suche gibt
Office und Textsearch
Hier Search haben wir
Fulltextsearch
Was davon muss ich denn jetzt aktivieren
Ich mach neuerdings in jede Präsentation
Ich mach mindestens ein Emoji irgendwo rein
Ich finde das wirkt irgendwie
Enable
Okay
Das ist excellent
Okay das heißt wir legen jetzt mal ne neue Textdatei an
Search.txt
Oh
Ohje was hab ich jetzt angelegt
Ja das muss auch funktionieren
Lulwe
Bra
Jetzt haben wir das gespeichert
Und jetzt suchen wir mal
Ach
Da muss man jetzt bestimmt noch irgendwelche Settings auswählen
Also ich würde jetzt eigentlich erwarten
Wenn ich jetzt hier nach
Lulwe suche
Finde ich die Datei
Mach ich aber nicht
Das heißt jetzt gehen wir mal in die Settings
Und schauen ob man da noch irgendwas zur Suche einstellen muss
Äh das war
Das war Elasticsearch glaub ich
Hier Fulltextsearch
Ne
Ah das ist doof
Das ist echt blöd
Ich glaube ich muss jetzt einfach eine Elasticsearch zu installieren
Dafür das ich ne Fulltextsuche hab
Echt nicht
Sowas muss
Ja und außerdem könnte man doch ganz simpel einfach
Deckex durch crappen
Zumindest Build-In anbieten oder
So ne ganz simple Suche
Die einfach alle
Allen Text durch crapt
Für dich
Würde doch schon reichen
Die meisten Leute haben da ne paar Megabyte Daten drin
Und da ist das ultra schnell die Sachen zu crappen
Verwende es halt einfach für File Sync schon seit Jahren und dafür ist es gut.
Also im Kern funktioniert das.
Aber alle anderen Features, die jetzt da dabei kommen und so,
ich merke nach einer halben Stunde Verwenden, dass es einfach hakt.
Dass es nicht so polished ist irgendwie.
Weiß nicht.
Nicht angenehm zu verwenden das meiste.
Für File Sync ist es gut.
Also sprich die Kerndisziplin mit File Sync, das ist in Ordnung.
Das klappt.
Und auch sich so die Basic Sachen im Webinterface anzeigen lassen ist okay.
Ich verwende es im Endeffekt nur für File Sync und für Kalenderkontakte.
Also so die Kerndisziplin funktioniert.
Up Bundles, was gibt es denn hier sonst noch?
Deck, was ist denn Deck?
Ein Kanban Board.
Oh, das ist was.
Das ist was für die agilen Leute unter uns.
Chat, seid ihr agil?
Seid ihr bereit für das Kanban Board?
Agile.
Agile, cute Chat.
Huge Agile.
Social Sharing, Twitter, Announcement Center, Dashboard.
Was ist denn Zenodo?
Brauche alles nicht.
Ah, ich müsste mir echt ein eigenes Elasticsearch installieren, dafür dass es funktioniert.
Und das ist wirklich komisch.
Wie ist deine Backup Strategie für den privaten Nextcloud?
Meine Backup Strategie aktuell ist total simpel.
In der Sauberkiste ist eine System SSD drin und eine Magnet Festplatte.
Also eine normale Festplatte.
Eine normale Festplatte und es hängt einfach am USB Anschluss noch eine Festplatte dran,
wo nachts einmal AirSynced wird.
Also richtig...
richtig oldschool pepega backup wird einfach einmal nachts erst und fertig
und auch nicht alles gameplay aufnahmen und so zum beispiel nicht nur wichtige
sachen das ist nicht so viel einmal nachts erst fertig ich habe das
zurückgefahren wie gesagt ich habe ja hier die letzten jahre den übelst fetten
aufbau gehabt mit einem 48 kern server mit mit 3 x 10 terabyte zfs platten
drauf mit offside backup mit geschiss und allem und ganz ehrlich es ist mir
für daheim ich meine es ist cool ja das ist letztendlich macht mir das immer
noch spaß auch wenn ich da jetzt schon seit der ganzen weile in dem bereich
arbeite aber es macht mir auch immer noch spaß privat mit sowas umzuspielen
aber es war einfach extrem offer kill für mich daheim
kein
321 naja so halb so halb ich meine das ist das nextcloud zeug also die wirklich
wichtigen sachen so wie der passwort save meine privaten notes notiz
geschichten und den ganzen kram der ist über nextcloud gesynkt auf zwei rechner
plus auf dem server liegt das sind ja schon mal drei und dann ist es halt noch
auf eine platte gespiegelt das war's also das offside 1 gibt es
aktuell nicht was man machen könnte ist es ist ja nicht viel
das sind ja das lasst uns das mal eine gigabyte an sachen sein das ist
wahrscheinlich viel zu viel ich könnte das wohle probleme offside backup
nehmen dann einfäß abfackeln habe ich ein problem aktuell
hab ich habe dann ist mein passwort safe und zeug weg da müsste ich erstmal
ewig recover aber im kern scheint dann kam ja zu funktionieren was sie an preisen
wirklich rundes gefühl gibt es mir immer noch nicht wenn ich das ausprobieren also rundекс
wirklich rundes gefühl gibt es mir immer noch nicht wenn ich das ausprobieren also
also rundex als passwort name direkt abgibsetzen und dann Geschichte im internet
das ausprobiere. Also, Grund
fühlt sich nicht an. Und was ich halt
immer noch enttäuschend finde, ist,
dass keine Suche
eingebaut ist. Ich will mir kein eigenes
Elasticsearch installieren dafür.
Was hältst du vom Programm wie Drivebooster?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist. Was ist
Drivebooster? Was ist das?
IOBIT. Ich glaube nicht,
dass ich sowas haben will. Was ist
das? Oh, ne.
Das ist Müll.
Ja.
Schon die. Das ist
Müll. Ich muss mir nur dieses
UI angucken. Das ist definitiv Müll. Braucht kein
Mensch. Ach du Scheiße. Ne, bloß
nicht. Bloß auf gar keinen Fall.
Installier das bloß nicht auf deinem Rechner.
Ich finde, es arbeiten einfach zu wenig
Leute am Next-Hot. Ich glaube auch,
dass das Problem ist, weil was man sieht ist,
dass im Ansatz, im Ansatz
ist alles da.
Es fehlt so das Finish
irgendwie. Wisst ihr, wie ich meine? Also,
vom Ansatz her ist alles da und ist
alles eigentlich auch gut und auch
gut durchdacht.
Aber es fehlt so das
Polish, so das Finish irgendwie.
Dass du sagen würdest, oh, das macht richtig Spaß zu
verwenden und es ist
intuitiv und es macht einfach, was es soll
out of the box und das fehlt
noch so ein bisschen. Aber das fehlt auch
schon. Es fehlt Nextcloud schon immer und
es hat Owncloud auch schon immer gefehlt.
Was du meinst, dass Office im Namen,
da will ich mir braucht es kein Office im Namen haben.
Ich bin ja eh Office-Hater.
Ich verwende für nichts Office.
Außer wenn es
sich gar nicht anders vermeiden lässt.
Und für die Geschichte auf der Arbeit,
verwenden wir aktuell auch nur
PowerPoint, weil ich das mit jemand
anderem zusammen mache.
Und der hat die Sache schon angefangen
in PowerPoint. Was fehlt da zum Beispiel
eine funktionierende Volltext-Suche, die
out of the box halt einfach sucht,
ohne dass ich mein eigenes Elasticsearch betreiben
muss. Wenn ich im Detail
gucke, fehlt da wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Ecke mehr.
Vor allem in Details, ja.
Ich find's auch nicht so hundertprozentig schlüssig,
dass es
drei verschiedene Sachen
gibt, wo man chatten kann.
Der eine Chat funktioniert gar nicht.
Der eine Chat ist eine eigene App und
der andere Chat ist pro Datei.
Das könnte man bestimmt schöner integrieren.
Ja, so klein sind so Kleinigkeiten.
80% ist gut, 80% ist durchdacht.
Es fehlen, es fehlen aber einfach so die
letzten 20%, um das Ding wirklich zu polieren.
Man darf aber eins muss man natürlich an der Stelle auch noch mal sagen.
Es ist kostenlos.
Und für das was sie die letzten Jahre
über gemacht haben, darf man ja auch nicht,
darf man ja auch nicht komplett jetzt
irgendwie so übersehen wegwischen.
Es ist natürlich toll, was sie
hingekriegt haben.
Unterm Strich ist es bei mir halt so,
ich bin vielleicht auch ein bisschen
ein bisschen immer sehr pingelig bei
sowas.
Bei mir muss ich halt auch kostenlose und
und auch Open-Source-Software
so an dem messen, was ich halt
unabhängig davon, ob eine Software was kostet oder nicht,
was ich halt gerne
benutzen würde, ja.
Also sprich, das, was für mich halt sinnvoll
ist. Und
wenn das halt
teilweise sehr hakelig funktioniert,
dann sage ich halt, dass es teilweise hakelig
funktioniert. Ich meine, warum gibt es drei
Chats? Warum gibt es einen Chat, der überhaupt
nicht funktioniert? Warum gibt es keine
Out-of-the-Box-Suche, die funktioniert, ohne dass
ich mein eigenes
Elasticsearch betreiben muss?
Warum sehen die Vorlagen für
die Präsentation aus, wie von 2005?
Äh, Basti, das stimmt,
aber man darf nicht vergessen,
das war schon immer so. Also
bei OwnCloud und NextCloud, du hattest
immer schon das Gefühl, ich verfolge
das ja seit fünf Jahren, also schon ewig, das
Projekt. Ähm,
du hast immer das Gefühl, dass das, was drinnen
ist, zu 80% gut funktioniert
und auch okay ist, aber die letzten 20%
fehlen. Und es kommt halt immer mehr
dabei, aber so der
Polish kommt irgendwie nie.
Auch, dass sich die ganze Oberfläche unglaublich
träge anfühlt, ja.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
es ist, hier ist nichts
drinnen. Das sind die Beispieldateien
und zwei User. Und dann
gibt es solche Dinger,
wo man nicht so genau weiß, warum.
80% gut und
im Kern macht es das, was es soll,
nämlich File, Sync, Kontakte und
Kalender. Dafür ist es okay.
Die anderen Sachen, wenn man die anderen
Sachen so als Beiwerk betrachtet,
dann ist es in Ordnung.
Auch eine Sache kann ich
euch auch nochmal zeigen, die ich halt schon
lange, lange vermisse.
Und zwar
Notes.
Die, ähm,
die Notiz-App, was ist denn Quick Notes?
Achso.
Die Notiz-App,
wir müssen mal gucken, ob das mittlerweile funktioniert.
Ja,
Basti, mir ist klar, warum das so ist.
Mir ist vollkommen klar,
dass die nicht die Ressourcen von Microsoft haben.
Keine Frage, ja.
Ich erwarte ja auch nicht,
dass die das jetzt machen, nur weil ich das sag.
Aber trotzdem muss ich, egal welche
Software, wenn ich die verwende, irgendwie
auch daran messen mit,
was ich mir halt, was ich mir so,
was ich halt gerne verwenden will.
Ich hab halt gewisse Ansprüche, egal ob
die Software kostenlos ist oder was
kostet. Und ich hätte beispielsweise
gar keine Schmerzen damit,
da was für zu bezahlen.
Generell ist es,
ist es, ist es bei mir bei vielen Sachen so,
dass ich aktuell den ein, ich nehm den einfacheren Weg,
der, der für mich am wenigsten Zeit braucht
und der für mich am besten zu bedienen ist.
Zum Beispiel, ich lad mir keine Filme mehr
per Torrent, sonst was runter, ich hab mir einfach
einen Netflix und damals so einen Prime Video Account gekauft.
Funktioniert, kostet Geld,
hat vieles, was mir auf den Sack geht, auch,
ja, aber ist das, was am einfachsten tut.
So, und eine Sache, die mir immer bei
dem Notizprogramm auch auf den Keks
gegangen ist, dass man
hier Sachen schreiben konnte.
Hallo, 1, 2, 3, blub.
Äh, dass man die Dinger nicht durchsuchen
konnte.
Hier zum Beispiel, 1, 2, 3, bam.
Findet keine Notizen.
Und Notizen,
die man nicht durchsuchen kann, ist halt doof.
No search result für 1, 2, 3.
Da ist ja offensichtlich nichts da.
Oder hab ich das nicht gespeichert, oder was,
was ist... Ich mein,
wozu brauch ich ein Notizprogramm,
in dem ich nicht suchen kann?
Ist halt unsinnig.
Äh, wie viel Gigabyte stehen da denn zur Verfügung?
Ähm,
100, 240G?
Haben wir gerade dranhängen
an SSD? Ach, ne.
Das ist ja in der VM.
Ne, ne, fast nix.
8G oder so.
Mir persönlich wär's lieber,
man würde auch,
man würde halt die Basic-Funktion
wirklich mal
richtig, äh,
richtig polishen, ja?
Also, Talk
ist so ne Sache, brauch ich nicht unbedingt.
Auch dieses, auch die ganzen Chat-Funktionen
und so, ist nice, brauch ich auch
nicht unbedingt. Äh, für mich
persönlich wär's halt einfach am besten,
das, das GUI wird sich halt richtig schön schnell
und responsive anfühlen. Vielleicht auch
irgendwie ein bisschen intuitiver
bedienbar sein, weil vieles ist schon
bisschen hakelig. Vor allem ne Suche, die
eingebaut ist, wär unglaublich wichtig.
Any cuties
in Chat?
Nicht nur in Chat. Ähm,
ne Suche, die eingebaut ist,
dass, ähm,
ach, es gibt viele Kleinigkeiten, ja?
Gibt es denn Cloud-Dienst für Massenspeicher
als Privatperson ohne Kredit aufzunehmen?
Kommt drauf an, wie viel du haben willst.
Gibt jede Menge.
Ja, ich will das jetzt auch nicht zu sehr flamen,
ich hab's ja schon gesagt,
ähm, weil man sich überlegt, mit was, mit
wie wenig Leuten, die da dran arbeiten und was
sie in den letzten Jahren geschafft haben, ist das natürlich schon
ne, ne große Leistung, das ganze
Ding hier auf die Beine zu stellen, ja.
Aber ich hab trotzdem das Gefühl,
es wird sich auch ein bisschen zu,
bisschen zu sehr auf
Features, äh, konzentriert,
so nach dem Motto, wir müssen da neue Sachen
einbauen, Office Collaboration
und, und Gedöns,
wohingegen die Notiz-App noch nicht mal
Notizen durchsuchen kann, was sie komplett
unbrauchbar macht. Ähm,
100 Terabyte!
Äh,
100 Terabyte ist saumäßig
viel. Das kostet
Kohle. Also 100
äh, 100 Terabyte sind, sind, sind
nicht, sind nicht ohne, wenn du die
Cloud-mäßig, ähm,
also je nachdem, wie du drauf zugreifen willst
natürlich, ja.
Wenn du das nicht irgendwie als Filesystem
mounten willst, wenn dir irgendwie Zugriff über
Web-UI oder so reichen,
da gibt's bestimmt Varianten,
ähm,
aber ich hab meine Zweifel, dass es
einen ordentlichen
Anbieter gibt, wo man 100
Terabyte, äh,
kostengünstig
hosten kann, vor allem
der auch
eine gewisse Performance hat, dass ich die im Zweifelsfall auch
wieder runterkriege.
Da wirst du mit irgendwelchen
kostenlosen Sachen nicht, nicht, sonderlich weit
kommen, denk ich. Es gibt zwar,
es gibt zwar Sachen wie, ich glaub Amazon,
ne, Amazon hat nicht mehr, hat nicht mehr, äh,
Unlimited, ne?
Es gibt ja, es gibt ein paar Anbieter,
die haben Unlimited.
Aber da weiß ich nicht,
ob man da mit 100 Terabyte wirklich
äh, weit kommt,
ja.
Naja, aber das, du musst ja kein Elastix, also,
erstens gibt's ja noch weit
mehr Möglichkeiten,
eine popelige Suche über Textfiles
zu ermöglichen, als mit Elastixsearch.
Und, ähm,
es gibt mit Sicherheit
kleine
Suchmaschinen, die man integrieren könnte.
Müssen wir mal auf GitHub gucken,
es gibt bestimmt irgendwelche Go-Geschichten, die wahrscheinlich
5 MB groß sind und, und auf jedem
x-beliebigen Linux laufen.
Ähm, alternativ könnte man was anbieten,
was einfach die Dateien durchgrabbt.
Das wär total simpel. Das würde natürlich
nicht für PDFs richtig funktionieren
und auch nicht für, für, äh, für
Powerpoint-Geschichten oder so, aber
es würde für Markdown und Text und Nodes schon mal
ordentlich funktionieren. Das ist ja, das wär ja schon mal
was.
Ich erwarte gar nicht, dass ich, äh,
dass ich Bilder nach Text
oder sowas durchsuchen kann,
aber, dass
Notizen durchsuchbar
sind, das würde ich schon erwarten.
Weil das macht dieses Notizprogramm
komplett überflüssig. Guck mal,
ich mein, wenn ich hier,
wenn ich hier viele Notizen angelegt
hab, ja, und ich such jetzt die
Notiz, wo 0w drinne steht, und man
findet nix. Das ist halt
unbrauchbar als Notizprogramm.
Die einzige Möglichkeit, die ich
da eventuell habe, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das
mit Notizen funktioniert ist,
dass ich mir ein eigenes Elasticsearch hauste, da hab ich keinen
Bock drauf.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es ein OCR gibt, aber
das erwarte ich gar nicht, dass das out of the box da ist.
Ja, ne, ja, Basti,
könnt, könnte ich eventuell machen,
will ich gar nicht. Ich will's
einfach nur benutzen.
Ich will's einfach nur benutzen.
Und wie gesagt, ich sag nicht, dass die das machen müssen, bloß
weil ich das haben will.
Es wär aber für mich ne wichtige Funktion und ne
Funktion, die für mich nicht so ganz
nachvollziehbar eben fehlt.
Weil, wozu
gibt es ein Notizprogramm, wenn ich Notizen nicht
durchsuchen kann? Das ist so Basic
Feature. Das wäre so das, was ich
einbauen würde, direkt
nachdem ich das Icon festgelegt
habe. Ein Notizprogramm
ohne Suchfunktion ist
unsinnig. So, gibt's noch irgendwelche
Sachen, die wir ausprobieren können?
Eins muss man aber nochmal
wirklich, also, wie gesagt, ich verfolge
das schon ne ganze Weile. Im
Vergleich zu den ersten OnCloud-Varianten
hat sich unglaublich viel getan.
Ähm, die erste
OnCloud-Geschichte, die ich damals installiert
hab, die hat Dateien
gelöscht.
Beim Syncen. Und
das ist tatsächlich mittlerweile
zuverlässig und funktioniert, ja.
Ich hab damals versucht,
mit einem der ersten
OnCloud-Varianten, äh, mit einem der ersten
OnCloud-Versionen, hab ich versucht
von meinem, von meiner iOS
Notizen-App über
WebDAV Sachen zu syncen.
Das hat prinzipiell auch funktioniert,
bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo manchmal Dateien
verschwunden sind. Das war halt, gerade bei
einem Notizprogramm ziemlich doof.
Weil, da verschwinden
nicht einfach Dateien, sondern da verschwinden
halt dann, da hab ich nicht so
viele Dateien, dafür steht da relativ viel drinnen.
Das war echt
doof, ja. Das war
unbrauchbar zum Zeitpunkt, zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt. Da hat sich viel getan,
das ist sehr zuverlässig mittlerweile.
Aber was ich halt sagen
will, ist nur, ich,
die meisten neuen Features sind
für mich persönlich jetzt halt nicht so
so wichtig, ja. Ich brauch
keine, keine, die ganze Collaboration
Geschichte nicht, auch die ganze Chat
Geschichte und sowas ist für mich
relativ, relativ überflüssig.
Es gibt bestimmt genug Leute,
die das verwenden. Für mich wär's aber
halt deutlich wichtiger, dass ich meine
Notizen durchsuchen kann.
Gibt es nicht Bounties für die Funktion? Ja,
ja, ja. Also ich denke mal,
dass die auch sowas haben. Viele haben ja so
Code-Bounty-Programme mittlerweile.
Mal gucken, wie der Editor lag beim
aufgehen. Wo kann man
eigentlich Dark Theme einstellen?
Gibt's da ein offizielles?
Ah, yes, Dark Theme.
Dyslexia-Font.
Oh!
Was ist Dyslexia?
Guck, schau
mir das sowas. Das ist das, was
ich meine, was halt einfach unpolished ist.
Warum ist das hier unten noch weiß?
Mich nervt's halt, dass ich so Sachen
immer nach zwei Minuten benutzen finde.
Und warum ist das überhaupt nicht gesteamt?
Es ist einfach
unpolished. Ich glaub, das kann man sagen, ohne dass man
da jemand auf den Schlips tritt.
Da fehlen halt so die letzten 20%.
...
Feinschliff. Nennen wir's einfach mal
Feinschliff. Ja.
So, Leute. Was macht eigentlich der Raspberry?
Wie warm ist er denn mittlerweile geworden?
54 Grad.
Gut. Ich glaube, wärmer wird er nicht mehr.
Wir haben jetzt
1,5 Stunden
haben wir CPU volle Pulle laufen.
Ich denke mal, 54 Grad
mit dem Gehäuse ist
top. Ja, mehr geht nicht.
So, jetzt habt ihr die Auswahl, Leute.
Wollen wir noch irgendwie
was machen? Wisst ihr was?
Ich geh jetzt mal aufs Klo und hol mir was zu essen.
Dann gucken wir noch
eine Runde Essen-Stream.
Gucken wir noch ein bisschen Videos.
Essen-Videos.
Ich futter was.
Und wir können noch ein bisschen hier
FAQ-Gedöns machen.
Wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt, Leute, sagt mir gleich Bescheid.
Ich geh jetzt mal kurz pinkeln.
Also, es kann durchaus sein, wenn ihr's jetzt
schreibt, dass ich's nicht sehe.
Und ich guck gleich in den Chat und dann
gucken wir uns das Ganze nochmal an.
Ich bleib wieder da.
So.
Hier ist ich wieder.
Äh, das ist ein Raspberry Pi 4.
Ja, warum heißt das eigentlich B?
Es gibt ja nur B.
Für was steht das B eigentlich?
Steht das etwa
für USB-C?
So.
Gucken wir jetzt ein bisschen Essen-Video.
So, also ich hab jetzt
hier ein Brötchen und
ein Toastbrot.
Ich werd jetzt erstmal was futtern. Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Also, wenn ihr was wissen wollt,
haut's in den Chat. Wir haben jetzt...
Ich hab eigentlich Zeit, ne?
Vier Stunden Stream, ne?
Ich hab eigentlich Zeit.
Es ist nicht, dass ich... Ich muss nichts machen.
Also, wenn ihr jetzt noch ein paar Sachen
habt, können wir noch ruhig noch ein bisschen
huge
High-IQ-Talk machen.
Ähm...
Mich würde echt mal
das aktuell laufende System im
Bundestag interessieren.
Performance von so einer großen
Nextcloud-Umgebung wäre echt... Was, die haben Nextcloud
im Bundestag? Ernsthaft?
Essen, Essen, Essen, Essen, Essen.
Du kannst Stellenanzeigen
zerlegen. Oh, das machen wir!
Das machen wir danach.
Wir gucken uns Stellenanzeigen an.
Ja.
Die besten Stellenanzeigen hier sind
Nummer 1, die Khmer-Noodles,
das ist ein lokales Reis-Noodle-Disch.
Und dann ist es das Teig-over-Reis.
Also, du bekommst ein kleines Suppe-Noodle,
du bekommst ein kleines Fleisch und Reis.
Das ist ein reiches, komplettes Essen, also habe ich beide.
Äh, ja, mach ich.
Mach ich, Michael. Schick mal, schick mal den Link.
Das ist jedes Nudel-Lover-Stream hier.
Oh, Mann.
Weep-Food.
Wo ist er denn?
Nee, er ist, er ist nicht...
Er ist in, in, in...
Kambodia?
Wo ist das denn?
Ah, Vietnam, okay.
...
Eins muss man ja sagen, das ist eine Sache,
die mag ich und die ist in Deutschland ja überhaupt
nicht angesagt.
Das sind alle, alle möglichen Arten von
Nudelsuppen.
Ist hier überhaupt nicht angesagt,
ist aber übelst nice.
Äh, welche Shell
nutzt du da auf deinem Manchaco?
Ich habe als Terminal ein ganz normales
Gnome-Terminal und ein ZSH als Shell.
...
Es gibt übrigens ein richtig gutes
Ramen-Restaurant in Frankfurt.
...
Ups.
Das da.
Das ist wirklich nice,
wenn man sowas mag.
Leider, leider, ähm,
ist sowas hier in Deutschland
viel zu teuer.
Ich gehe mal davon aus,
in Japan kann man sowas wahrscheinlich
für umgerechnet irgendwie 5 Euro futtern
oder so.
Hier bezahlt es glaube ich 13 oder sowas.
Aber das schmeckt wirklich
sehr nice.
Weiß gar nicht, ob die
eine Speisekarte
haben?
Äh,
was auch immer.
2,92
kennt sich aus, ja. Ja, der ist wirklich
nice.
Was hat der denn da jetzt reingeschmissen?
Irgendwie so Hot Sauce oder so?
...
Wir haben bei uns um die Ecke
ein vietnamesisches
Nudelsuppen-Restaurant. Schmeckt auch immer gut.
...
Ich lebe nicht nur, ich esse sogar.
Oh, ich glaube, wenn du dort...
Ja, ich glaube, wenn du in solchen Regionen Chili kriegst, dann ist es wahrscheinlich echt scharf.
Es schwitzt ein bisschen, ne?
Moment, das ist Frühstück?
Die hauen sich sowas schon zum Frühstück rein?
Da muss ich hin.
Gebratene Schweine mit Reis.
Zum Frühstück. Huge.
Jetzt bin ich sofort dabei.
Ja, Bacon zum Frühstück fülle ich auch.
Es sieht ein bisschen geschwitzt aus.
Oh mein Gott.
Das ist eines der einfachsten, leckersten Zutaten, die ich jemals gehabt habe.
Ich meine, ich bin sicher, dass es nicht einfach ist, diesen Teig zu kochen, aber...
Ich finde es geil, wie er immer ausflippt beim Futtern.
Du sagst immer so, oh, ist das gut.
Also, ich würde es sofort zum Frühstück futtern.
Ich meine, für Veganer ist es...
Das ist nichts. Das ist wohl so, ja.
Ja, also ich würde es...
Ich könnte es den ersten Tag auch erstmal 24-7 essen.
Wie viel...
Wieso, wie viel futtert der eigentlich immer?
Ist das...
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass er irgendwie Competitive Eater ist.
Der futtert immer Massen.
Das schmeckt noch besser als der erste.
Frischer und heißer.
Und die Zutaten sind springiger und schüchter.
Oh Mann.
So heiß, der Brot.
Also, jeder Ball kostet ca. 2 Dollar.
Zwei.
Zwei Euro.
Oder weniger.
1,70.
1,70 Euro.
Bei uns bezahlt er für sowas 13 Euro.
Okay.
Was, die kann ich mir gar nicht mehr gut vorstellen.
Was ist das?
Das Muschel?
Sind das Muschel oder sowas?
Ja.
Ich glaube, du kannst es wie eine Sonnenblume öffnen.
Oh, das wäre nichts für mich.
Das ist nicht gut genug für das.
Oh.
Wie geht's dir?
Mach ich ein Eis?
Versuch es.
Oh, wow.
Okay, also er verwendet seine vordere Hand, um es zu öffnen.
Okay, ich brauche vielleicht zwei Hände für das.
Ich konnte es endlich öffnen.
Das ist bestimmt Übungssache.
Danach erst mal zum Zahnarzt.
Oh, süß.
Ich sehe, warum das so gut geht.
Das könnte ein Spaßesnack sein, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man das hier öffnen kann, weil das hier mit einem Kung-Fu-Grip so nahe ist.
Wow.
Gute Arbeit, Kumpel.
Der denkt sich auch an Schilder an.
Also, Fleisch und Fisch sind ein paar Zutaten, die hier in Kambodschi sehr viel genutzt werden.
Wegen der geografischen Location am Nikon-River und wahrscheinlich das nationale Gemüse in Kambodschi, das ist der Amak.
Der Fisch-Amak.
Das ist ein Fisch-Curry, der meistens in einem Bananen-Rieb gebraten wird.
Und es hat ein paar Zutaten und Zutaten drin.
Aber in diesem Restaurant, in dem ich bin, haben sie da gebraten.
Also, ich weiß nicht, wie das hier schmeckt.
Ich zeige dir, ob das gut ist.
Es ist sehr kokonattig.
Es riecht wie ein chunky Fisch-Curry.
Also, der Aroma ist fantastisch.
Super chunky Fische.
Und es gibt hier auch Eier.
Also, sie nehmen hier auch Eier.
Wisst ihr, wie das aussieht?
Als ist man da, nach einer halben Schüssel, pappsatt.
Das sieht aus, als ist es sehr gehaltvoll, ja?
Was ist das denn? Ein Salat, oder?
Ja.
Das ist mehr kustardig und cremig.
Aber ich denke, was ich am meisten davon mag, ist der wirklich schöne Kokonatteroma.
Ich bin wirklich interessiert, die gebrannte Version dieses Dosis zu probieren.
Ich denke, wenn es in einem Bananen-Rieb gebrannt wurde, würde dieses Dish noch mehr aromatisch sein.
Das Ding ist besser geworden, als ich es bis zum Boden hatte.
Ich fühle mich viel zu dem Geschmack, auch wenn es nur ein paar Zutaten sind, die ich gar nicht mag.
Ich finde auch, das Zeug ist bestimmt alles übelst scharf.
Ich werde es zum Schluss noch probieren.
Der ist alles am selben Tag gegessen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie er das reinkriegt.
Das ist die ganze Zeit, wie man es hier entspricht.
Es ist fast wie Thais, Indiener, Kambodscher.
Er geht wahrscheinlich essen, danach macht er Workout, bis zum nächsten Essen.
Essen, verbrennen, Essen, verbrennen.
Was willst du machen, als Food-Blogger?
Da musst du durch.
Es ist definitiv eines dieser Arten, bei denen man es langsam nehmen muss und wirklich ausprobieren und überprüfen muss.
Und ich habe es schon oft gegessen.
Ich will wirklich jeden Schlauch probieren, weil es so viel Unterschied gibt in Geschmack und Texturen.
Und es gibt so viele verschiedene Inhalte, Erdbeeren, Spiegel, die das Ganze wirklich gut ausmachen.
Und das ist das, was mich wirklich fasziniert.
Ich will wirklich den Steamed Version probieren, weil ich möchte den Geschmack auch so gut ausmachen,
dass er den Fisch auch so gut infiziert.
Also, das ist mein erstes Mal, dass ich dieses Gericht esse. Es wird nicht mein letztes.
Ich habe heute ein riesiges Abendessen.
Also, ich gehe nach Hause und will nicht zurück.
Also, tuk tuk.
Tuk tuk.
Na, da haben sie es mit dem Recht von links dran zu vergessen.
Da ist Vorfahrt, wer als erstes fährt.
Wer als erstes fährt und nicht umgefahren wird bei hat gewonnen.
Ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen? Nur ein bisschen?
Oh nein, ganz ein bisschen.
Okay.
Wir werden das letzte Mal essen.
Wo gibt es Essen? Ich brauche mehr Essen.
Leider.
Mehr Essen.
Ich bin gerade in der Bak Puk-Bereitschaft der Stadt.
Diese Bereitschaft ist so genannt, weil die Schule Bak Puk genannt wird.
Und das ist wirklich ein sehr lokaler Teil der Stadt.
Wenn du nur herumfährst, besonders in den Abendessen,
es sind viele Lebensmärkte vorhanden.
Es gibt einfach Futter überall hier.
Das ist nicht der typische zentrale Markt oder der russische Markt,
den die Touristen normalerweise gehen.
Das ist ein lokaler Jammertag hier.
Wow, das ist so cool.
Ich wusste nicht, dass Papaya Salad eigentlich aus Kambodscha ist.
Es ist ein sehr interessantes Ingredient.
Und es ist eine rohe Krabbe.
Und ich sehe das oft in der koreanischen Cuisine.
Aber ich habe es noch nie in einem Papaya Salad gesehen.
Da ist auch Schale drum, oder? Oder Panzer.
Du nimmst es nicht?
Du nimmst es nur für den Geschmack, aber du nimmst es nicht.
Sehr interessant.
Okay.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das immer hinkriegen.
Wow, das ist ein sehr starker Geschmack.
Es ist sehr salzig und sehr heiß.
Diese Krabbe ist mehr sauer als die Salade.
Ah, das ist schon eher was für mich.
Ich habe auch ein paar traditionelle gebrannte Sausage.
Wow.
Oh Mann.
Die originelle Sausage, die sich ausbreitet, ohne Kassierer, ist wunderbar.
Ich liebe das kleine Gericht.
Und das Ganze bricht sich einfach aus,
und es ist wie die meiste leckere, leckere,
schwarze kleine Kontraktion.
Oh mein Gott.
Gib es ein bisschen Dipp.
Sieht aus wie eine Bratwurst.
Ja.
Stille Sauce?
Unglaublich.
Das ist unglaublich.
Das hätte auch das Ende der Bratwurst sein können.
Ich gebe dir nur diesen Stil.
Ich nehme dir nur das ganze Blatt.
Ich nehme dir den ganzen Blatt.
Und das ist ein gebrannte Fischkech.
Das heißt Songhua.
Und drinnen gibt es Palmzucker, Salz und Wein.
Ich sehe diese gebrannten Fischkechen in dem ganzen Südwesten Asiens.
Und das Ganze sieht sehr flexibel aus.
Das ist ein kleiner Erdbebenstuch.
Du machst ein kleiner Rappen von dem.
Okay.
Das ist ein kleiner Erdbebenstuch.
Oh, das ist ein kleiner Erdbebenstuch.
Es ist sehr flexibel.
Ich weiß nicht.
Es ist wie ein kleiner Ersatz.
Du machst ein kleines Wrappchen davon.
Ein kleines Zucke.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, das wäre nicht so meins.
Wobei ich die Sache finde ich cool.
Das machen sie in Korea ja auch,
dass da sauviel Zeug in Salatblätter gewickelt wird.
Und das finde ich, ist eigentlich eine super Idee.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle, wenn irgendwas auf dem Grill liegt
und man schneidet das klein.
Bei uns machen wir es immer so.
Also generell hier so.
In Deutschland macht man es ja gerne so.
Man nimmt das Zeug vom Grill.
Schneidet das klein und hat dann noch irgendwie Baguette
oder Knoblauchbaguette oder irgendwie sowas dabei.
Da finde ich das eigentlich mit dem in Salat wickeln viel besser.
Du schneidest das einfach klein.
Nimmst dann irgendwie einen Platz Salat.
Machst dann noch irgendwie ein bisschen Chili-Kram rein.
Machst dann ein Stück Fleisch rein.
Dann futterst du das komplett.
Das ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch deutlich besser und gesünder,
als wenn du da massig Baguette dabei futterst.
Das ist ein tolles Mauergefühl.
Es hat so eine schmutzige Texture.
Es riecht sehr vinaigrette.
Viel vinaigretter als wahrscheinlich jede andere Fischküche, die ich je hatte.
Ich denke, dass du nicht so viel von der Fischflavor riechst.
Es ist wirklich nur die Texture.
Wir sind auf einem kleinen Stehstand.
Das ist so interessant, weil
natürlich hat Kambodschland eine starke Influenz von den Franzosen.
So wie Vietnam.
Also gibt es hier viele Baguette.
Aber das ist das Wichtigste.
Baguette.
Oui, oui.
Würde ich mir jetzt auch reinhauen.
Das würde ich mir jetzt ohne...
Ohne...
Oh.
Oh, ich glaube, das ist echt hot.
Das ist bestimmt scharf wie Sau.
Aber es schmeckt gut.
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich was.
Die Kombination hier, die ist, glaube ich,
die schmeckt gut und ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch relativ gesund.
Das ist ein bisschen wie ein Schmutzigkeits-Baguette-Sandwich.
Es kommt auf eine kleine Bananen-Lehre.
Und es ist so unglaublich kräftig draußen.
Und es schmeckt so gut.
Die Baguette ist definitiv kräftiger.
Sie hat mehr Mochi-Effekt als eine normale Baguette.
Sie bricht nicht zusammen.
Deshalb musst du diese Brühe zerstören.
Die Brühe ist schmutzig.
Sie ist ein bisschen süß.
Wow, man kann die Pinus-Sauce riechen.
Sie riecht den Zucker.
Ist das nicht so?
so gut sind also es ist nicht so komplett unglaubbarer hype ja ich habe
ja früher fast jedes video von dem gekocht manche sachen wird der flächendeck
vielleicht weiß man vorher nicht genau wir fahren jetzt alle hin und checken das
aus weil man das wollte es gibt wahrscheinlich auch nur ein stand davon
aber da fahren alle motorrad
das ist jetzt echt nichts für vegetarier
es ist nicht so meins
ich weiß ich glaube ich meine ich meine probieren würde ich mal aber ich
glaube das nicht meins das schon eher ich frage mich nur was das mal für tiere
ursprünglich gewesen sind
sind wahrscheinlich dass es das ist ein hühner fuß
und sie das wie ein hühnerfuß schicken
es ist okay man weiß dass die franzosen da gewesen sind eindeutig er hat ja
gesagt es ist waren früher die franzosen da deswegen gibt es da auch frösche zu
essen
metro ich würde mir auch also ich habe mir keine frau selbst bauen
das ist so ein bisschen latin ist
nie probiert
tatsächlich also das wird wiederholen aber der frosch ich weiß nicht ob der
frosch wenn ich meine
erotikus gott all that great herbs like lemongrass stopp inside the fish belly
one of my favorite things to eat in south east asia it's just to roll the
whole fish nobody wants the chicken feet chicken foot on air it's all mine
das muss nicht sein
really what's so great about this is just you're tasting so much of the smoke
because they're using real wood charcoal here and you get that great smoky
flavor just penetrating every single bit there's gonna be tender near in crunchier
so das muss nicht sein
so wirklich essen tut das auch nicht oder da wedelt nur damit rum
also hähnchenfuß
das ist der frosch
ob fuß oder flügel ist kein großer unterschied am flügel ist ein bisschen was dran also ein fuß
oder flügel ist kann man nicht kinder so auf number of freue so da wird doch
also wenn der flüssige la nation der typisch machen und was kommt dann getrunken
um attaching feinds durch die reise she was not olsun parcaelsius 2
der schweizer krendt heim schroud drücken
für die dritten weorde
flüchte
candy
kauf ab 보ßtheit
hab, kennst du einen guten Channel, wie man
sein eigenes Smartphone
bauen kann?
Ich hab Smartphone gelesen, nicht Smart
Home. Ja, Smart Home
kann ich dir ein paar Channels
empfehlen, ja.
Also Smart Home gibt's ein paar Channels.
Zeig dir gleich mal ein paar.
Da ist so viel
Geschmack in dem. Einen wirklich schönen,
riesigen, schmutzigen Geschmack.
Das macht dieses Essen wirklich fantastisch.
Es gibt alle anderen Ingrедиente in hier.
Du riechst den Süßes des Palmschokolades.
Du kriegst den tollen Geschmack des Basil
und der Chilis.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Enten eigentlich
an sich selbst riechen.
Aber das Fleisch ist definitiv Tender.
Wenn du all das zusammen isst, ist es definitiv
ein großartiges harmonisches Blende
von süß, heiß,
Zitrus. Du riechst den Timmer.
Der Krust.
Die Vegetablen sind
abweichlich.
Ich glaube, es braucht bestimmt etwas Reis
oder eine Reihe von Nudeln oder so.
Ja gut, die sind da halt hart im Himmel.
Sie sollten definitiv von etwas verbrannt werden.
Aber im Allgemeinen, wenn es mit all den anderen
Saucen und Ingrедиenten zusammenfällt,
wird es ein absoluter,
schreckliches Essen.
Cambodian Popcorn.
Ich wünschte, die Filmmitglieder
hätten das tatsächlich gesehen.
Es hat einen Doppel-Crunch.
Es hat einen Pop von Pernod.
Das würde ich wahrscheinlich
den Popcorn hier bevorzugen.
Ich hoffe es geht euch gut.
Es kommt auf die
App.
Und ich hoffe, wir sehen uns wieder.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Schau mal.
Strictly Dumpling heißt der.
Salty, sticky, chewy.
All sorts of textures and flavors.
And trust me,
this is very heavy.
This is not going to be like,
Oh, ich weiß ja nicht.
Also, Heimautomatisierungs-Channels, da kann ich dir einmal den hier empfehlen.
Der ist ganz gut zum Einstieg und hat relativ gute Guides.
In letzter Zeit macht er relativ wenig, was mich interessiert.
Aber der ist ganz gut.
Dann gibt es hier den Typ.
Den da.
Der ist auch nicht schlecht.
Also generell für Heimautomatisierung insgesamt jetzt.
Wie heißt der andere?
Ist das der?
Ja, der ist auch ganz gut.
Das ist so, wenn es ganz grob um das Heimautomatisierungsthema geht, finde ich die ganz gut, die drei.
Natürlich, wenn du spezifische Sachen dir angucken willst, da gibt es immer andere.
Also, wenn du dich für Mikrocontroller und Programmieren in der Richtung interessierst, gibt es wieder ganz andere Channels.
Gibt viel. Gibt viel auf YouTube.
Gibt auch viele, die hätten meiner Meinung nach mehr Abos verdient.
Any cuties in chat? Überall.
Schon mal das Blackout-Hörspiel gehört.
Was für ein Blackout-Hörspiel.
Du schreibst das so, als müsste man wissen, was das Blackout-Hörspiel ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Es ist nicht nur rausgeschmissenes Geld, sich eine Komplettlösung zu kaufen.
Die Komplettlösungen sind auch schlechter als das, was man selbst bauen kann.
Und noch deutlich unsicherer.
Vor allem, weil die alle irgendwelche komischen Cloud-Geschichten machen mittlerweile.
Und man kriegt es mit Komplettlösungen selten so hin, wie man es haben will.
So, wir wollen uns nochmal eine Runde Stellenanzeigen angucken.
Also.
Wir gucken jetzt mal in Frankfurt.
Wir suchen jetzt einfach mal nur nach IT.
Wir suchen einfach nur IT.
Wir suchen einfach mal alle.
Alles, was es gibt.
Alles.
3.053 Jobs.
Easy.
Alles dabei.
Easy as a fuck.
Ach so, genau.
Wir wollten von Michael mal gucken.
E-Tech Service Consulting.
Also, da fängst du an.
Oder wie ist das?
Da fängst du demnächst an?
Oder da hast du dich beworben?
Oh, schau mal, schöne Grinser.
Auf der Startseite.
Das muss ja so sein.
Die sind immer glücklich.
Ja, super.
Das sind irgendwelche Stock-Icons auf jeden Fall.
Die kommen mir bekannt vor.
Aktuelles Vorstellungsgespräch.
Ja, hm.
Was machen die denn?
Service.
Jobs.
Karriere.
Also, wo hast du dich beworben?
Zeig mal her.
Da?
Ach so, du weißt nicht, was...
Warum weißt du nicht, was die machen?
Wer war da im...
Moment.
Wer von uns beiden war jetzt im Vorstellungsgespräch?
Okay.
Vorteile.
Viele Möglichkeiten zur aktiven Mitgestaltung und Einbeziehung.
Entscheidung.
Okay, das ist gut oder schlecht.
Man weiß es nicht.
Werkstatt der Arbeitszeiten von pro Stunde.
Gut, das ist jetzt für dich egal.
Flache Hierarchien.
Das ist gut.
Das ist...
Ja, da weiß ich nicht, ob das alles so Vorteile für einen selbst sind.
Das kann je nachdem gut oder schlecht sein.
Das sagt jetzt noch mal gar nichts aus.
Modernes Arbeitumfeld.
Arbeiten in einem modern ausgestatteten Büro und direkt gehen zum Einkaufszentrum.
Wenn es für dich ein Vorteil ist, ist es eindeutig ein Plus.
Ein großartiges...
Das sagen alle.
Da würde ich nichts drauf geben.
Das sagen wirklich alle.
Subventioniert das Essen.
Kantine.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Ich würde sagen, von allen Vorteilen, die sie hier aufgelistet haben, ist das hier wirklich ein Vorteil.
Subventioniert das Essen nicht verkehrt.
Du bekommst...
Ne, du bekommst nicht gratis Futter.
Doch, du bekommst gratis Smoothies und Snacks.
Und subventioniert das Essen.
Das ist doch ganz gut.
Wir suchen eine aufgeschlossene Persönlichkeit.
Michael, bist du eine aufgeschlossene Persönlichkeit?
Ja, ich bin eine aufgeschlossene Persönlichkeit.
Die sich mit Engagement und Eigeninitiative...
In unser Team einbringt.
Blablabla.
Ihre Aufgaben, Fachinformatikerin...
Die benutzen dazu eigene Methoden...
Okay.
Das ist absolut nichts sagen, das ganze Ding.
Aber okay.
Du willst jetzt von mir wissen, was die machen.
Okay.
Ich sag dir, was die machen.
Die machen komisches Prozessgedöns.
Komisches Prozess-Consulting-Gedöns.
Oder so würde ich mal sagen.
Kann man jetzt schwer...
Schwer.
sagen sie entwickeln software und sie bieten was zum tue ich habe keine ahnung was sie machen das
ist irgendeine consulting firma oder wenn die was von prozessen standardisierung und services reden
dass das das hört sich an wie eine consulting firma beratung das ist in consulting laden
consulting laden der auch eigene software verkauft für die bereiche in denen sie konsulten was
natürlich clever ist weil dann können sie dir quasi raten kauft auch unsere software nachdem
sie nachdem sie konsultiert hast das ist eigentlich eigentlich richtig richtig big brain du lässt dich
beraten und am ende der beratung kommt raus am besten kaufst du die software von etec das ist
eigentlich big brain iiq move open data check
ja dass das ist das ist eine consulting laden an die technik das frage ich mich auch
warum bist du da gewesen hast überhaupt kein plan von dem laden also dass du da hin gehst und
keinen plan von dem laden das kann ich noch irgendwie nachvollziehen aber dass man sich
dann auch so gut verstanden hat und sie es dir auch nicht geschafft hat irgendwie ein bisschen
was über sich zu erzählen ist schon merkwürdig das ist eine consulting die machen irgendwie
irgendwelche Business Consulting
Geschichten und entwickeln auch Software
dafür, die sie dann den Leuten antreten wollen.
Mit irgendwelchen komischen
Zertifizierungen und
was auch immer.
Die haben mir nichts über sich erzählt. Wahrscheinlich wissen
die selber nicht, was die machen.
Was kannst du das gleiche mit BMC
Solutions geben, kann ich also sagen.
Wieder BMC.
BMC ist
für mich Baseboard
Base Management
Controller. Wie heißt das Ding bei
IBM? Ne, doch
nicht.
Okay, dann nicht.
Das Einzige, was sie gesagt
haben, sie arbeiten fast ausschließlich mit PHP.
Das heißt jetzt erstmal
nichts. Normalerweise
sind die bei solchen Vorstellungsgesprächen
immer ganz scharf drauf, nochmal
zu betonen, was für ein geiler Laden sie sind.
Also, was suchen die
hier denn?
IT System Engineer
vor PDM
Enterprise Architect
braucht man nicht. Projektmanagement
Okay, geh mal weg.
IT Site Lead
Das ist quasi so ein
Niederlassungschef
oder sowas.
Ja, Michael, normalerweise
drücken sie einem das ganz gerne aufs Auge, wie toll
sie sind.
Da muss ich Neo recht
geben. Das wäre tatsächlich nicht schlecht gewesen.
Ich meine, wenn du zu denen gesagt hast,
ich habe überhaupt keinen Plan, was sie hier macht,
wäre vielleicht ein bisschen blöd, aber wenn du sagst, du hast die Webseite
gelesen und
zu manchen Sachen hast du jetzt noch Fragen,
was das genau bedeutet,
dann hätten die sich bestimmt gefreut.
Achso,
BMC Solution in
Stuttgart.
Das sind die doch, oder?
Ach ne,
die hier.
IGIT
Die Webseite
MonkHS
Optimiert für Microsoft Internet Explorer
800x600
Okay, wir stehen für Software Engineering.
Ähm, wobei
die Webseite ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Weil ich glaube,
die ist relativ,
gucken wir mal in den Source,
ähm, oh, es ist WordPress.
Es ist WordPress.
Es ist irgendein WordPress-Standard-Team.
Okay, ich finde es doch schlecht.
Was, bei offenen Stellen?
Wo siehst du das jetzt?
Ich erkenne, ich blicke hier
auf der Seite gar nicht durch, wo hier überhaupt
irgendwie was ist. Bei dem Typen da.
Oh,
ja, ich seh's.
Ich hab's erst, ich hab's erst gar nicht,
ich hab's erst gar nicht gecheckt.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, ob der
so guckt, als ist er einfach nur glücklich,
oder als will er mich beißen.
Könnte beides sein.
Vielleicht sollte man mal unseren lokalen Witcher
da hinschicken.
Also, weiß nicht, das sieht irgendwie gefährlich aus.
Ähm,
hier findest du eine vielfältige Auswahl
Aufnahmen.
Okay, was, was haben sie denn Schönes?
Web-Entwicklung.
Okay, aber du wolltest ja wissen, was die
machen. Native-Apps machen
sie. Oh, er macht Native-Apps.
iPad, iPhone,
los.
Web-Apps.
Bootstrap.
Frontend-Entwicklung.
jQuery! Hui!
Moment.
NoJS? Im Frontend?
Wait, wait.
Das, was wollen sie uns sagen?
NoJS?
NoJS hat im Frontend eigentlich...
Also, zumindest nicht dort, wo es ausgeführt wird.
Man benutzt das in der Frontend-Entwicklung
auf dem Rechner des Entwicklers,
aber nicht so wirklich im Frontend.
Ähm, okay, also,
lesen wir uns mal durch, was ich tolls mag.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Okay, die Frontend-Entwicklung ist die technische Umsetzung
des Erscheinungsbildes
sowie des interaktiven Fallens eines Web-Anwenders.
Ach du große...
Entscheidend für den Erfolg
ihrer Web-Anwendung ist das User-Entwicklung.
Interface-Design.
Das könnte Nextcloud auch noch brauchen.
Unser Fokus bei der Frontend-Entwicklung
liegt auf Web-to-Print,
Unternehmens- und E-Commerce-Portalen.
Hierbei setzen wir auf Technologien wie
HTML5,
JavaScript,
CSS3,
jQuery,
also, es wird
schwierig,
auf diese Sachen nicht zu setzen,
weil ich meine,
wenn Web-Entwicklung geht,
halt ohne Nummer nicht.
Ähm, jQuery, ja gut,
ist zwar jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr so der neueste Shit,
aber es ist halt wahrscheinlich noch gut verwendbar, ja.
Ähm, Bootstrap ist auch ziemlich 0,15 CSS-Zeug.
Ich würde mir eigentlich eher Gedanken drüber machen,
wenn jemand, der für mich
ein individuelles, hochwertiges Frontend entwickelt,
das gerade, äh, mit Bootstrap machen.
Okay, Angular, ja gut.
Ja, also, wenn du wissen willst, was die machen,
das sieht für mich nach...
einem Laden aus, der Web-Anwendungen entwickelt.
Und die eine ziemlich merkwürdige Homepage haben.
Guck mal, sie haben Microsoft als Partner.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie für Microsoft Webseiten gemacht haben.
Die haben bei Microsoft wahrscheinlich ein paar Office-Lizenzen gekauft.
Fuck!
Die kenn ich!
Das ist eine Zumutung, diese Software, euer...
Leute.
Die kenn ich!
Oh, yeah.
FNT, Alter.
FNT ist so ein Inventarisierungssystem.
Es hat das schlechteste...
Ich zeige es euch mal.
Es hat das schlechteste User-Interface, was ihr je gesehen habt.
Also, ich übertreibe jetzt nicht.
Ja.
Sowas da zum Beispiel.
Also, was...
Also, was sie sich bei diesem Programm gedacht haben, ist mir echt schleierhaft.
Ähm...
Das kann übrigens nicht mal Tabs.
Das sieht so aus, als kannst Tabs, aber das funktioniert nicht.
Also, du kannst Tabs aufmachen, aber wenn du dann Back drückst,
dann landest du dann auf einer anderen Seite, nicht auf der, wo du vorher warst, so ganz...
Äh, guckt euch das an.
EGIT.
Ja, das ist es.
Das Interface, das Interface, das tut weh, das tut so, das tut so weh, das Interface.
Boah.
Racktables, ja, Racktables kosten wenigstens nichts.
Holiday Check haben sie entwickelt, okay.
Ob sie das auch mit Bootstrap gemacht haben?
Technologien.
Objektive C und Xcode und Git, Jira und Confluence.
Wer hat denn das geschrieben?
Ich meine, Objektive C, klar, es ist eine etwas ältere IOS-Anwendung.
Ähm, Xcode, ohne Xcode kannst du gar keine IOS-Anwendung erstellen.
Git, ja gut, ist für die Anwendung doch scheißegal, mit welchem Versionsverwaltungssystem,
was für ein Ticketsystem verwendet wird, während man...
Ist auch egal, und ob die nur Confluence verwenden oder nicht, ist doch auch wurscht,
das hat doch mit der App nichts zu tun.
Was ist denn das für ein Blödsinn?
WTF?
Das hat mit der App überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Nichts davon hat was mit der App zu tun.
Das einzige ist Objektive C.
Das sind doch nicht mal Buzzwords.
Das sind, das sind, das sind zumindest planlos Words von denen, die die Webseite schreiben.
Wisst ihr, wenn jemand beispielsweise eine Handy-App entwickelt und sagt Technologien,
dann würde, okay, dass es in Objektive C geschrieben ist, würde ich, würde ich, würde ich verstehen, ja.
Dann, ich würde erwarten, dass dann sowas drin steht, wie zum Beispiel,
FHC, das ist ja, das ist ja, das ist ja, das ist ja, das ist ja, das ist ja, das ist ja, das ist ja, das ist ja, das ist ja.
FFM-Pack, wenn's, äh, Video, Video, Audio, Video-Zeug drin hat.
F, dass FFM-Pack drin steht.
Oder, dass irgendein, irgendein, was weiß ich, äh, Grafik-Framework drin steht, wenn's verwendet wird oder sowas.
Ähm.
Oh, doch nicht Git.
Okay, weg.
Okay, also was suchen die hier?
Äh, wartet mal kurz, so.
Die Logo-Farben, ja, so halbwegs.
Ähm.
Blablabla, dein Aufkommen.
Du bringst da...
Dein Profil.
Entschuldigung, blablabla.
Sehr gute Kenntnisse, objektorientierte Softwareentwicklung.
Na gut.
HTML5, JavaScript, PHP und CSS.
Also, HTML, JavaScript, CSS ist absolut Grundlage für Web-Anwendung.
Ohne geht es nicht.
Ähm.
Erfahrungen mit Plattformen wie Android oder iOS wünschenswert.
Okay.
Grundlegendes Erfahrung mit Web-Service.
Soap!
Igitt.
Gibt es wirklich noch Leute, die Soap-APs machen?
Na gut.
Ähm.
Warum nicht?
Hohe Qualität, Ergebnisorientierung.
Das ist so ein Satz, den schreiben viele gerne rein, ja.
Hohe Qualität und Eigeninitiativen, sowas steht dann da immer drin.
Das ist so komplett Füllworte.
Kommunikation und Teamfähigkeit, sehr gute Deutsch- und Englischkenntnisse online.
Wir haben...
Ähm.
Man kann anhand der Website überhaupt nicht erkennen, ob es ein guter oder schlechter Laden ist.
Ganz ehrlich.
Kann man echt nicht ableiten.
Nur, dass diejenigen, die die Homepage schreiben, glaube ich, relativ wenig Ahnung haben von dem, was der Laden eigentlich macht.
Okay, Leute.
Wir müssen ein bisschen einschränken.
3.053 Jobs sind zu viel.
Macht mal einen Vorschlag.
Nach was für einem Job wollen wir suchen?
Wir haben das letzte Mal immer bei mir...
Na, Consulting.
Consulting, nee.
Es muss was sein, wo ich was zu sagen kann.
Ich weiß, DHL.
Jaja, ich weiß, DHL hat immer noch...
Zumindest das Offizielle, was du findest, hat bei DHL immer noch Soap.
Wobei, DHL mittlerweile, die haben eine neue...
Die haben eine neue...
Äh.
API-Schnittstelle.
Ich hab hier das ja in meinem...
In meinem...
Ähm.
Versand-Tracker eingebaut.
Die neue DHL-API ist auch mit...
Mit JSON überrest.
Sys...
Sysadmin.
Systemadministrator.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
128.
Für Microsoft im Bereich Operational Services.
Systemadministrator.
Ich hab mit diesem Laden noch nie was zu tun gehabt.
Aber ich hab gehört von ein paar Leuten, die da gearbeitet haben,
dass es wohl ziemlich...
Sackt.
Kann ich aus persönlicher Erfahrung nicht...
Nicht...
Nichts zu sagen.
Aber...
Ja.
Oh, guck mal.
Der Bund.
Systemadministrator an der Uni.
E-Shelter.
Die kommen mir bekannt vor.
Das kommt...
E-Shelter.
Wer war das nochmal?
Die kenn ich irgendwoher.
E-Shelter.
Hat das nicht ein Rechenzentrum-Anbieter oder sowas?
Die kommen mir bekannt vor.
Ich glaub, da hatten wir mal was.
Ich glaub, bei denen hatten wir mal was gemietet.
Home to the Cloud.
Ja, genau.
Die haben Rechenzentrum.
Warum suchen wir gerade nach Jobs?
Weil der Chat gefragt hat, ob ich nicht mal wieder...
Also quasi der...
Wollte, dass wir uns mal wieder IT-Sachen angucken.
Oh, Skills. Linux.
Leute, ich filter das mal nach Sachen, wo ich auch was zu sagen kann.
Gleich dann.
Was?
Systemadministrator.
Robotic Process Automation and AI.
Das muss ich mir angucken.
Was wollen die?
Was will denn die Bank damit?
Linux-Systematm...
EU-Networks.
Moment.
Die kommen mir auch bekannt vor.
Die kommen mir bekannt vor.
Woher sagt mir denn der Name irgendwas?
Es könnte sein, dass wir Glasfaserleitungen von denen haben.
Nee, Easy Killer.
Das ist jetzt nur Zufall.
Managed Now Monitoring.
Schwerpunkttelefonie.
Bist bei denen bestimmt gebannt.
Aber da gebannt bin ich nur bei MSI.
Für Server-Systeme.
Die hätten sich auch Servus...
Servus-Technology nennen können, oder?
Servus-Technology hätte irgendwie besser geklungen als Certus.
Die Caritas in Frankfurt.
Uiuiui.
Wahnsinn.
Windows.
Ne, das guckt man gar nicht.
Grieb.
Oh, man hat Wiesmann?
Fuck, ist viel zu weit weg.
Bist echt bei MSI gebannt, ja.
Ich hab über RGB-Beleuchtung gemeckert.
Das fand MSI nicht lustig.
Also, irgendwo hört auch mal der Spaß auf.
Ne?
Wer über RGB-Beleuchtung sich lustig macht, den kann man schon mal bannen.
Okay, warum braucht ne Bank einen Systemadministrator für Robotic Process Automation und AI?
Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Jump on.
Jetzt Systemadministratoren blablabla, wo andere von komplexen Zusammenhängen sprechen, sehen sie logische Verknüpfung.
Ah, yes.
Alles.
Wir sehen überall logische Verknüpfung.
Mit ihrer analytischen und gleichzeitig kreativen Denkweise bringen sie Prozesse voran und entwickeln sie ständig weiter.
Das passt.
Gibt es irgendeinen IT-begeisterten Mensch auf dieser Welt, der sich diese zwei Sätze durchliest und sich dann denkt, das passt.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Unsere IT-Area Service freut sich.
Was?
Unsere IT-Area Service?
Was soll denn das für eine Bescheuere?
IT-Area Service?
Ich kann mir da gar nichts drunter vorstellen.
Ist das die, die lokal hinlaufen und Druckerpatronen tauschen oder wie?
Weil, weil Area Service?
Nix.
War bei MSI.
Die haben mich auf Twitter gebannt, weil ich über RGB-Beleuchtung gemeckert habe.
Kann man ja machen, wa?
Ja.
Okay, also ihre Aufgaben.
Sie haben Lust auf Betreuung.
Interessante Anwendung im agilen Fintech.
Fintech, das ist eine Wortgeschichte, Wortkreation, das ist mittlerweile voll angesetzt.
Das mögen sie.
Fintech.
Und dann haben wir vielleicht den perfekten Job für sie.
Sie interessieren sich für neue, zukunftsreiche Technologien, haben Spaß, eine neue Lösung im Bereich Robotic Browser Autoripa und AI zu identifizieren und zu implementieren.
Außerdem kennen sie sich im Windows- sowie Unix-Umfeld bestens aus.
Und dann haben sie die Möglichkeit, sich zu verändern.
Übernehmen die Administration und den Second-Level-Support halten mit Rollouts, handeln sie souverän, was?
Handeln.
Lol, hab ich nicht gehört.
Rollouts handeln sie souverän, greifen den Stakeholdern unter die Arme.
All you can eat.
Last-Banner sind sie auch.
Was?
Bei Governance und BCP-Prozessen ein zentraler Player.
Hahaha.
Geiler Satz, Alter.
Last-Banner und least sind sie auch bei Governance und BCP-Prozessen ein zentraler Player.
Alles klar.
Das können nur wieder irgendwelche realitätsfernen Personalleute geschrieben haben, dieses Ding hier.
Niemand, den ich kenne, der sich für diese Sache interessiert,
würde auch nur...
...ein Traum so einen Satz rausbringen, ja?
Und fördern aktiv mit ihren Dokumentationen und smarten Präsentationen ein Netzwerk zum Austausch über die RPA- und AI-Lösungen in der Bank.
Oioioioi.
Ich verstehe das mit dem Robotics auch nicht.
Vielleicht werden wir jetzt ja noch schlauer da draus.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das mit Robotics zu tun hat.
Mehrjährige Erfahrung an Windows Unix.
Ja, da kennen sie alle...
...mit...
...i.
Warum wollen die immer Java haben?
Gut, ich weiß, es ist Enterprise und vor allem bei Banken und so ist Java, aber muss...
Okay, Bewerbung ist raus, Leute.
Instant.
Ich schreib einfach rein.
Ich habe jahrzehntelange Erfahrung im Fintech-Umfeld als zentraler Player.
150k.
Weil, wenn man schon so zentraler Player ist, da muss das sich ja auch lohnen.
Man müsste das echt mal probieren.
Wenn man einfach nur die Stellenanzeige umschreibt, für ein Anschreiben, wie das ankommt, und dann müsste man noch dahinter schreiben, und dann müsste man noch zu hinter geschrieben, das passt, Fragezeichen.
Okay, weiter.
Ähm...
Ah, die haben schon mal hier schöne Image-Fonts am starten, wobei das sind keine Image-Fonts, das sind einfach nur Images.
Monitoring, Administration...
...Operations.
Handels-Service, okay.
24-7-Support.
Schichtarbeit, mal gucken.
Die heißen wirklich...
SVA Systemvertrieb Alexander GmbH.
Was ein Zungenbrecher.
Hast du schon mal deine Firma gewechselt?
Ja, einmal. Einmal habe ich die Firma gewechselt.
Ich habe gelernt, habe ich bei einem Provider, und jetzt arbeite ich bei einer Bank.
Okay, also die SVA Systemvertrieb Alexander GmbH...
Was ein Name, ey.
...ist einer der Firmen.
Wir führen den deutschen System-Integratoren.
Branchenunabhängige Kernthemen des Unternehmens...
Bla, bla, bla, bla...
Business Continuity, IT Service Management, SAP...
Was ist SAP?
Den Satz kapiere ich nicht.
Darüber hinaus bietet SVA Unterstützung im Betrieb der Infrastruktur durch Operational Services mit System-Engineers schon ab First Level und Service...
Ah, und Service Made in Germany.
Okay.
Bla, bla, bla, bla...
Installation und Administration von Checkmk.
Das verwenden noch Leute?
Checkmk, das habe ich zum letzten Mal gesehen.
Vor 10 Jahren oder so.
Das ist ein Nagios Fork, wenn ich nicht ganz...
Oder?
Das ist doch ein Nagios Fork gewesen.
Ja, genau. Das war ein Nagios Fork ursprünglich.
Ich kann überhaupt nichts zu sagen.
Easy Killer.
Ich kann da wirklich nichts zu sagen.
Ich habe das vor 10 Jahren oder so das letzte Mal gesehen.
Gibt es da ein paar Bilder dazu?
Boah, das sieht immer noch voll Nagios...
Nagios-y aus.
Das sieht voll Nagios-Style aus.
Programmierung von Checks für Nagios Checkmk.
Jupp.
Erstellen und Pflegen von Regeln im Continuous Management Tool wie Sols.
Oh, mal eine der Sols-Decks verwendet.
Aktuell ist ja eher Ansible so der Shit.
Tut aber gut seinen Dienst.
Ähm, genauso wie Nagios.
Ganz ehrlich.
Nagios ist zwar bestimmt nicht mehr der neueste Shit, aber Nagios tut einfach.
Das bringen sie mit.
Freude an der Arbeit im Team.
Das hängt ganz entscheidend vom Team ab.
Starke Service-Orientierung.
Gute Kommunikationsfähigkeit.
Deutschkenntnisse auf Level C1.
Was ist denn das?
Das heißt, ist das wie Muttersprache oder noch drunter?
Kenn mich bei diesen...
Ich kann mir diese Level immer nicht merken.
Erfahrungen mit Checkmk.
Nagios oder Derivaten.
Ganz am Anfang,
also bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber,
hab ich mich mal
fast eineinhalb Jahre
um unser Nagios Zeug gekümmert.
Und ich muss sagen,
wenn man sich ein bisschen an die Nagios Config gewöhnt hat,
ist das eigentlich ganz angenehm.
Programmierkenntnisse.
Bevorzug Python und Bash.
Konfigurationsmanagement.
Bevorzug Sols-Deck.
Weil ich hab mit Sols-Deck, ich weiß was es ist.
Hab ich keine Ahnung von.
Hab ich noch nie was mitgemacht.
Linuxkenntnisse bevorzug Rethat und CentOS.
Das ist Standard.
Wie gesagt im Enterprise Umfeld.
Weil sich vorher einer darüber aufgeregt hat.
Ich würde so oft Umfeld sagen.
Ist Rethat ziemlich normal.
Zusätzliches Basiswissen in einem oder mehreren erfolgten Themen.
Enterprise Storage.
Virtualisierung. SAP.
DB2.
Oracle Backup Lösung.
IBM Spectrum Protect.
Hab ich auch noch nie was von gehört.
Ich finde die Stellenanzeigen gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist jetzt nichts wo ich sagen würde.
Wow da bist du ja voll hin und weg und voll begeistert.
Aber wenigstens.
Die schreiben einfach wie es ist.
Und die haben auch nicht irgendwelche überzogenen Dinger.
Das macht doch einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Ich meine letztendlich wird das hier sowas sein.
Wahrscheinlich ist das so.
Weil im Prinzip.
So halb Support.
Oder 80% Support.
Mann.
So lese ich das jetzt.
Aber warum nicht.
Ich finde es nicht verkehrt.
Aber ich meine das ist natürlich.
Unter unserem Niveau Chat.
Weil wir sind ja.
Enabler im Hyperscale Enterprise Umfeld.
Das ist das hier für uns natürlich nichts.
Und natürlich sind wir zentrale Player.
Zahlen bestimmt also 30k als Lohn.
Easykiller.
Ganz ehrlich ich finde das liest sich tatsächlich ein bisschen wie sowas in der Richtung.
Als suchen die einen Supportmann.
Weil die schreiben ja auch hier Quereinsteiger und sonstwas.
Als suchen die quasi Junior-Admin-Einsteiger.
Die halt was suchen und.
Ja jetzt vielleicht auch nicht so die Wahnsinnsansprüche haben.
Aber kann man machen.
Die verschleiern das hier irgendwie nicht.
Die schreiben einfach wie es ist.
STBA42. 4 Monate. Dankeschön.
Die kenne ich.
Der Name kommt mir übelst bekannt vor.
Ich glaube bei denen haben wir Glasfaserleitungen gekauft.
Nagios.
Network Management.
Fiber Networks.
Haben sie das stehen gehabt?
Hatten die Fiber stehen?
Ah ja dann sind das die von denen wir Glasfaser gekauft haben.
Fujitsu.
Systems Management.
Managed Now Monitoring.
Ob Hardware oder Cloud Solutions.
Das ist ja schon ziemlich random alles zusammen gewürfelt oder?
Gut das ist ja auch Absicht.
Sie wollen ja auch sagen sie sind global überall dabei.
Aber das ist schon ziemlich random.
Cloud SAP
IoT, AI
arena
Als globaler Konzern bietet
Fujitsu das
gesamte Spektrum an IT.
Unser Ziel ist, das unsere Kunden
pragmatisch im Alltag
und sie gleichzeitig
für die digitale Transformation
zu rüsten.
Okay also.
Administration und Weiterentwicklung von System Management
Infrastruktur. Ja.
überwachungstool entsprechen einfach ihre entwicklung anpassung skript mit arbeiten
normal kunden kundkenntnisse im betriebssystem optionale kunden optional kennen sie den tools
bmc patrol true site oder service tracker hat man das echt so ach tracer
big brain aussprache service tracer kommunikationsfähigkeit
also die anforderung ist jetzt nicht sonderlich hoch das ist wahrscheinlich auch in so einem 30
k support job dank hoher eigenverantwortung flexibilität haben sie die möglichkeit
wirklich etwas zu bewirken an der stelle will ich mal eine eine sache
loswerden weil das schreiben ja das schreiben ja so viele ja es gibt durchaus leute die sind
da gar nicht so scharf drauf dass sie eine hohe eigenverantwortung haben und flexibel sind und
was bewirken können sie wollen eigentlich nur hingehen arbeiten geld verdienen und wieder heim
gehen sie wollen gar nichts bewirken und deswegen das schreiben so viele ich meine für die meisten
wird es kein allzu großes
vorteil sein dass man irgendwie was bewirken kann die meisten leute wollen einfach geld verdienen
weil sie geld verdienen müssen durch flexible arbeitszeiten das kann das kann was gutes und
schlechtes heißen ja genau ist so es kommt es kommt halt auch auf den laden also bei mir ist
es persönlich jetzt kann ich kann ja immer nur von mir ausgehen ja ich habe da also je nach
so je nach umfeld aber ich bin der sache prinzipiell gar nicht abgeneigt habe also ich
gebe gerne meinen cent dazu wenn ich sehe dass irgendwas nicht funktioniert oder wo ich würde
oder das könnte man anders machen dann gebe ich gerne mann selbst senf dazu aber viele
lehnen wollen das irgendwie gar nicht weil wenn man 20 x was gesagt hat und 20 mal ist es im sand
verlaufen und 20 mal bekommst du keine keine rückmeldung oder irgendwas irgendwann hast du
wenig bock ja irgendwann das to b nicht bock noch mitzumachen war so was und das kann man an leuten
vorwerfen. Wir hatten
auch letztens so eine
Wir-werden-besser-Aktion
auf der Arbeit.
Da habe ich mich angemeldet.
Ich glaube, das habe ich euch schon erzählt, oder?
Da habe ich mich für angemeldet.
Und
da haben wir ein halbes Jahr
haben wir uns Dinge ausgedacht,
die man verbessern könnte
in einem
gewissen Bereich.
So, und jetzt
sie haben dann groß erzählt,
so nach dem Motto, ja, es werden alle Punkte angegangen
und jetzt kommt halt mit der
Zeit raus, dass sich halt
einfach nichts tut in dem Bereich. Das ist auch keinem
wirklich großartig interessiert. Also
eine Sache, die wir vorgeschlagen haben,
wurde gesagt, wollen wir überhaupt
nicht. Bei der anderen
Sache wird es jetzt genau anders gemacht, als
wir vorgeschlagen haben. Und eines der ersten
Sachen, die ich damals gefragt habe,
wo es drum ging,
wer mitmachen will, habe ich gefragt,
wie
ist denn da so die Rückendeckung bei dieser
Aktion? Weil ich habe schon viele Aktionen mitgekriegt
in dieser Richtung und die sind meistens
im Sand verlaufen. Wie ist es,
wie ist es denn diesmal? Und da waren
alle ganz euphorisch und haben alle erzählt,
so nach dem Motto, diesmal ist das anders, diesmal
haben wir hier von höchster Stelle Rückendeckung
und das soll jetzt passieren und soll jetzt sein.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, wisst ihr was, ich mache mal wieder mit.
Ja, aber jetzt ist bei mir die Motivation
erstmal eine Weile wieder weg.
Ja, und
ich glaube, es gibt viele Leute, die was bewirken wollen,
aber einfach keinen Bock mehr darauf haben.
Und es gibt
auch genug, die sagen, Leute, ich will einfach
Arbeit, mein Geld verdienen und ich will,
ich will gar nichts bewirken.
Ich will einfach meine Arbeit ordentlich machen
und Kohle verdienen und gut ist.
Ich sage ja auch immer, es ist nicht verkehrt,
wenn man sich mit seinem Arbeitgeber
identifizieren kann, also sprich, wenn man gut
findet, was sie machen oder wenn man
sich da irgendwie, wenn man sich so aufgehoben
fühlt, ja, das ist, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Es ist für die
Motivation mit Sicherheit auch
gut, aber es ist nicht
unbedingt notwendig. Also sprich,
man kann auch ohne Probleme irgendwo arbeiten
und Geld verdienen, ohne dass man den Laden
toll findet oder ohne, dass man toll findet, was
der jeweilige Laden macht oder dass man da irgendwie
dahinter steht. Man kann es einfach ganz pragmatisch
sehen und sagen, ich gehe da hin, um Kohle zu verdienen
und gehe dann halt, wenn es Zeit ist, wieder heim.
Das ist auch nichts
Verwerfliches dran. Es ist
beides vollkommen legitim.
Man muss dann aber, finde ich, auch gucken als Arbeitgeber,
dass man eben die Leute,
die wirklich dann auch was machen wollen und
sich einsetzen,
dass,
dass man denen dann aber auch
gewisse, dass man denen zumindest mal
Gehör schenkt, ja.
Und, weil sonst haben die irgendwann auch keinen Bock mehr.
Naja, gut.
Durch flexible Arbeitszeiten
und Orte, ja gut.
Flexible Arbeitszeiten
und Orte. Wenn die wirklich
was für, wenn die wirklich was
gemeint hätten, was für mich gut ist, dann hätten
sie geschrieben mit Homeoffice-Möglichkeit.
Dann, dann wüsste ich,
okay, da hat man was, was, was davon.
Ansonsten flexible Arbeitszeiten
und Orte,
klingt eher so, wie
man muss random ran,
eventuell Schichtarbeit und man weiß nicht genau
wo.
Gemeinschaft
und Wertschätzung des Einzelnen sowie Firmenfeiern
und Team. Okay.
Jetzt wissen wir schon mal genau,
wer diese Stellenanzeige geschrieben hat.
Entweder irgendein Management-Typ
oder irgendein Personalmensch,
der das wirklich geil findet.
Keiner in der IT,
den ich kenne, mag wirklich Firmenfeiern.
Team-Events ist so'n bisschen so'n bisschen 50-50, ja.
Aber Firmenfeier, so die, so die,
sag'n wir mal so, die Firmenfeiern, wo's dann
nicht drum geht, ähm,
wo's so so halbe, halbe
wir repräsentieren-Feiern sind, dann,
ne, die Fort- und Weiterbildung
unserer Mitarbeiter mit Großgeschämen auf
internationaler Entwicklung, so blablabla, blablabla,
blablabla, äh,
pfff,
ah ja,
ah ja, gut, das ist, äh,
irgendjemand hat im Chat grad geschrieben, ziemlich
generic, ja, liest sich ziemlich 015.
Okay, next.
Teamplayer.
Also, Leute, ganz ehrlich, das
wär nix, das wär nix für mich.
Sowohl von dem, was sie suchen,
als auch, was sie wollen.
Linux-Ubuntu-Server, easy, kann ich.
Aber ich komm' keine Schmerzen mit.
Kann ich wahrscheinlich, jetzt ohne,
ohne, ich weiß selbst nur, ob's stinkt,
aber wahrscheinlich besser, als
die meisten, die sich hier drauf bewerben. Aber alles andere,
kann ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung von Windows, keine Ahnung von Hyper-V,
keine Ahnung von Microsoft SQL,
keine Ahnung von Exchange, äh,
so gut wie keine Ahnung von, äh,
ESX-Administration, auch keine Ahnung von
vCenter, Citrix und
VM9. So, was bieten
sie denn? In einem dynamisch engagierten,
okay, das schreiben wir alle, spannende Aufgaben, blablabla,
blablabla, okay, das ist, äh, 0815,
ganz vergessen.
Next.
Die Servus-Technologie
GmbH.
Ah, ja.
Wer, wer kennt das nicht?
Wer, wer, wer kennt das nicht, ja?
Normal.
So steh' ich auch immer vor nem
Rack. Vor allem mit
nem Notebook auf, auf, auf den Fingerspitzen.
Die sieht, die sieht irgendwie
sehr streng aus, da hinten.
Das, das sieht nicht aus, wie jemand aus
der IT, das sieht eher so nach Prozessoptimierung
aus oder so.
Alter
ist das Wort, nee!
Oh, ja, hier. Das war sonst auch noch mal. Aber
was haben die hier?
Adobe Stock. Okay, das Zeug heißt schon
Hä?
Moment. Ich will das aufmachen, das da.
Wie?
Geht nicht?
Eieiei.
Ich wollte mir jetzt den Typ da angucken,
was der macht.
Was ist das? Die doppel
Null Agenten im Arbeitsbereich
IT-Dienstleistung.
Oh.
Okay. Vielleicht wird's ja noch
besser.
Und zwar ganzheitlich
und wertschöpfen. Das ist unser Ziel.
Dafür ziehen wir alle
an einem Strang am liebsten mit dir, weil du gerne
in unterschiedlicher IT-Umgebung unterwegs
bist. Vom Helpdesk bis
zum Monitoring.
Vom Helpdesk bin ich, äh,
ungern
unterwegs. Ehrlich gesagt.
Von
der Projektplanung, Kundenmedien bis zum Rollout.
Also, vier
ITler sind schon... Oh, ganze vier
Stück? Hui!
Huge!
Ja, kein Wunder, da musst du ja auch wirklich alles machen.
Mal davon
abgesehen, das kann
gar nicht, also das kann ganz gut
sein.
Es ist nicht, es ist nicht schlecht,
wenn man alles machen muss, pauschal.
Wenn es, wenn es nämlich wirklich nur vier,
nur vier Leute gibt
in der IT. Ich mein, ich weiß auch,
ich hab zwar keine Ahnung, wie die mit vier IT-Leuten,
die, die doppel Null Agenten
im Bereich IT-Dienstleistung
sein wollen,
passt irgendwie nicht so ganz zusammen, aber
okay, das kann gut sein.
Also, wenn man sich mit den Leuten gut versteht,
das muss
nichts Schlechtes sein, wenn man
wirklich bei jedem, bei jedem Mist,
so war das bei uns ganz am Anfang auch, ja,
wo ich noch Azubi war, da waren
vier Leute oder fünf Leute
oder so am Start. Du hast alles
irgendwie gemacht.
Das war gar nicht schlecht.
Das war gar nicht so übel.
Es kommt halt ein bisschen drauf an,
wie das Umfeld mit einem umgeht,
ja. Gehalt
weit über dem Durchschnitt.
Gleich was safen hier.
Vertrag unbefristet. Homeoffice
ab und an möglich. Und sonst
tolle Benefits
plus standortspezifische Feinheiten.
Rein Chrome laggt, also
bei mir laggt nix. Aufgaben.
Irgendwie klingen die Jobs
in der IT und Informations-Technologie immer
gleich. Das liegt, da haben sie
Recht, aber das liegt zum größten Teil daran,
dass mittlerweile nur noch
Personal-Buzzword-
Dinger von irgendwelchen
Personalleuten Buzzword-Anzeigen geschrieben werden,
wo du gar nicht genau weißt, was die eigentlich
wollen. Wie viel besser ist
es dann, wenn du gleich aus erster
Hand weißt, wie ein Tag bei uns aussieht.
Dein neuer Job ist entstanden,
weil unser Team Verstärkung braucht,
rund um die Themen IT-Infrastruktur, Systematik,
Immigration, Serverlandschaft, Projektarbeit,
Realisierung neuer Lösungen.
Dein künftiger Kollege Daniel sagt
dir, was er im Einzelnen
macht. ID,
Ideas,
Rich Prime, Dankeschön, POC.
Für diese Woche ist die Planung
für eine Migration der alten Lösung geplant.
Okay, es ist sehr
ultra-spezifisch.
Eine Planung für
eine Migration der alten Lösung. Ah ja, alles klar.
Der Terminverwunsch
steht heute an, um die offenen Punkte zu besprechen.
Der Chef,
beziehungsweise der Anspruch hervorragend ist
im Gespräch diskutiert und entschieden.
Nach dem Gespräch werden die
Systeme überprüft.
Irgendwie liest sich das voll wie
sowas, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Also damals, als es noch klein war.
Einfach fünf
Leute, die sich um jeden Scheiß
kümmern müssen und es irgendwie geht.
Nach dem Gespräch
werden die Systeme überprüft. Es gibt Klärungsbeamte.
Okay, das kommt vor. Schnell mal
einen Kollegen anrufen und fragen, was er dazu meint.
Weiter geht's. Die Kundendokumentation läuft
automatisch während der Arbeit
mit. Ich habe es noch nie
erlebt, dass eine Dokumentation auf
Automatisch passiert.
Zu den meisten Sachen gibt es gar keine Dokumentation.
Eine Zusammenfassung der
Arbeit kommt dann ins CRM
System. Warum ist das auf einmal so
laut? Gut zu wissen,
selten mal eine Reise- oder Rufbereitschaft
unsere Kunden sind regulär ansehen. Okay,
das ist, das ist, eigentlich
muss ich, ich finde die,
ich finde die Anzeige nicht schlecht.
Aus dem, aus
aus einem Grund.
Die versuchen erst gar nicht so auf.
Wir sind
Weltführer im Bereich XY
und Hyperscaler, Enabler, Technologien,
Multispeed Architekturen,
bla bla bla. Die sagen
einfach, wir sind
IT Dienstleister
für im Endeffekt
so Leute für alles, ja.
Ich finde die Anzeige gar nicht so
blöd. Aber wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich auch
nur
ähm
weil das halt so ist,
wie das, wie das
bei dem Laden war, wo ich meine Ausbildung angefangen
habe. Da war das halt mehr oder
weniger so, ja. Du hast
die Lizenz zur IT, oh Gott, bisschen
cringe geschrieben ist es ja schon.
Warum tippst du eigentlich ständig eine 1 und
überlöscht sie dann wieder? Da haben wir sogar
ein extra Kommando für, warum ich das mache.
Du hast die Lizenz, dein
Weg, IT-Studium, Weiterbildung,
Zertifizierung, ähm
Das einzige, was ich zu bieten habe, ist das da
und das ist seit 15 Jahren oder so
abgelaufen.
Oder noch länger, nee.
Seit, nee, nee, nee,
so lange nicht. Seit,
ähm, hab es seit 11 Jahren
abgelaufen oder so.
Hm, hm.
Deine Zufallanalytische Denkstelle
Deutsch, Englisch oder MS Office,
MS Office, oh ja, da sind sie bei mir genau richtig.
Ich glaube, dass
der Laden, also
so mein Bauchgefühl würde mir sagen, der Laden
ist gar nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube, der Laden ist gar nicht schlecht.
Ein solider Arbeitgeber.
Lockeres IT-Device,
wo die die Chemie stimmen.
Okay, bla bla bla bla.
Ich glaube, die sind gar nicht so übel.
Okay, Frankfurts Doc-Foto.
Moment.
Warum soll ich Teamviewer
runterladen?
Was hat das auf der Webseite zu suchen?
Download Teamviewer.
Haben die sich vertan mit dem
Icon da oben?
Das Icon soll dann nie im Leben, soll das Icon da oben hin.
Wir gehen jetzt erstmal
auf unsere Linux-VM.
Und gehen auf die Seite nochmal.
Ach.
Hier geht's.
Bei mir,
bei mir unter Windows ist die Seite kaputt.
Lol, weh.
Guck mal.
Bei mir ist die Seite kaputt.
Aber
unter Linux,
Firefox geht's.
Haben die, haben die SSA,
oh ne, ein abgelaufenes Zertifikat.
Please.
Yourserver.de?
Ja.
Okay.
Except.
Oh, okay.
So wirklich gut funktionieren tut's ja nicht, ja.
Drei Eistraßen und
wo ist das denn?
Wo ist das denn?
Sagt überhaupt nichts.
Ach, hier am Südbahnhof.
Ach, ne.
Doch, am Südbahnhof. Ach, da ist das.
Das ist ja voll um die Ecke.
Na gut, aber da will ich nicht hin, aber
ganz ehrlich, Leute.
Man merkt, dass die Anzeige
nicht einfach
ja, nicht, nicht, nicht einfach
irgendwie so nach so nur nach 15 Zeug
zusammen gedingst, zusammen
gewerkelt ist, ja.
Ich find die gar nicht schlecht.
Please, nochmal von eben.
Was, von Zeit zu Zeit?
Oh je.
Ja gut, da bin ich
natürlich nicht dabei.
Na. Wenn, wenn ich
Feierabend hab, dann geh ich heim und
treffe mich nicht erst noch zum Umdrück.
Weit über Durchschnitt.
Ich glaube, die sind gar nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube, die sind gar nicht so übel.
So, nächste.
Die, die, ganz ehrlich, die Grinser
auf dem Foto sprechen mich deutlich weniger an
als das hier.
Aber auch wenn Stockfotos sind,
ja.
Wenn die nicht mal ein richtiges Zertifikat
haben.
Das ist halt noch so ein richtiger,
so ein richtiger Frickelladen.
Ja. Da, da, da macht
jeder noch alles und jeder fuddelt überall dran rum.
Was nicht schlecht
sein muss.
Okay, was suchen die hier?
Die Caritas in Frankfurt.
Au.
Systemadministrator, Systemadministratorin.
Ah, wenigstens D.
Sonst wär jetzt die Anzeige gleich raus.
Suchst du für dich oder einfach so?
Einfach so.
Ich mein, wenn jetzt, wenn's das
irgendein mega geiles mal gibt,
würde ich mich da auch drauf bewerben
oder wenn's hier irgendwie was ergibt,
auch, aber ich such eigentlich nix.
Männchen stärken, Wege finden.
Blablabla.
Wohlfahrtsbande katholisch.
Oh ja, das ist ja genau das richtige für mich.
Weil ich ja so,
so unglaublich gläubig bin.
Ähm.
Blablabla, blablabla.
Citrix Server?
Windows?
Oh je, es ist, es ist Windows.
Dabei sind sie Pflege.
Use of Rechte, Vergabe, Active der Rechte.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, hör mir auf.
Wann hast du zuletzt Overwatch gespielt?
Oh, ein halbes Jahr oder so.
Ich hab mal zur Duo-Queue zur,
als, als, nicht Duo, als, als
Role Select rausgekommen ist, hab ich mal ein bisschen
paar Runden gespielt.
Nee, es ist Windows, das ist überhaupt nix für mich.
ITIL V3
Zertifizierung.
Weiche. Ähm.
Die sollten doch eigentlich wissen, wo der Teufel drinsteckt.
Als katholische,
als katholische, äh, Organisation,
wie was mit der katholischen Kirche
zu tun hat. Und wenn irgendwo der Teufel
drin ist, dann in ITIL V3.
Ein abgeschlossener Ausbilder, blablabla.
Sehr gute Kenntnisse, Praxiserfahrung,
sehr active, active
die
Rektorie.
NTFS, Rechte, Vergabe.
Okay, es ist Windows-Admin.
Es ist Windows-Admin.
Also definitiv nicht
für mich.
Oh, jetzt kommt GRIP. Nee, GRIP.
GRIP. Oh,
Ayayamusik, ja.
GRIP.
Achso, das bieten wir.
Das erste. Okay, Moment, ich guck nochmal.
Wenn's aufgeht.
Will nicht.
Ah, jetzt.
Genial.
Eine wertschätzende Unternehmenskunde
auf Grundlage des Christi im Endeffekt. Ey,
so schlecht ist das doch gar nicht.
Wenn's um
Nächstenliebe geht, ey.
Wenn die das wirklich machen, was
die hinschreiben, es gibt doch wirklich Schlimmeres.
Vergrütung nach
TVÖD. Was ist TVÖD?
ÖffentlicheDienst.info.
Okay, das heißt, man verdient nichts.
Man verdient schon was.
Ja.
Was? Man braucht
Bibelkenntnissen. Das wär's doch, ey.
Das wär doch geil.
Bibelkenntnisse.
Okay, next. Wir haben hier GRIP.
GRIP.
Wow.
Jobs.
Äh.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie
kann ich hier filtern?
Ich hab die Seite geprickt.
Drinnen.
Nein.
Nein. Wo kann man hier überhaupt...
Ich check hier nicht, was man da sortieren kann.
Wo kann man hier nach Zivilfiltern
auf aktuelle Stellen
Okay, okay. Auf aktuelle Stellen.
Aktuelle Stellen.
Ist schon ziemlich bescheuert, dass man das später nicht filtern kann, ne?
Ihre Interessen kämpfen.
Ah, hier. Ziviliker, ja.
Okay, und schon sieht die Seite gleich viel ekliger aus.
Okay.
Kirchenhilfkraft.
Und, und...
Und wo
kann ich jetzt suchen nach...
Scheiße. Das ist ja eklig, die Seite.
Entsäulungsgottes Höchste.
Natürlich.
Technology?
Okay, Fortnite. Kein Bock.
Was wollten wir noch gucken?
Ähm. Gab's noch was,
was wir gucken wollten?
Okay. Oh.
Jetzt.
Jetzt gibt's noch das Huge Money.
Maxmonks.
Warum Monks?
Warum nicht?
Behind you.
Ja, hinter mir steht mein
Mikrofonständer.
Offene Stellen.
Wer macht diese Seiten hier bitteschön immer?
Kein Wunder, dass du da nix findest.
Äh. Premader.
Kommt drauf an. Kommt drauf an, was man macht.
Kann man das nicht ordentlich
filtern nach irgendwas?
Was ist das denn hier?
IT-Administrator
für zentrale Netze.
Aha.
Achso. Man sollte vielleicht...
Man kann nicht immer nach Ort filtern, oder?
IT und Telekommunikation.
Boah.
Hinweis.
Das Referat.
RZLAN, WLAN und zentrale
Netzdienste.
Das klingt schon so...
so Beamten...
Behördenmäßig.
Also folgende Aufgabe erwarten
ich. Erstellen und pflegen von Konzepten für die zentrale Netze.
IP-Adressverkabe DHCP
und DNS und NTP.
Das ist nix, was man irgendwo reinschaut.
Äh.
Erstellung und Pflege von IPv4 und IPv6
Adresskonzepten.
Das klingt mal sehr...
lahm. Irgendwie.
Mindestens neun Jahre.
Hab ich locker.
Okay. Also.
Ach nee. Das ist nicht das, was man kriegt.
Sehr gut.
Was ist das für eine beknackte Anzeige?
Das ist eine total
beknackte Anzeige. Das sagt ja gar nix.
Achso. Doch. Hier.
Mit ihrer Bewerbung...
Zwei-Schicht-Betrieb. Okay.
Und tschüss.
Entgeltgruppe 12
TVÖD
Okay. Wir gucken mal
wenigstens, was man verdienen würde.
Entgeltgruppe
Ähm.
Was ist das da oben?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Was ist das?
Die Jahre?
Die Jahre, wo man
dabei ist? Was? Die Stufen?
Ja, aber da steht überhaupt keine Stufe dabei.
Ah. Nach Jahre.
Oh, das ist doch gar nicht so übel.
Aber das sind bestimmt keine 6 Jahre,
oder?
Das sind bestimmt keine 6 Jahre.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so ein komisches
System, wie
2 Jahre, 2 Jahre
und dann hier 3 Jahre
und hier 5 Jahre. Irgendwie so komisch.
Ja, genau. 15 Jahre.
Ja, genau. Irgendwie sowas.
Wobei, das hier geht.
Das hier geht in Ordnung.
Da muss man...
Das scheint ganz okay zu sein.
Ich meine,
es ist die Frage, sind es
12 Monatsgehälter, sind es 13, sind es
14 Monatsgehälter? Sind es wahrscheinlich 12?
12 ist halt...
Das ist halt wenig.
Das ist zu wenig.
Da kriegst du...
Wobei, es geht. Es geht eigentlich.
Für...
Wenn du einsteigst, wenn du einsteigst,
geht das doch. Das geht.
Na, wenn du einsteigst, dann kriegst du
42 km im Jahr.
Das ist für einen Einstieg absolut in Ordnung.
So schlecht ist das gar nicht.
Ich meine,
das hier ist natürlich schon
eine ganz andere Hausnummer, aber
ist okay.
Also, ich dachte, das ist schlimmer.
Das ist doch in Ordnung.
Also, ich habe jetzt eigentlich gedacht, man verdient da nichts.
Hoffentlich schaust du auch für den
richtigen Bereich. Achso. Aha.
Ach, stimmt.
Wahrscheinlich gucke ich falsch.
Ja. TVÖD
Bund muss man gucken.
Moment.
Äh.
12, Stufe 1.
Ah, okay.
Das sieht schon wieder ein bisschen...
Doch, ist doch das Gleiche.
Das ist okay.
Ich finde, das
macht eigentlich ganz...
Mein Eindruck ist ganz okay.
Ah.
45 km zum Einstieg
ist echt in Ordnung. Kann man nichts sagen.
Also, mir wurde gesagt,
mit einer Ausbildung kannst du maximal bis E9 kommen.
Na gut, hier steht eindeutig, es wird nach
nach Entgeltgruppe 12
berechnet. Und wenn da Entgeltgruppe
12 steht, dann muss da Entgeltgruppe
12 sein. Oder
sie sagen, klar, ich kann mich nicht gebrauchen.
Ähm. Beim BND
Da habe ich jetzt noch nicht geguckt. Was hat denn da
BND? BND Jobs.
Zeig mal her.
Haben wir noch Standort?
Pullach.
Der Teufel ist Pullach.
Junior Cyber-Sicherheitsanalyst.
License to Hack.
Konfiguration
und Administration von Rechnersystemen.
Arbeitsort Berlin. Ja, das wäre
für mich schon mal nix.
Da müssten die mir echt
viel bezahlen. Ich finde das immer
geil, ne? Berufliche Gleichstellung
und im gleichen Atemzug
sagt man, ja, aber, aber,
wir bevorzugen jemand.
Wo steht's, was es zu
verdienen gibt?
Ah, hier. Wie, das
ist doch noch weniger.
Das ist ja deutlich weniger als bei den
anderen. Ja, naja,
dann nicht. Gut, ich mein,
also gerade die hier, die müssen da auch ordentlich
was rüberwachsen lassen, weil die
brauchen Leute. Mindestlohnagenten
beim BND. Man muss,
naja, wenn man, wenn man Mindestlohnagenten
ist, dann ist man ja hoffentlich wenigstens
patriot und überzeugt, ja.
Dann macht man das auch umsonst.
So, bei der Gelegenheit.
Wie warm ist unser Raspberry eigentlich?
Okay, also Raspberry rechnet jetzt
seit dreieinhalb Stunden unter Volllast.
Dreieinhalb Stunden Volllast rechnet
er und er wird 55 Grad.
Ich glaube, man kann sagen,
was Nip hat, Nip hat mal
wieder gewonnen? Moment, Nip ist doch
nicht mal Nip. Nip ist doch jetzt
bei Dignitas, oder?
Die, die ehemaligen
IP-Leute. Okay, Ubuntu
power off, power off,
bam,
weg. In der Wirtschaft
lachst du die doch nach fünf Jahren aus.
Kommt drauf an. Ähm,
nix
dabei, wenn man, wenn man für,
wenn man einfach nur Basics macht und dafür ordentlich
Kohle kriegt. Also, wenn das wirklich,
ähm,
Stufe, was war das, Stufe 12 oder 13
ist, das hat jetzt
erstmal keinen so schlechten Eindruck gemacht von der
Kohle. Man müsste mal
gucken, in welchem zeitlichen Abstand das, das
dann passiert mit mehr Geld.
Aber so schlecht fand ich das jetzt gar nicht.
Äh, wie ist die M2 SSD
an die Raspberry Pi eingeschlossen? Äh, per Adapter
auf USB. So, Leute,
war ganz schön langer Stream. Guck mal hier, fünf
Stunden, 55.
So lang war ich lange nicht mehr on.
So, müssen wir noch dringend
irgendwas klären, Leute.
Gibt's noch was, gibt's noch was,
was Spannendes, was man noch,
was man noch besprechen müsste.
Wie ist das ausgegangen mit der Nextcloud?
Ähm,
es funktioniert ganz gut,
aber es fehlt noch so der Feinschliff.
Nächstes Video, ach.
Äh, AX7 habe ich mir
noch nicht überlegt, aber für meinen
YouTube-Channel eignen sich meine Livestreams nicht.
Das ist nicht das,
was die meisten Leute dort interessiert.
Doofe Frage, aber wie Ressourcen
lasse ich jetzt der Paket-Track so?
Meinst du meinen?
Meine komische,
unfertige,
du meinst nicht meinen, oder?
Du meinst nicht meinen komischen, unfertigen
Versand-Tracker. Doch,
der braucht so gut wie nichts an Ressourcen.
Was hältst du von Zertifikaten in der
TI, zum Beispiel CCNA?
Ja, kommt immer drauf an,
ob du welche, ob du mal an Leute
gerätst, die auf sowas stehen.
Ich persönlich find's ziemlich unnütz.
Ja.
Zumal es gerade wie bei Microsoft-Zertifikaten
halt teilweise
lächerlich ist, ne.
Wusstet ihr, dass bei einem Azure-Zertifikat
gezählt wird,
wie viele Klicks ihr im UI
braucht, ob ihr besteht oder nicht?
Du musst es exakt in Microsoft-Way
machen, ansonsten klickst du raus.
Das ist halt fair. Ich halte da wenig
von. Zusammenfassung
zum Thema Office 365 Alternative.
Ne.
Nicht wirklich. Keine, keine,
keine gute Alternative.
Also, es funktioniert, man kann zusammen
Dokumente bearbeiten, es fehlt aber
noch der Feinschliff irgendwo.
Welche Informatikbereiche würdest du machen,
wenn ich nicht das mache, was ich jetzt mache?
Dann würde ich was, dann würde ich
programmieren. Mittlerweile auf
Ich meine, wie gesagt, ich hab ja mal
bei einem Provider angefangen, ursprünglich.
Da hab ich auch meine Ausbildung gemacht.
So auf reine
Server-Administration-Geschichte hab ich
keinen Bock mehr. Helpdesk.
Naja, ich krieg's ja täglich
mit, ne. Ich sitz
ja auf der Arbeit in einem anderen
Büro.
Also in einem anderen Büro, als mein restliches Team
sitzt. Und dort, wo ich sitze, sitzt halt auch
unser First Level,
First Sec, so ne Mischung aus First
und Second Level Support.
Eigentlich ne Mischung aus First,
Second und Monitoring
Team. So ne
wilde Mischung sitzt da.
Und was da teilweise
für Leute anrufen, da hätt ich echt
keinen Bock drauf.
Ich mach da ab und zu mal,
lass ich mich dazu überreden, mal ans Telefon
zu gehen, wenn gerade mal alle weg müssen.
Um
manche Sachen,
ne, ganzen Tag müsste ich das
nicht machen.
Was machst du aktuell? Hab ich dem Video zugemacht.
Wenn's dich genau interessiert, kannst du dir
das hier angucken bei mir auf YouTube.
Ja, Easykiller, kann ich mir vorstellen.
First Level Support ist der größte Crap, den's gibt.
Vor allem, wenn man halt
jemand ist, der Leute nicht mag.
Ihr wisst ja, ich mag Menschen nicht. Und da ist First Level
Support kacke.
First Level Support für mich
ist, ähm,
für mich ne Zumutung und für den, der anruft,
ne Zumutung.
Den Chat, na klar, den Chat mag ich.
Der Chat mag ich.
Chat, Chat ist beste.
Nutzt ihr Azure DevOps?
Ja und ne.
Ähm, es wird bissl damit rum
gebastelt, aber nichts, wo man
sagen könnte, da laufen jetzt
super wichtige Sachen drauf.
Wie geht man am besten als
Oh, das ist ne gute Frage, da weiß ich nicht, ob ich
der Richtige für bin. Äh, wie geht man
am besten als angehender Informatiker
mit einer abgeschlossenen Ausbildung eine Gehaltsverhandlung?
Da bin ich glaub ich nicht der Richtige
für. Ich hätte da bisher
immer Glück. Ich krieg ja seit
letztem, seit letztem Jahr
Kollegen. Oktober,
also ich hab's ja auf Twitter geschrieben,
Oktober krieg ich ja, krieg ich ja
wieder mehr Kohle.
Und einfach nur, weil ich mal gesagt hab, es wird
mal wieder Zeit. Also ich hab da echt Glück.
Ich musste da noch nie so richtig knallhart
verhandeln hier.
So hier, BÄM, auf geht's, Leute.
Auf jeden Fall ist es nicht
verkehrt, wenn du weißt, was du kannst.
Das kann man so generell
durch die Bank weg eigentlich sagen.
Ja? Und vor allem, wenn du einschätzen
kannst, wie das halt
so im Verhältnis zu der Masse
der Leute ist. Also wenn du weißt,
die brauchen dich in dem Bereich und in diesem Bereich
bist du saumäßig gut und in diesem Bereich
gibt's halt auch nicht so viele Leute, die
ähnlich gut sind. Das ist zumindest schon mal
wichtig zu wissen.
Und meistens, doch ich kann
dir eine Sache
kann ich dir wirklich als Tipp geben,
meistens verhandelst du
gar nicht direkt mit dem, der dann
am Endeffekt wirklich unterschreibt,
dass du mehr Geld kriegst. Je nachdem, wie groß
die Firma ist, ja? Das muss man sagen.
Also, das kann aber
durchaus sein, dass du nicht direkt mit dem verhandelst,
der ganz am Ende wirklich
unterschreibt, dass du mehr Geld kriegst, aber
derjenige,
der dem verkaufen muss,
dass du mehr Geld kriegst.
Also sprich, wenn du mit deinem
sagen wir Teamleiter jetzt über mehr Geld
verhandelst, dann ist es nicht dein Teamleiter,
der am Ende und wirklich
konkret final unterschreibt,
ähm,
dass du mehr Geld kriegst, aber
du musst
weniger deinen Teamleiter überzeugen, weil
wahrscheinlich ist der sogar schon überzeugt.
Du musst ihm aber gute Argumente geben,
wie er seinen Chef davon
überzeugen kann, dass
du mehr kriegen sollst.
So, und die musst
du eigentlich überzeugen und das machst du am besten,
indem du quasi
deinem Chef gutes, gutes
Material zur Verfügung
stellst, wie er das
gut verkaufen kann.
Weil er freut sich letztendlich auch, wenn er sich
nichts aus den Fingern saugen muss, ja.
Weil es ist für deinen Chef auch blöd,
zu sagen, so hier gibt nichts, ich kann
nichts machen und so. Das macht er meistens
auch, also je nachdem, was du für einen hast, wahrscheinlich
auch nicht gerne.
Wenn der gute,
wenn
der stichhaltige Sachen weitergeht,
kann es für alle Beteiligten
am besten.
Ja, also Quai, bei mir ist es das letzte Mal auch ähnlich
gewesen. Ich habe auch nur mal so ganz grob
gesagt, so nach dem Motto, es wird
mal wieder Zeit, hier, das, das und das.
So mehr oder weniger zwischen Tür und Angel.
Wir haben da gar nicht wirklich großartig drüber gesprochen.
Und irgendwann, kurz bevor
ich heimgehen will, kommt der Arne und drückt mir einen Umschlag
in die Hand und sagt, hier, guck mal rein.
Und ich sage, ah ok, ah cool, gib mir Geld.
So ungefähr lief
meine letzte Gehaltsverhandlung.
Deswegen, ich bin nicht der Richtige,
der jetzt darum geht, wie man richtig krass verhandelt.
Aber ich kann mich bei mir eh nicht großartig
beschweren. Ich meine, die Kohle ist jetzt nicht
so, dass man sagen würde, ähm,
es ist
voll übertrieben viel,
aber für
das, was man,
für das, was von einem
verlangt wird,
und so das, so
das Gesamtpaket,
ist das wirklich in Ordnung, was man kriegt.
Ich habe es euch ja letztens
mal gezeigt, ich weiß,
ich weiß es ja nicht, also ich,
ich kann mir sagen, ich, ich
weiß nicht, wie viel ich verdiene.
Ich muss jedes Mal nachgucken, und wir haben uns ja letztens
das angeguckt,
im Stream,
das, was zumindest
im aktuellen Tarifvertrag drinsteht,
das heißt,
die, die dabei gewesen sind, wissen es ungefähr,
das ist ein Ticken mehr, als das, was im Tarifvertrag
steht, aber
das ist schon mal eine ganz gute Hausnummer.
Legst du dein
Geld an? Ja,
aber nicht
so, nicht so gut, wie ich könnte.
Ich habe viel zu viel Geld rumliegen,
sagen wir es mal so.
Ich mache
ein paar Sachen, ja, aber ich müsste
viel mehr Sachen machen.
Das meiste liegt einfach nur
sinnlos rum. Ja, Jiggly,
das ist, das ist wohl wahr,
außer, außer du bist damit zufrieden,
ja, und hast keinen Bock, dich weiter damit zu beschäftigen.
So war es bei mir halt zum letzten Mal.
Einfach alles in ETFs,
da habe ich tatsächlich auch schon dran gedacht.
Aber nicht alles.
Bei mir kommt aber noch dazu,
was, was
auch bei mir, seitdem ich das mal
realisiert habe, für ein sehr
so ausgeglichenes
Leben irgendwie sorgt, ja, also wo ich
mir wenig Gedanken machen muss, ist einfach,
ich habe immer
noch die Möglichkeit, mit
meinem YouTube, Twitch,
Raffling, sonst was, Geschiss, Kohle
zu machen, und man verdient ja auch
immer noch ein bisschen was dabei, das ist schon mal
nicht schlecht, und ich verdiene fast von der Arbeit.
Das heißt, ich bin auf keines von beiden
so richtig krass
hundertprozentig angewiesen, dass das jetzt
äh,
äh, dass ich damit
quasi alles machen könnte, was ich wollte, weil ich habe ja immer noch
was anderes, und außerdem
ist bei mir ja auch so,
ich,
ich brauche nicht so viel Kohle.
Also ich muss
mir keine Rolex kaufen, ja.
Könntest du
zu 100% von YouTube und Twitch leben? Nein.
So gerade definitiv nicht.
So garantiert nicht.
Will ich auch gar nicht.
Will ich gar nicht.
Ich will das gar nicht so ernst nehmen,
wie manche halt auf YouTube. Guck mal,
wie, der eine Typ letztens,
ne, wisst ihr, wo das hinführt,
wenn die Leute quasi auf YouTube angewiesen
sind und YouTube zu ernst nehmen? Dann führt
es zu solchen Ausgeburten, wie der eine, der
den Tod seiner Freundin gefakt hat, um
Videoclicks zu generieren. Habt ihr das
mitgekriegt? War das nicht, das war
letztes Jahr schon, glaub ich, ne? Erinnert ihr euch?
Letzten Jahres oder so.
Der irgendwie gefakt hat, dass seine Freundin gestorben ist
und die Familie der Freundin hat auch gesagt, sie ist
gestorben und, ähm,
dann hat er irgendwie noch ein Video gemacht, wo er
am Grab war und geweint hat,
wo man sich auch denken kann, Alter, wie gestört kann
man sein? Danach hat er noch ein Video
gemacht, wo er versucht hat, irgendwie ihren Geist
zu kontaktieren und sowas. Solche
Ausmaße nimmt das an, wenn man
YouTube zu ernst nimmt und komplett von YouTube
abhängig ist. Genau,
du musst es halt machen. Das ist egal, ob du
Fulltime YouTube Mensch bist,
Fulltime Twitch Mensch bist, das ist
vollkommen wurscht. Du musst halt.
Und sobald man muss,
ähm,
ja, stellen sich,
ist es halt, wird's halt schnell von Spaß
zu Stress, ja.
Viele Sachen, die man gerne macht
und auch oft und lange gerne macht,
sobald man die wirklich immer
machen muss,
fängt's an, wo es keinen Bock mehr macht.
Du kannst auch mal öfters. Ja, können
könnte ich schon.
Deswegen finde ich es nicht verkehrt, so wie
es bei mir gerade ist.
Ich verdiene
mit vier Tage Woche, also ich bin
vier Tage auf der Arbeit, verdiene ich ganz okay.
Ach, ich mein, reich
wirst du davon nicht, aber es ist schon in Ordnung.
Und, also, das Gesamtpaket
ist echt okay.
Und, ähm,
je nachdem, was ich so YouTube und Twitch und
sonst was mäßig mach, gibt's ja auch nochmal
ganz gut Kohle. Deswegen,
ich bin da wirklich sehr
ausgeglichen, was so meine finanzielle Geschichte
angeht. Dazu kommt noch, dass
ich ja das Haus hier, meine Mutter hat
das Haus vom Opa geerbt, aber
im Prinzip hab ich ein Haus, ja.
Ähm,
ich bin da, was
die finanzielle Sache angeht, bin ich,
fühl ich mich echt entspannt.
Viermal acht Stunden,
nee, viermal
7,48 sind's, glaub ich.
Wie ist das eigentlich
mit der Rente, wenn du nur
Teilzeit arbeitest, zahlst du freiwillig? Nö.
Mach ich nicht, aber ich hab noch
ich hab ja, äh,
bei meinem Arbeitgeber
noch, ähm, so ne, so ne betriebliche
Altersvorsorge abgeschlossen, wo
die nen Teil bezahlen und ich nen Teil bezahle.
Und,
damit, von da krieg ich quasi eh
schon fast mehr Geld als von meiner normalen Rente.
Wenn ich mal in Rente geh, gibt's eh kaum was.
Kannst voll knicken, ja.
Ähm,
ich muss euch aber ehrlich sagen, also ich hab
nicht vor, bis, bis, äh,
was auch immer Rentenalter ist, wenn ich mal in Rente geh,
bis 70 oder so zu arbeiten.
Garantiert nicht.
Also,
wenn das so läuft, wie ich mir das aktuell
vorstelle, mit 50 ist Schluss.
Wie gesagt, ich brauch
auch nicht viel Kohle, ja.
Genau. Dann wär ich
Fulltime-Streamer. Wie soll das
klappen? Naja, aus der Kombination, dass ich erstens
nicht wahnsinnig viel Kohle brauch,
dass ich ein Haus hab, und dass
ich auch schon ordentlich Kohle mittlerweile auf dem Konto
liegen hab, die ich mal anlegen müsste,
ich weiß, ähm,
da müsste ich eigentlich über die Runden kommen.
Ich mein, ich kann keine riesen Sprünge
machen und irgendwie, äh,
jeden zweiten
Wochenende irgendwo hinfahren, oder so,
oder hinfliegen, oder so.
Okay, ich mein, ich hab
mittlerweile,
sag mal, wenn ich das, wenn ich mal, wenn ich die
beiden, wenn ich die beiden Konten
zusammenzähle,
hab ich
ungefähr, über den Daumen gepeilt,
ungefähr 100k,
ungefähr,
bisschen aufgerundet, so in dem Dreh,
ähm,
mittlerweile schon, schon quasi,
ja,
mehr angespart, könnte man's eigentlich auch schon nennen.
Zwar nicht alles, was da
um, was, es liegt jetzt nicht alles auf dem Konto rum,
ähm,
ein paar Sachen hab ich investiert,
ein paar Sachen hab ich auch verdient,
aber das größte Teil liegt halt noch rum,
und, ähm,
wann, bis ich in Rente, oder
bis ich, es sind ja noch 15 Jahre hin,
bis dahin hab ich dann noch mal ein bisschen was
angesammelt,
und ich hab ein Haus,
und ich kann, ich verdien ja dann immer noch ein bisschen
hier auch was mit meinem Online-Kram,
also meine Hoffnung sind,
dass ich über die Runden komm.
Irgendwann kommen die Kinder
und die Kohle brauchen. Tja, Leute,
sollte ich mal irgendwann auf die,
in der, mich in der geistigen Umlachtung
befinden, doch noch Nachwuchs zu zeugen,
dann hab ich Pech.
Dann hab ich gelitten.
Einfach mal mit dem Finanzthema beschäftigen. Ja, da hast du vollkommen
recht, ähm,
es ist ein Thema, was mich halt
nicht interessiert, und was mir voll auf den Sack geht,
aber ich weiß, dass ich mich damit beschäftigen muss,
weil die Kohle
sonst, ne, nicht weg ist, aber
unsinnigerweise
weniger wird.
Kinderarbeit, easy, genau.
Ne,
aber das hab ich nicht vor, ähm,
das hab ich echt nicht vor,
Nachwuchs zu zeugen.
Erstens,
es fehlt ja schon an, es fehlt ja schon an
grundlegenden Voraussetzungen.
Erstens,
will ich auf gar keinen Fall.
Zweitens,
fehlt mir auch jemand, mit dem ich es
auch nur in Erwägung ziehen würde,
Nachwuchs zu zeugen,
beziehungsweise umgedreht, auch jemand, der es
mit mir in Erwägung ziehen würde, Nachwuchs
gibt's ja aktuell nicht.
Also insofern, die Frage
stellt sich bei mir grad weniger.
Wie alt bin ich denn? 35.
Exquisite.
So,
ok.
Ja,
ich bin quasi
nur auf
die Weihnachtsfeier,
genau das ist es.
Ist das Chromium? Ja, ist es.
Mein,
bei mir liegt's eigentlich hauptsächlich
daran, dass ich ultra faul bin,
was zwischenmenschliche Interaktion angeht.
Ist halt nun mal so.
Was hältst du von Chromium aktuell?
unmotiviert, was zwischenmenschliche Sachen
angeht. Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Ich war das schon immer,
aber noch nie so
unmotiviert.
Sobald sich auch nur ein bisschen was
abzeichnet, was eventuell was werden
könnte, kümmer ich mich
einfach nicht mehr drum.
Ich hab euch doch vor, wann war das?
Vor zwei Jahren von dem Weihnachtsgrill
erzählt, oder?
Können sich vielleicht noch die einen oder anderen dran erinnern.
An das Weihnachtsgrill.
Warum ist da nichts draus geworden?
Zum größten Teil, weil ich mich
absolut nicht drum gekümmert hab.
Weil ich das einfach komplett
ignoriert hab. Kümmer dich drum, du wirst
das mal bereuen. Warum?
Warum soll ich das bereuen?
Wie können wir dich für solche Sachen motivieren?
Warum solltet ihr mich für sowas motivieren?
Der Cute Chat.
Spenden.
Genau.
Bei einer Million Abos
war ich dann ein Speed Dating
Livestreamer.
Wir möchten dich glücklich sehen. Ich bin glücklich.
Ich brauch kein FPS-Grill.
Wenn ich da irgendwie das
Bedürfnis großartig verspüren würde,
würde ich mich wahrscheinlich auch mehr
um zwischenmenschliche Sachen kümmern.
Und das nicht einschlafen lassen
wie beim Weihnachtsgrill vor zwei Jahren.
Aber ich hab ja den Chat.
Eine Million Abos
sollte nicht so gut kosten.
Das gibt es ja Leute, für die sind inzwischen
Menschliches iPhone.
Ja, ich finde das ultra anstrengend.
Ich find zwischenmenschlich dann ultra anstrengend.
Hast du schon von Anytime
Das sagt mir irgendwas.
Das sagt mir irgendwas. Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Das hab ich mir letztens angeguckt.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr, was es ist.
Was ist es denn? Ich hab keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Ich erkenne es nicht. Ich check's nicht.
Übrigens, was wir uns demnächst auch mal im Stream
angucken müssen, ist
ähm
Das ist ne neue, das ist von den, soweit ich das gelesen hab von den Gründern von NodeJS
Die haben jetzt ne neue JavaScript
ähm
nicht Runtime, das ist die Google Runtime
ne neue JavaScript
ähm
ja Runtime
äh
rausgebracht
die Native TypeScript kann
und die angeblich
viele Vorteile gegenüber NodeJS haben soll
das wollte ich mir mal angucken
ob das wirklich was dran ist, dass das so
huge ist.
Super, how to talk, oh, das kenn ich, das war doch
mal, vor einer Weile haben sie das doch alle gestreamt.
Vor einer Weile haben sie das
doch mal alle gestreamt.
Soft, Lunan69,
Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
High IQ Sub.
So,
ähm,
ich mach jetzt ganz schön lang on für meine Verhältnisse, ne?
Du streamst ja immer noch,
ich weiß auch nicht, was da mit mir los ist heute.
Das ist ganz schön, ganz schön lang, ne?
Ganz schön, ganz schön lang.
Guck mal, 6 Stunden 21.
Was ist da los?
Exquisite Livestream, excellent.
Ich hab letztens auf der Arbeit
wieder irgendein,
irgendwelche Twitch Memes von mir gegeben, ich krieg's
aber nicht mehr zusammen.
Ich hab irgendwie, wie war denn das?
Ja, Azubi ist
zu mir gekommen, ich hatte ja vorletzte
Woche mal wieder Azubi, nächste Woche übrigens wieder.
Ähm,
der ist mit irgendeinem Problem
zu mir gekommen, hat irgendwas nicht hingekriegt.
Und ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen.
Aber ich glaube, ich hab irgendwie sowas gemacht, wie,
äh, also ich hab ihm irgendwie gezeigt, wie es geht,
hab irgendwas eingetippt,
und beim Enter drücken, hab ich dann gesagt,
ah, excellent, five head.
Er hat halt null reagiert,
ja? Der hat sich wahrscheinlich gedacht,
was, was redet er?
Vielleicht hab ich's einfach nicht richtig verstanden.
Das passiert mir öfters mittlerweile, wenn ich so in
Gedanken bin und mir nicht auffällt,
dass ich quasi nicht vor
dem Rechner sitze und Twitch Chat vor mir
habe, dass ich manchmal Twitch Chat,
äh, Sachen sage.
Cringe vom
Boomer-Ausbilder, ja?
Weil es ja auch so richtig
Boomer-Style ist, excellent five
head zu sagen, ne? Ist ja, ist ja
allseits bekannt, dass
Boomer gerne Twitch gucken.
Während der Arbeitszeit mit dem Chat sprechen.
Ja, sagen wir nichts, es gibt teilweise echt lustige
Situationen, ne? Ich hab
letztens, ich hab letztens auf Twitch,
äh, nicht auf Twitch, auf Twitter geschrieben,
alter, sie sind gemäß der,
einer der Kollegen neben mir,
der schläft jetzt schon seit vier Stunden,
und
dann hat danach jemand,
der auch
neben mir sitzt,
per Skype
geantwortet, so nach dem Motto,
es sind nicht erst nur, sind nicht, ne,
irgendwie, es sind nicht nur vier Stunden,
es wär viel mehr. Also es ist schon teilweise
echt komische Wege, wie Nachrichten
nehmen mittlerweile, die man irgendwo hinschreibt,
ja? Und ich
muss manchmal echt aufpassen, weil
ich weiß, dass jetzt die ein oder andere
von der Arbeit halt auch das lesen.
Ja, Heinrich, kann schon
sein, ne? Mich irritiert das übrigens
immer noch, weil mein Azubi heißt
auch Heinrich. Während der
Arbeitszeit über den Chat sprechen, ja.
Der Chef guckt die Videos, ja.
Manche.
Ich hab sogar irgendwo,
irgendwo, ich hab mich, ich hab mich schon
lange mal überlegt, das müsste man eigentlich erst nochmal bringen,
ich hab irgendwo noch
einen USB-Stick, da ist
ein Battlefield 3 Gameplay von meinem
Chef drauf.
Heli, äh, ich glaub Kark Island
HeliStells. Irgendwo hab ich
noch einen USB-Stick. Das ist, der ist
zehn Jahre alt oder so.
Den, das müsste ich echt mal
ausbuddeln, das Teil.
Hast du doch schon hochgeladen, was? Echt?
Hab ich?
Ne, ne, hab ich
nicht. Ne, das kann ich,
das glaub ich nicht, dass ich das schon hochgeladen hab.
Ich wohne in Frankfurt, ja.
Also Leute,
sechseinhalb Stunden on gewesen.
Ich glaube,
jetzt reicht's. Gibt's irgendjemand, den wir
hosten können?
Ist der Friseur vielleicht am Start? Ei, Frisi.
Ist der Frasier am Start?
Nein.
Ähm.
Gibt keinen, den ich hosten
kann. Gut.
Also Leute,
wir sehen uns.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.